hey everyone welcome to simply launch
youtube channel in this session we will
be learning the complete software
testing
but before we begin i would like to take
a quick confirmation from the viewers if
i'm clearly audible and the screen is
visible if yes kindly type yes in the
chat section and if there are any
problems that we could rectify please do
let us know in the chat section
all right i see a lot of positive
responses from our viewers thank you now
i think it's clear to get started so
before we get started with software
testing i would like to tell you guys
that we have daily updates on multiple
technologies so if you are one of those
tech geeks in a continuous hunt for
latest technological trends then
consider getting subscribed to our
youtube channel and don't forget to hit
that bell icon to never miss an update
from simply learn now without further
ado let's get started with the agenda
for today's session
so at first we will get started with
selenium and in selenium section we will
learn the advent of selenium then
followed by that we will understand what
exactly is selenium and the
technicalities of selenium followed by
that we will understand the selenium
tool suite then we will learn how to
install selenium in our local systems
then we will learn the selenium ide
tutorial followed by that we will get
started with selenium webdriver tutorial
so once we are done with the selenium
webdriver tutorial we will get started
with xpath and selenium webdriver
followed by that we will learn selenium
chrome driver tutorial
once we are done with the selenium
chrome driver tutorial we will get
started with test ng annotations then we
will have a head on head comparison with
selenium and qtp followed by that we
will go through selenium jobs and salary
trends in the current id industry
and finally to make things interesting
we carried out a survey on the major
testing software companies and collected
some most frequently asked interview
questions based on selenium now this
will be helpful for your software
testing career so followed by selenium
we have another tool that is j meter so
we will get started with j meter
installation then we will learn
performance testing followed by that we
will learn j meter load testing and
advancing ahead we will learn about j
meter api testing and finally in j meter
part we will learn the j meter script
recording so once we are done with the j
meter script recording and j meter tool
we will get ahead and learn the chain
gains
so in jenkins part we will have a brief
tutorial about what exactly is devops
where we will understand the
fundamentals of devops so that we have a
clear idea what we are dealing with and
why we are using jenkins and software
testing followed by that we will learn
the critical part of ci cd pipeline then
we will get started with what is jenkins
and then we will learn how to install
jenkins in our local systems once we are
done with the installation part we will
go through continuous integrations in
collaboration with jenkins and finally
to make things interesting we are
including some most frequently asked
critical jenkins-based interview
questions
so with that we are done with the agenda
and i hope i made myself clear with the
agenda now without further ado let's get
started with the first part that is
selenium now over to our training
experts
hey there welcome into the world of
selenium if you're going to embark on a
journey of automation i promise you this
is the right place to start so let me
take you on the first lap of this
journey this is a video tutorial what is
selenium from simply learn what is in it
for you before you start understanding
any automation tool it's good to look
back into what manual testing is all
about what are its challenges and how an
automation tool overcomes these
challenges challenges are always
overcome by inventing something new so
let's see how selenium came into
existence and how did it evolve to
become one of the most popular web
application automation tool selenium
suite of tools selenium is not a single
tool it has multiple components and we
will be looking into each of them as you
know every automation tool has its own
advantages and limitations so we will be
understanding the advantages and
limitations of selenium and how do we
work around it selenium jobs and salary
very important isn't it you are here to
learn selenium you definitely want to
know what's the market demand on the
skill what what you will be once you are
skilled on this automation tool so what
we will do we'll just discuss some stats
on the job market related to test
automation and selenium in particular
all right so let's get started manual
testing and its challenges what is
manual testing manual testing mainly
involves physical execution of test
cases against various application and to
do what to detect bugs and errors so as
a definition if you can say it is one of
the primitive methods of testing a
software execution of test cases without
using any automation tools it does not
require the knowledge of any automation
tools and can practically test any
application this could be as simple a
definition can be let's do one thing
let's take an example right before we
start understanding why what are the
challenges of manual testing and why we
have to really look into any automation
tools let's take a simple example say we
have a simple use case as a user i want
to log into my web application using
username and password a very common use
case isn't it and this is a common use
case for any kind of web application
under test now let's say for example i
have a web application here say i have
this
community.simplylearn.com for me to
actually enter into this application
what i need to do is first log into this
application so this is a simple login
page which accepts a user id or an email
id a password and you click on the login
now as a tester you would write multiple
test cases to test this use case for
example you will have multiple data test
cases like valid credentials invalid
credentials null value and so on you
will also test multiple links on this
page probably the forget password link
the sign up now so whatever links are
made available you're going to test that
then you will say it as this check box
so you will check the remember me
functionality and when you log in back
again you want to validate if all your
previous data are filled up you will
also check for error messages on an
invalid login you will do accessibility
testing you will also do a performance
on this page like say for example
response time after you click on login
button and so on so while you are doing
a manual testing literally you can do
any kind of test you want so this is
what you do in the first place and then
you start executing these test cases one
by one you will find bugs your
developers are going to fix them and you
will need to re-run all these test cases
again and again until all your bugs are
fixed and your application is ready to
ship now this is a very simple use case
now let's look at a little complex use
case now say you have an account
creation form like this so i have this
online pan application form right this
is still a simpler form i would say now
look at the amount of data you need to
fill here each and every field you need
to test and you need to test this with
hundreds of transactions because you're
going to have those kind of data sets
with you and then you're going to repeat
them again and again until you are
satisfied that your application is
working as per it is designed so now if
you go back to our presentation now this
brings us to the first demerit of the
manual testing and what it is this is
very time consuming process and hence
it's going to get very boring for any
manual tester also it is more error
prone the risk of error is pretty high
why because it is done manually and
human mistakes are bound to happen
requires presence of tester all the time
since its manual execution tester's
presence is required all the time one
needs to keep doing manual steps over
and over again and hence he needs to be
sitting in front of his pc manual
creation of logs and repositories
creating manual reports grouping them
formatting them so that they are like a
good looking reports sending those
reports manually to all the stakeholders
say collecting logs from the various
machines after you execute the test
cases consolidating all those results
and logs right creating repositories
maintaining them wow this is a huge long
list of mundane tasks one needs to do
and this you need to do a do again and
again until your testing is completed
right so this is going to be a manual
process and it's going to be very
tedious and as i said it is also error
proof limited scope the scope of manual
testing is very limited for example say
regression testing ideally you would
want to run all the test cases which you
have written but since it's a manual
process you would not have the luxury of
time to execute all of them and hence
what you do you will pick up choose your
test cases and then execute that way you
are kind of limiting the scope of
testing also say working with large
amount of data which is manually pretty
impractical what about performance
testing so you want to say collect
certain metrics on various performance
measures as a part of your performance
testing you want to simulate certain
multiple loads on your application which
is under test hence performing this
manually is definitely not feasible and
to top it all the say you're working in
an agile model where your code is being
churned out by developers say every week
testers are building their test and they
are executing them as and when the bills
are made available to them for testing
now this happens iteratively and hence
you will need to run all the test cases
which you have created multiple times
during your development process and
doing this manually is going to become
definitely very tedious and boring and
is this really effective way of doing it
not at all so what do we do we automate
it so this tells us why we want to
automate one one is for the faster
execution two to be less error prone and
the most importantly to help you run
your test cases frequently as many times
as you want so there were many tools
available in the market today for
automation so one such tool is selenium
advent of selenium much before selenium
there were various tools in the market
like rft qtp just to number few popular
ones selenium was introduced by a
gentleman called jason huggins way back
in 2004. he was an engineer at
thoughtworks he was working on a web
application which needed frequent
testing and he realized the inefficiency
manual testing his application
repeatedly so what he did was he wrote a
javascript program that automatically
controlled the browser actions and he
named it as javascript test runner he
also made this open source which later
was renamed as selenium core and this is
how selenium came into existence since
then selenium has become one of the most
powerful tool to test web application so
what is selenium selenium is the most
popular and widely used automation tool
for automating your web application it
enables us to test web application on
all kind of browsers like ie chrome
firefox safari edge opera and even the
headless browser selenium is an open
source and it's platform independent the
biggest reason why people are preferring
this tool is because it is free of cost
whereas the qtp and rft which i
mentioned earlier are the chargeable
tools selenium is also a set of tools
and libraries to facilitate automation
of web application it is not a single
tool it has multiple components in it
which we will be seeing in detail in
some time and all these tools together
they help us test the web application
you can run selenium scripts on any
platform it is platform independent as
and why it is platform independent
because it is developed in javascript
it's very common for manual testers not
to have in-depth programming knowledge
so the selenium has a record and replay
back capability and this tool is called
as selenium ide which can be used to
create a set of actions as a script and
then you just have to replay the script
so mainly this is used for demo purposes
because selenium itself is such a
powerful tool and it offers so rich
functionality you would want to be in a
position to take the advantage of all
its future however if you have testers
who do not have enough of programming
knowledge to start with there is still
this id which is a record replay tool
which you can use to create your test
scripts it also provides support for
different programming languages like
java python c-sharp ruby and so on so
you can literally write your test
scripts in any language you like or
which you know of so one need not again
know a complete in-depth or an advanced
knowledge of any of these languages
selenium supports different operating
systems and browsers it supports windows
max linux and say if you want to run
your test on ubuntu machines yes that is
also possible it's on any platform of
your choice selenium you can run the
test cases selenium suite of tools so
now let's go little more deeper into the
selenium so as i said it is a suite of
twos and these are the major components
of the selenium selenium ide selenium
remote control which is in short called
as rc selenium web driver and selenium
grid from selenium 3.0 version onwards
you will not find the remote control
anymore because it has been deprecated
but you still have your id web driver
and grid components now let's take a
deeper look into each of these
components and understand how they
function in this suite of tools selenium
integrated development environment which
is called as selenium ide so it is the
most simplest tool in the suite of
selenium it's an integrated development
environment it has a record and playback
functionality and it's very very simple
and easy to use too however it is mainly
used as a prototyping and not used for
creating the actual automation for your
real-time projects why because of its
own limitations since it's just a record
and replay tool so this ide is available
as a firefox plugin and a chrome
extension so either you can use firefox
or the chrome browser to record your
test scripts the commands created in the
scripts where you are going to record
are these commands are called selenius
commands and these are the commands
which interact with your browser you can
also write some of these commands
manually while you're recording your
scripts and we'll see how to do that
when we talk about the id in detail and
it is again a platform independent so
you can deploy id on any platform of
your choice so you can have it on your
windows linux and macros however the
only requirement is you should have
either chrome or firefox browser support
on that particular platform earlier
selenium ide was only a firefox
extension it died with the firefox
version 54 or i55 i guess so id was not
supported from the 55 version onwards
and this was sometime during 2017.
however very recently all new brand
selenium ide has been launched by apply
tools and they have made it cross
browser that is it is available both on
chrome and firefox now so you can
install this extension as a chrome
extension or as an add-on on your
firefox browser it's a completely
revamped version which was done by apply
tools they literally rewrote the
complete code and now they have made it
available on the github under the apache
2.0 license and it also comes with many
new features now like reusability of
test cases it has a better debugging
technology now and most importantly it
supports parallel test execution it has
introduced an utility called selenium
side runner that allows your test cases
to run on any browser so you can create
your automation using your ide on chrome
or firefox however through the side
runner from your command prompt you can
execute any of your test cases on any
browser of your choice and thus by
achieving your cross browser testing you
can also run parallel testing using grid
without writing any specific code to do
this again this can be done using the
selenium side runner and having the grid
installation done so let's look at how
ide looks like and what are its
components are and how do we work with
ide let's go to the firefox browser now
and launch the ide and see how the id
looks so let me go to my firefox now on
this browser if you can see here there
is an icon here which says selenium id
and this appears after you go ahead and
install the selenium id plugin so now
i'll just go click on this and then i
already have a project created so this
is the ide window which gets open for me
i have a pre-recorded script here and
what the script does is i just open
amazon dot in website and i am searching
for the product iphone also i have an
assertion statement here which asserts
for the webpage title and then i'm
closing the browser so let's first
execute the script and see how it works
and then we will get into the details of
what are the different components
available on this id so for me to
execute what i will do is it id has a
very beautiful feature here to control
the speed of the execution so what i'll
do is i'll reduce the speed a little bit
so that you should be able to see the
complete execution step by step now to
execute the script i'll just go here and
say run current test so this opens the
firefox window and the amazon dot in
website it should search for iphone
product now then it is going to do the
title assertion and close the process so
if you look here all the statements look
in green now so that means every step
has been executed successfully and there
are no errors so now let's look at the
components of this id so the first
component which you need to understand
is how do you record the test so there
is a start recording button made
available to you clicking on which you
can launch any website of the
application under test and you can start
recording your steps and once you have
recorded you can use this play button
which is nothing but your run current
test button to execute your test so if
you want to execute multiple tests then
you have an option to do so here which
is run alt test this particular window
what you're seeing here right so this is
the window where you have all your
commands which gets recorded when you
record your script and these are pretty
simple commands and they're very
self-explanatory like say for example
open so it says open and the target is
amazon dot in that means it is giving
instruction to your browser to open this
particular website setting the window
size clicking on a button so this is the
search button which we have and then
typing what is the product which you are
searching for and then you have multiple
assert statements made available to you
in this id so these are all called as
the salinis command and as simple as a
close browser command and now if you
look here in this window this is log
window so every step which gets executed
here there is a log generated showing
you the status of the execution of that
step so if at all there is a failure you
would see a red failed mark against that
particular step and the test case will
not say completed successfully it will
say the failure occurred okay so it is
very simple and a very user friendly
kind of an id so let us go back to our
presentation so we saw the play button
here and we saw how to record it i also
showed you the commands the command
window what we have so these are the
selenium commands and then we saw the
log which indicated the execution of
each of this command now saving the
script so let me go back to the id again
so once you have created your test
scripts you have run it successfully you
need to save your project so for you to
save the project when you click on the
save project every ide project it is
saved with an extension dot sid which is
nothing but selenium id so you just go
ahead and click on save since i've
already saved this project i'm going to
just say cancel so that's the text file
extension it uses to save your project
for more details on how to use ide you
can watch our video on selenium id on
simplylearn.com selenium rc this is
selenium remote control so this was
developed by paul hammon and he
refactored the code and was also
credited with jason as a co-creator of
selenium rc is used to write web
application test in different
programming language the server itself
is written in java language it supports
multiple programming languages like java
c
perl python and php it interacts with
the browser with the help of rc server
it uses a simple http get and post
request for communication this rc server
is also a selenium one daughter version
but it got deprecated in selenium 2.0
and was completely removed in 3.0 and it
got replaced by selenium webdriver we
will see why this happened when we talk
about the selenium webdriver this is the
architecture of selenium remote control
so when jason huggins introduced
selenium the tool was javascript program
and he called it as javascript
testrunner and it is also called as
selenium core so every html has this
javascript statements which are executed
by this web browser there is a
javascript engine which helps in
executing this command now this had a
major issue of something called a same
origin policy now what is the same
origin policy same origin policy
prohibits your javascript from accessing
elements or interacting with the scripts
from the domain different from where it
is launched and this was for the
security measure for example every web
page in say google.com domain like say
your search email google drive can be
accessible but nothing outside this
domain like say if you want to access
yahoo or an amazon that was not possible
due to security reasons obviously so the
testers had to install the selenium core
and the web server which contained your
web application which you are basically
testing on the same system and this was
not feasible and effective all the time
now to overcome this to overcome the
same origin policy what paul hammond did
was he created something called as this
remote server which is selenium remote
control server and it acted like a proxy
to trick the browser in believing that
your core which is your selenium core
and your web application under test are
on the same domain this thus by
eliminating your same origin policy and
this was called as your selenium remote
control which was a version one of
selenium now if you look at the simple
architecture of this what are the things
it has so one is your script right first
you need to write your scripts using any
supported language like say php java
python and ruby as i mentioned now
before we
start the testing what is the
requirement of the selenium one version
is you need to install the rc server now
this rc server is a separate application
so once you install this this selenium
server is responsible for receiving the
selenius commands now these are the
salinis commands which you have written
in your scripts it interprets them and
it executes it on your browser and the
results are sent back to your test
scripts and this browser interaction
happens only through this rc server
again as i said using a simple http get
and post request to communicate now upon
receiving these instructions right from
the selenium core the response is sent
back to this rc server from your browser
and back to your test scripts so the
cycle starts from your test scripts the
selenius commands are interpreted by
your rc server those are sent to the
browser and it's a simple javascript
which executed on your browser and the
results after the execution are sent
back to your test scripts through your
rc server this is a simple cycle now
this cycle is repeated for every command
written in your test script until your
complete test case is executed okay so
this is how the rc worked now this rc
had few shortcomings and what are those
one is the architecture of this rc
itself was complicated why because of
this intermediate rc server which we
have between the browser and your test
script and this rc server had to be
installed before running any test
scripts so that means this became an
additional setup and it acts as a
mediator between your selenium commands
and your browser also the execution of
commands takes a very long time it is
pretty slow why because every command it
needs to make a full trip from your test
script to your rc server to the core and
to the browser execute the script and
then again back in the same line which
makes your overall test execution very
slow and now because of this short falls
web driver was introduced so selenium
webdriver selenium web drivers were
introduced by a gentleman called styman
stewart and it was developed in the year
2006. it is the first cross-platform
testing framework it is a programming
interface to create and run test cases
it makes provision to act on web
elements so basically there are multiple
locating techniques which selenium
webdriver provides us for finding those
elements and to perform operations on
those web elements webdriver does not
require a core engine like rc and it
interacts natively with the browser
application so there is a direct
interaction with your browser
application and it eliminates the need
of having that intermediate rc server
and that makes the architecture pretty
simple this web driver again it supports
multiple languages which we already
talked about and also it has integration
with multiple frameworks so once you
understand how the web driver works what
are its functionalities and what are it
drawbacks you will appreciate the fact
that so how the selenium webdriver
overcomes this even in web driver we
have test scripts we also have a web
browser here and then we have a web
driver however what we do not have this
additional server which rc required and
this makes the architecture of the web
driver simpler the browser is controlled
directly from the operating system level
now due to this direct communication the
speed of test execution is much faster
than rc now how does this web driver
work so we have something called as
client libraries or the language
bindings so we know now that selenium
supports multiple languages and you're
free to use any supported language to
create your automation script and where
are these libraries available so if you
go to seleniumhq.org
so let me go to the browser and show you
that so in the selenium hq dot r if you
go to the downloads so here you will see
something called as selenium client and
web driver language binding and
depending on the language which you want
to work with or which you want to create
test scripts with you can download this
client libraries so if you're working
with java download the client library
for java so if you're working with
python you have a corresponding link
which you through which you can download
your client libraries and then selenium
provides lot of apis for us to interact
with the browser and these are called as
the rest apis so then we have the
browser drivers through which we
interact with the browser now what are
these browser drivers so there are
drivers specific to each browser so let
me show you that on our
seleniumhq.org so here if you just
scroll down you have something called as
third-party drivers bindings and plugins
for every supported
browser of selenium you have a
corresponding driver file available now
say for example if you want to work with
firefox mozilla gecko driver is what you
need to download and these driver files
so if you go and click here you will get
an executable driver file for any of the
platforms which you are working so if
you're working on windows mac os or
linux you can just download the
corresponding driver files here so these
drivers see these driver files are the
ones which interact with the actual
browser and how does this happen this
driver establishes the connection with
the real browser without revealing the
internal logic of the browser
functionality now what does that mean
say we want to execute a test script and
how does this test script gets executed
first is it it sends an http request
which is generated and sent to this
browser driver which we just saw for
each of the command in your scripts and
then this driver receives the request
through your http server and this hp
http server does all the execution
directly on the browser and then the
execution status the complete status is
sent back to your test script so let me
show you a simple use case how it works
with the web driver so for that let's go
to my eclipse here so i already have a
test script written here in webdriver
and what this basically does is it
launches amazon.com amazon.in website it
uses the firefox browser and then i'm
also fetching the page title and
printing it on the console and then i'm
closing the browser this is a simple
functionality which i'm doing here so if
you look here so the eclipse is the id
which i'm using i've already installed
selenium here and i've written a simple
java class and this java class we have
multiple methods one is to launch
browser one is to fetch the title of the
page and one is to close the browser now
while launching the browser i said every
browser has its own driver files so
somewhere in this java class i need to
tell selenium as which browser to use
and how is that done that is done by
this first two statements here where i
am doing a system.set property and where
i am indicating that this is my driver
file which is geckodriver to be used and
using this i want the selenium to launch
the firefox browser and after this all
the operations any operations which you
want to perform on your web application
under test you can do it here now let's
go ahead and execute this and see how it
works so simply what i need to do is
i'll just say execute this as a java
program so the firefox browser is
getting launched so you can see amazon
dot in being launched here and since we
are not doing any operations here what i
am simply doing is printing the title of
the page and closing the browser that is
it so if you see here you can see the
page title is online shopping site so
and so and this is what i'm printing
through this method which is fetch page
title a very simple way of writing a
automation script using webdriver so now
you saw how we write a small test script
using the webdriver function now say if
i want to run the script on multiple
browsers and on multiple operating
system and i do not have just one test
case i say say i've got hundreds of test
cases now with this approach what you
can achieve your best is you can
sequentially execute on every browser
available and all your 100 or 200 test
cases whatever you have now this is
going to take quite a long time to
execute and hence to reduce the time
taken for the execution selenium has
something called as grid selenium grid
the main objective of the grid is to
minimize your test execution type this
grid is designed to distribute commands
to different machines simultaneously in
real time environment you always have
the need to run test cases in a
distributed environment for example a
web application for which say you have
automated thousands of test cases and
you want to run them as a regression
suite across multiple browsers and os
what you need to do is you need to run
them parallelly and not really
sequentially so grid allows this
parallel execution of test on different
browsers and operating system you also
want an integration with reporting tools
so that you can get a consolidated
report after the tests have been
executed on multiple machines so grid
can be integrated with such many other
tools how does the grid work so grid has
this hub and node concept which helps in
achieving the parallel execution let's
take an example say again your
application supports all browsers and it
also supports different os like the one
which you're seeing here like windows
mac and linux and your requirement is to
run tests on all the supported browsers
and operating system like this one so
what you do here is you configure a
master machine that is this which is
also called as hub by running something
called a selenium standalone server and
this selenium standalone server can be
download downloaded from your selenium
hq website so let me show you that let's
go to my browser and in the downloads
here if you see selenium standalone
server version
3.1.4.5 and this is what you need to
download so using the server you create
a hub configuration like this once you
do this you also need to create nodes
specific to your requirement like a
windows 10 like a mac machine with
firefox with the windows 8 with a chrome
and mac say with safari browser and the
node configuration is also done using
the same server which is the selenium
standalone server so you create a node
configuration on this node machines so
once you have the setup created through
your master that is your hub you can
control on which nodes you want to
execute which test say for example here
say you want to run some test on your
mac machine with safari browser so you
have a kind of smoke test which you need
to run now through the master you can
control this complete execution so what
master does it it selects this
particular node depending on the
configuration which you have set on the
master machine also you could have
multiple possible combinations like say
i want to just run smoke test on all my
nodes i want to run specific component
test on say only windows 10 with an edge
browser or i can say i want to just run
my complete regression suite but only on
mac machine and so on and all this is
controlled through your master so what
happens on the node once it gets the
command from the master the node
actually runs the specified test on the
browser so you can check out our
detailed video on selenium grid for you
to understand how the grid works and how
do we do this configuration and execute
the test to summarize the selenium
versions selenium version 1 comprised of
an id rc and grid as we discussed
earlier rc was on its path of
deprecation and webdriver was taking
birth so selenium 2 had an earlier
version of webdriver and also rc existed
from 3.0 onwards rc was completely
removed and webdriver took its place
also there's a four dot version around
the corner it has more features and
enhancement so some of the features
which is expected are like w3c webdriver
standardization they have an improved
idea and also i believe there are some
improvements done to the grid advantages
of selenium speed and accuracy since
there is no manual execution your test
can run faster and with grid it helps in
parallel execution so you can actually
execute large volume of test cases
within a short frame for example let's
say before your release of product
during your last lap of testing you find
a bug and it has to be fixed so the
developer fixes the bug and what you
want to do is you want to run all the
test cases pertaining to that area can
you imagine the amount of time which
will be required if you have to do this
manually but by automation you can
achieve this in a short duration of time
and you can also enable releasing your
product in time and with less or no
human error the second advantage is it's
an open source so it's available free of
cost and anyone can download and start
using it supports a wide spectrum of
programming languages it is not
restricted to any particular programming
language whatever language you are
comfortable with you have an option to
use that and to write your selenium
scripts selenium has support for almost
all browsers and operating system
including a headless browser so this
helps you to create test cases once and
run them across all browsers and
operating system and thus saving your
time for manual execution it also helps
in achieving a broad test coverage it's
a pretty easy to use tool you can check
out all our videos and you can just
master the skill of writing automation
scripts reusability and add-ons of
course like any programming languages it
provides you a mechanism to reuse your
code and avoid redundancy limitations so
like any other tool selenium also has
certain limitations so let's look at
what they are and see if there are any
workarounds also since selenium is an
open source you do not have much
technical support available however
there are loads of documentation
materials forums available which you can
refer to this tool is for automating web
application it cannot handle mobile
application or desktop application
automation however what selenium
provides is a support for integrating
tools like apm tool for mobile testing
selenium is not very good with image
testing since especially it is designed
for web application automation but then
we again have many other tools which can
be integrated with selenium like auto it
and securely selenium again has a
limited reporting capability it can help
create basic reports but we definitely
need more so it provides supports for
tools like test ng report ng extent
reports which you can integrate and
generate beautiful reports powerful
isn't it of course it does not have a
test management capability a tool need
not have all these capabilities but
again you can integrate with the test
management tool used in your
organization since selenium supports
multiple programming language the
developer of the automation script need
to have some basic knowledge of any
programming language to write effective
automation scripts of course a deep
advanced knowledge is not required a
basic knowledge is more than sufficient
so if you look at all this selenium
still provides a complete solution for
your automation need and that's the
beauty of selenium and that is what
makes it the most popular today most
popular tool today for automation in
this video we will look at how to
install selenium on windows system
selenium installation is a three step
process so it has certain prereqs the
first prerequisite you need to have java
on your system so we will be installing
java first and then we will be working
with eclipse id so we will be installing
eclipse and then we will install
selenium for java we will install the
version java 8 and for eclipse we have a
version 4.10 this was the last stable
version which was released in december
last year so i'll be using that version
and selenium we will download the latest
3.14 version okay so let's get started
with our first step which is the java
installation so to install java let's go
to the browser and simply just search
for java 8 download
so now you will see that there is an
oracle site which is listed there and
that is where you would be downloading
all your java package so go ahead and
click on that and for you to download
any jdk package from the oracle site you
need to create an account so if you
already have one you just need to log in
using that account and then you can
download any of the jdks and if you do
not have one please go ahead create a
new account on the oracle login to that
account and then you can just download
the java it so since i already have an
account and i have already downloaded
the package but i'll show you how and
where to download it from so in this
page if you scroll down so you will see
this java development kit 8211 so this
is the version we'll be downloading it
so click on the accept license agreement
and then since we are working on the
windows system today so we will be
downloading this the windows package so
just click on that and it will get
downloaded in your downloaded folder and
as i said i've already downloaded the
packages so here it is what i've done is
i've just created a directory called
installers and i'm going to be keeping
all my installables here so here i have
a folder called java installer and this
is where my installable is so now that
we have this file so we will just go
ahead double click on it and launch this
installer the installer is launched and
just click on run so this will take a
few minutes to install java the
installer is launched i'll just click on
the next button here so here for the
installation directory you can
change the directory to the choice of
whatever drive and the folder structure
you want to i would like to leave it as
default here and we just go and click on
next and then the java installation is
in progress so let's wait until this is
completed it really shouldn't take too
much time maybe just a few more minutes
here
okay accept the license term just click
on next we leave the destination folder
as it is
so jdk8 is successfully installed on
your system so close the installer now
and let's go ahead and check whether the
installation is done properly so for
that what i'll do is i'll go to my
command prompt and i'll send just say
java minus version so it says java
version 1.8 and this tells us that the
java is installed successfully now after
this installation there are couple of
configurations which we need to do and
what are those configuration one is you
need to set the path variable and then
you we are also going to set a java home
directory so for that first let's go
ahead and check where is the java
installed actually let's figure out the
directory first so if you remember the
directory structure where the java got
installed was in program files java i
have there are certain previous versions
which had installed and then uninstalled
it so that is why you see some residuals
here sitting here let's not worry too
much about that instead let me go to the
latest one what i have installed which
is this okay and there is a bin folder
here and this is the path which we need
to set in our path variable so what i
will do is i'll just copy this path and
then
go to your control panel here go to your
where is my system yeah so click on the
system go to advanced system setting and
here in the environment variables find
the path variable okay and then say edit
now what are we doing here in the path
variable is we are going to add the java
bin directory to the path be very
careful whenever you are editing your
path variable do not overwrite anything
always go into the edit mode go towards
the end here and then just say control v
paste the path which you have just
copied from the explorer window that's
it now just say okay done so your path
setting is done so what's the next one
we need to do we need to add a new
environment variable called the java now
what i'll do for that is i just say new
i just type java home here
and what is the value of this we need to
set we need to set the same path but
without the bin directory so we just
need to set the path till your java
directory that is this so we'll just
copy the path again and paste it here
that is all just say okay click on ok
click on ok here and we are done so
again let's go to our command prompt and
just say java minus version
so everything seems to be fine so now
successfully we have installed java on
the system so what is our next
installation step what we have now we
need to install the eclipse so let's go
back to the browser again so to download
eclipse we will be downloading the
package from the eclipse.org so when you
go here to eclipse.r you can see the
latest version which is available and
the latest version available when this
video was made was twenty ninety zero
six so especially with eclipse since
it's an open source i prefer to work
with the last stable version and so does
most of the developers do and hence that
is the reason why i have picked up the
version which is like last year's
version which is
4.10 which was released in last december
so you can always choose to go with the
latest version but then if there are any
issues and if you're like first time
working with the eclipse you're going to
get confused as where these issues are
coming from right so i would still
recommend that you use the last table
version which is available with your
eclipse so now to get the last table
version what you need to do is go and
click on this download packages and here
if you scroll down this page you can see
here more downloads so there is a list
of all the previous releases of eclipse
which is available and this is what we
need to download so just click on that
4.10 version and then click on the os on
which you want to install eclipse for us
it is windows so i'll just click here on
the 64-bit windows and then click on the
download and you will be downloading the
complete package so once you download
this is what it will look like so let's
go back to our directory of installers
so this is the installer for the eclipse
which i got now what's the next step i
need to do just launch this installer
and install eclipse so i'll just say
double click on this i'll say run
so here you'll see multiple options here
for eclipse installation so depending on
your requirement you can go ahead and
install any of these packages so for us
we just need an eclipse id for java
developer so i'll select this and i'll
say install so again you'll have a
choice of directory where you want to
install so i have chosen d drive here
this is the default directory name it
takes which is ok we can leave it as it
is and then also you have an option to
create a start menu entry and desktop
shortcut so just leave the default
selection as it is and go ahead and
click on install so this will take a
while to install the eclipse
this is select all you can close this
window this is select all and accept it
okay so the installation has been
completed successfully so let's go and
click on this launch and let's see the
first window what opens
when you launch the eclipse you need to
specify a workspace directory now what
is this workspace directory so this is a
directory or a folder wherein all the
java files or any programs or any
artifacts which you are going to create
through eclipse will be stored in this
particular folder so this could be any
location on your system so this is you
can go ahead browse the location and
change it so for in our case what we
will do is i'll go to the d drive and
i already have a directory so here i'll
create i'll just clear select this
folder and then create a folder called
workspace i'll say my workspace and then
i'll say launch so every time i open the
eclipse right so this is going to take
as my default workspace and all my
programs all my javascripts or my
automation scripts are getting are going
to be stored in this particular location
so we'll say launch
so this is a welcome window which opens
we can just close this and there we go
the eclipse is open with a certain
perspective so there are certain windows
here which we do not need let's just
close them so now the first thing what
you do after launching the eclipse is go
ahead and create a new project so i'll
say file new and since i'm going to be
using java with selenium i'll say create
java project so give a project name
let's say my first project now you have
an option here to select the jre which
you want to use so we just installed
this jdk 1.8 okay so i'm going to click
on use default jre otherwise you also
have an option to use a project specific
gr for example i could have two
different projects where one project i'm
going to be working with gre 1.8 and
there is another project which i want to
work with the latest java maybe java 12
and i can have more than one java
installed on the machine so this give me
an option to select whichever java i
want to work with so if you have another
java installed here it will show up in
this list so and you can just go ahead
and select that now since we have only
one java installed on our machine which
is java 1.8 i will say use default gre
which is 1.8 and i will click on finish
now if you observe this folder structure
the project which is created see all the
reference libraries to this particular
java have been created here now we are
ready to create any kind of java
programs in this project so now we have
successfully done the second step of our
installation which is the eclipse
installation after this we need to
install the selenium so again let's go
back to the browser and see what files
we need to download to install selenium
so let me go to my browser and here i
will be going to the seleniumhq.org
so if you are working with selenium this
particular website the seleniumhq.org is
going to be a bible everything and
anything related to selenium is
available in this website whether you
want to download the files whether you
want to refer to the documentation
anything regarding to selenium is
available here so what we want now is
the installables for selenium so here go
to the download tab now for you to
install selenium and start working with
selenium there are three things which
are required for you to download one is
a standalone selenium server so this is
not required immediately when you get
started with selenium however when you
start working with remote selenium
webdriver you would be requiring this
when you have a grid setup you will be
requiring the standalone server so for
that what you can do is you can just
download the latest version available
here so when you click on that it will
download the file into your download
folder so this is one particular file
which you need to keep next selenium
client and web driver language bindings
now in today's demo we will be looking
at selenium with java so that means my
client package of java is what i need to
download so whatever programming
language selenium supports we have
respective downloadables available with
that say if you're working with python
then you need to download your client
library for python and since we are
working with java you need to download
this package so simply what you need to
do click on this link and it will
download the java package for you which
are basically the jar files so we have
client libraries now and then there is
another component what we need now with
selenium you are going to be automating
your web browser applications correct
and you also want your applications to
run on multiple browsers so that means
your scripts the automation scripts
which you create should be able to run
on any browser selenium works with
multiple browsers like edge safari
chrome firefox and other browsers even
it has a support for headless browser
now every browser which it supports
comes with its own driver files now say
for example we want to say work with
firefox driver so that means for us to
start working with firefox browser we
need to download something called as a
gecko driver here and if you want to
work with chrome browser you need to
install the chrome driver so depending
on what browsers you'll be testing with
go ahead click on each of this link and
download the latest driver files now
since we are going to be working with
firefox in this demo what i need to do
is i just need to click here on the
latest link so when i click on the
latest link it is going to take me to
this driver files so driver files are
specific to each of the operating system
so if you go down here you will see
there is a separate driver file
available for linux for mac and for
windows so depending on which operating
system where you'll be running your test
download that particular driver file and
this is the driver file i need because
we are working on windows machine so
these are the three different packages
which we need to download from the
seleniumhq.org
for us to install selling so let me show
you the folder where i've already
downloaded all this so if you see here
selenium java
3.141.59 okay this is nothing but our
client library which we saw here let us
go back to the main page here that is
this so once i download this this is a
zip file after i unzip the file this is
the folder structure i see and let's see
what is there in this folder structure
so there are two jar files here and then
in the lips there are multiple jar files
and we will need all this to work with
selenium and then we also downloaded the
driver files so what i did was after
downloading those driver files for the
browser i created a directory here
called drivers and i've kept all my
browser drivers here so i have a driver
file downloaded for chrome i want to
work with firefox so i have a gecko
driver here and then for internet
explorer that's it so this is all we
need so once we have all this what you
need to do is go to your eclipse in the
eclipse right click on the project which
you have created and then go to the
build path and say configure build path
go to the libraries tab here now do you
see this jre libraries here this is what
got installed first and now similarly we
are going to add the selenium jars to
the slide british and how do we add that
on your right you can see this add
external jars click on add external jars
go to your folder where you have
downloaded your selenium which is this
select all the jar files which is
available so i have two jar files here
i'll just say click open again i will
click on add external jar now from the
libs folder i will select all this file
so select all the five jars and click on
open so you should see all the seven jar
files here so once you have this just
say apply and close now if you look into
your project directory here you will see
some a folder called referenced library
and this is where you will see all the
selenium charts here this is a very
simple installation in eclipse when you
want to install selenium you just need
to export all the jars of the selenium
into eclipse and now your system is
ready to start working with selenium
scripts all right so now let's just test
our installation by writing a small
selenium test script so for that what i
will do is i'll go to the source folder
right click new and i'll say java class
so let's name this as say
first selenium test and i will select
this public static void main and i will
click on finish all right so now let's
uh create a use case say we want to
launch a firefox browser and then we
want to launch the amazon site so these
will be just two simple things which we
will be doing in this test script so for
me to do that what i usually do is i
create a method for any functionality
which i want to create here so now i
want to do a launch browser so i'll
create a method here called launch
browser now whenever you start writing
your selenium scripts the first line
what you need to do is you need to
declare an object of webdriver class so
here i'll say
webdriver driver so now if you hover
over this error what it is showing it
says import web driver from or dot open
qa dot selling it so if you remember
when we installed the selenium we
imported all these jars right so that
means so what whenever we want to use a
web driver we need to import this class
from these packages so just go ahead and
click on this import state done now next
step now for us to launch a firefox
browser it is a two steps process which
is involved here one is you need to set
the system property and then you need to
launch the driver so let's do that i'll
say system dot set property so use this
method set property so this takes two
arguments the key and the value bill now
what is the key i'm going to mention
here i'm going to be mentioning the
gecko driver and the path for the gecko
driver okay because since i'm working
with the firefox so in double quotes
i'll say webdriver.geco.driver
this is my key and the value is going to
be sorry the fully qualified path for
your driver files and you know where we
have kept our driver first let's go to
that driver files in d colon i have
selenium tutorial in installers i have
driver folder okay so i'm just going to
copy the complete path from here ctrl c
and
i paste it here control v along with
this i need to provide the file name for
the gecko driver which is
geckodriver.exe and let's complete this
step next so once i've set the property
i need to provide a command for
launching my firefox driver and how do i
do that i simply use this driver object
which i have created driver equal to
new firefox driver again similarly the
way we imported packages for the web
driver we also need to import the
package for firefox driver so just hover
over the mouse over that and select
import firefox with these two statements
we will be able to launch the firefox
browser and as i said in our use case
what is the next thing we want to do we
want to launch say amazon dot in website
for that there is a command in selenium
which says driver dot get and you pass
the url here so for me to write the url
what i usually do is i go to my browser
i open the website which i want to work
with in our case it's amazon dot in and
i just simply copy this fully formed url
go to my eclipse and just paste it here
now this ensures that i don't make any
mistakes in typing out the url let's
complete the statement and we are done
and now in the main function i'll just
create an object of this and we will
call this method so i'll copy this class
for selenium test say obj equal to new
for selenium test and now i'll say obj
dot this is a function launch processor
so let's save this and execute this
control c right click run as
java application okay so the mozilla
firefox has been launched now it should
launch your
dot bingo so there goes our first test
script which runs successfully in this
session we will be looking at how to
install selenium on your mac machines
selenium installation on mac is a
three-step installation
one we need to install java which is a
prereq and then we need an id to work
with so we will be installing eclipse
and then we will install selenium and
these are the versions of the installers
which we are going to use so we will be
using java 8
eclipse version 4.10 which was released
in 2018 december and then selenium
version 3.14
so let's get started with our first step
which is the java installation
so for us to install java let us go to
our browser
and simply what i'll do is i'll just
google for
java 8 download
okay so we would select the oracle site
for downloading the sd
okay so once you go here you can see
that we have something called as java
software development kit 8 u211 so this
is the version we'll be working with so
in order for you to download you need to
have an oracle account so since i
already have one i have directly been
logged into that so if you do not have
an oracle account please go ahead create
an account for yourself so that you can
download any of the java installers
now let's go for and download our
package so i'll be downloading this
package for that i need to click on
accept license agreement and then since
we are going to be working on mac this
is the package which i am going to
download so let's go ahead and click on
that
and now the download is going to start
however we will not wait for the
complete download to happen since i have
already downloaded the package and i
have kept it in one of my folders so let
me show you where that is
so let me go to my finder so what i have
done is i have created a folder is
called installers and all the software
which we are going to require today for
us to work with selenium is what i have
downloaded it and kept it here so we
will go step by step so that you
understand what each of these packages
are so as you see here i have the jdk 8
which i've already downloaded so let's
go ahead and install jtk so how do we
install jdk so you have the dmg file
here you just go ahead and double click
on that
okay and then i will double click on
this package
and then we will say continue
and install
so it's going to ask me for my password
okay i've given my password and i'll say
install the software
probably it will just take a couple of
minutes to install java
okay there you go so now the java has
been installed so i let me close this
window let me close this window too and
then now i'll go to my terminal window
so let's open my terminal and here
let's say java minus version
bingo so there we have java 1.8
installed on our system now there are
couple of other things which you need to
do apart from installation of your jdk
you also need to set some system
variables right so in mac how do you set
the system variables or the environment
variables you do that in your bash
profile so let's see how we do that all
right so what i will do is i'll use an
editor which is my vi
okay and then i'll open my bash profile
so what is bash profile it's a config
file for your bash cell
this is mainly used to export variables
in your shell
like in windows we are going to do the
system variable setting from the
advanced setting right so similarly we
are going to do that here so i will say
vi dot
bash underscore
profile so this is the file
where
i will be adding java home path
now i have other parts here already
written because i'm working with other
multiple software on this machine and
now i'll go to the end of this file and
i'll say
export
java home
equal
now what is the path we need to give for
java home we need to give the path where
the java has been installed on your
system
okay first let's go and find out that
path so let's go back to our finder
and then i have a
folder called library here so here
there is a java and then there is
something called as java virtual
machines so if you have a single java or
multiple java versions installed so all
those versions you are going to see
under this directory which is java
virtual machines and java one dot is is
what we installed just now so let me go
and open that folder there is something
called as content and then home and in
this you have your jre and bin folder so
that means i need to give my java home
path until here
till this home directory so simply what
i'm going to do is i'll just go here say
get info because i want to just copy the
path and what you can do is you copy
this path
okay and then go back to your shell
and here
i'm going to paste this path plus i want
to till the home directory so i'm just
going to type out h o me home that is it
so you have now set your java home
environment variable so simply you do
save the file
escape colon wq and come out of it and
now what you need to do for this batch
profile
to be activated you just exit out of
this terminal
okay close this terminal window and i'll
go ahead and open another terminal
so let me close this
in for text so here let me again give
java minus version
ok so everything seems to be working
fine so this completes our java
installation now your system is ready
and you have your java up and running
other thing which you also can do is go
to your system preferences
okay here you will see this java control
panel okay this is another way of
finding out that your java has been
installed successfully on the machine so
you can just open this java control
panel and if there is any settings which
you want to do here you can do it
through your control panel also
all right
let's close this let's minimize this
window
and this folder windows
so we have successfully done a step one
so what's our step two we need to go
ahead and install the eclipse now same
thing what i will do i'll go to my
browser
okay and
now i'll open another tab here
and i'll say
eclipse download
and we'll go to this eclipse.org
now here whenever you are going to do
this installation you will see the
latest version appears here my
recommendation to you is instead of if
you are working first time instead of
working on the latest version available
i would suggest that you work with the
last stable version and that's exactly
what you are going to do today so for me
to go to the previous versions i just
need to go here on this download
packages click on it
okay so once you click on that
on this page if you scroll down you will
see something called as more downloads
right in this you will see all the bills
of eclipse which is available all your
previous versions so since today i'll be
working with 4.10 version i will go
ahead and click on this 4. this 4.10 was
released last year this is 2018 december
okay and now when you look at this
installer you have multiple packages
available here so depending on your need
you can choose which package you want to
work with so today for our demo what i
would be using is eclipse id for java
developers
so since we are going to be working on
mac i will go ahead and click on this
downloadable
and then i'll click on this download
which is going to download this
particular file for me i've already
downloaded this file and kept it in my
folder
let's go to my folder
okay it's not opening so let me click
from here
and then let's go to our selenium demo
folder and in that installers okay so
now do you see this eclipse java 2018 12
are
blah blah blah dot dmg so this is the
file which we are going to be using to
install eclipse now as simple as what we
did for jdk i'm going to double click on
this and install the eclipse let's see
how the eclipse gets installed
all right so now
i'll just move this folder into
applications
done
so my eclipse is ready now so simply
let's go ahead and launch so what i'll
do i'll just simply search for that on
my system eclipse there you go and i'll
just double click this
is an application downloaded from the
internet are you sure you want to open
it yes please go ahead and open it
okay it is launching it so did you see
how simple the eclipse installation is
it's just downloading the package and
just installing it on your mac machine
all right when you start the eclipse for
the first time you need to set your
workspace so workspace is place where
you're going to keep all your folders
all your
java code or whatever you're going to do
in eclipse all under that particular
directory um so right now it gives me a
default directory rather what i will do
is since i have created a separate
folder for our demos i will go ahead and
select that folder which is my simply
demo
and then in this i will add
a folder called
workspace
okay so that means in this particular
location whatever files i am going to
create whatever code i am going to write
in selenium is going to be stored at
this location and then i'll go ahead and
say launch so it will take a minute to
load your workbench yeah there it goes
so when you launch your eclipse
right so let me just
make this window bigger the first screen
what you are going to see is the welcome
screen
just go ahead and close the welcome
screen and this is the first view of
your eclipse what you're going to get so
let's close out all the windows which we
are not going to be working today
and i just need this main screen here
now what is the first step you're going
to do once you have the eclipse i would
go ahead and create a project first
so i'll simply say open file new java
project let's give a nice name to this
since this is our first project which is
going to be created so i'll say
selenium first project
now if you observe here
so we have a jdk already installed and
eclipse needs a jdk to work with and
what it is done while i create my new
project it has already given me an
option to use the execution jre which
you already have in the system that's
why it is already chosen java one dot it
in case you have multiple javas
installed in in that case what you can
do is you can always go here select this
and select the java of your choice so
say if you have got the latest java
which is java 12 installed on your
system it will give you an option here
along with java software 8 it will give
you java 12 here so you can go ahead and
select that for this particular project
that option is also available now since
we have only one jtk installed here i
will go ahead and create this project
so i just click on finish and it's going
to create a projection so there are few
default things which it grades created
one is definitely the gre system
libraries right this is what we told
eclipse when we created project that my
java is 1.8 so what it has done is it
has imported all this jar file which it
requires for our java programs to work
in our eclipse id and then it creates a
src which is your source directory
wherein we will be creating all our java
code or selenium descripts okay good so
far so this is a simple way of
installing your eclipse and getting your
eclipse ready to work with your selling
all right so now let's go back
so we have done the installation of java
we have done the installation of eclipse
now what's left just the selenium right
so what is that we need for selenium
let's go back to our browser
okay and this time we will go to
selenium
hq
dot
so this is going to be a bible for you
if you're going to be working with
selenium so in this website what i do is
i go to downloads
and there are two things which we need
to download for us to work with selenium
one is the selenium standalone server
right so when you're going to be working
with remote selenium webdriver is when
you would require this however i would
suggest that we download whatever is
required for us even though we might not
use it immediately so what i just need
to do is i need to click on this and
it's going to download this server for
me okay so i have already downloaded it
and i'll show you that
and then what we need is the selenium
client and web driver language bindings
okay we need a client so what is the
client which you are going to work in we
are going to working with java client
with the selenium and for that i need to
go ahead and download this if you are
working on say c sharp or ruby or python
then you have the respective packages
which you can go and download now since
we are going to be working with java
here i would go ahead and click on this
and this is going to download the java
client for me now as i said since i've
already downloaded it so let's go ahead
and look at what are those downloadables
what we have so let's close out this
window now if you see here
uh one is the selenium server standalone
which we just downloaded and then when
you download the client libraries what
it does it it creates a zip file it
downloads a zip file and it unzips it
and what is contained in that particular
folder so if you look here selenium java
3. in this folder you have multiple jar
files
with which is what we'll be working with
selenium
so here you have two jar files here and
then under the folder libs you have
other jar files now these are the files
which we will need and now let's see how
do we utilize this file in our eclipse
so for that let's go back to our eclipse
okay so
let me maximize this window so in
eclipse first thing what you need to do
is click on your project
okay right click on that
and then you have something called as
build path
go to the build path and say configure
now here in this configure build path
what you need to do is go to your
libraries
okay go to add external jars
now when you click on that this is where
you need to select all your jar files
from what you have downloaded from the
selenium site so that is present in our
selenium java three so what i'll do is
simply select
these two first
okay
then again you click on the external jar
files what we have is ellipse so select
all the jar files in the list
say open okay you have all the java
files what we need identified here go
ahead and click on apply and close
once you do that how do you know whether
all those jars have been imported
correctly
go to the reference libraries
here you should be able to see all the
selenium jars which we have downloaded
to be listed out here and so it lists
here so that means we have successfully
imported selenium to test our
installation let's go ahead and write a
small test script so for that i'll go to
my source folder
right click new and will create a java
class so let's name it
selenium
first test
and i will also use a public static void
name here and i'll click on
finish
let's remove all this comments here
which we do not need so before even we
write our first line of code first what
we need to do is create an object of
webdriver so i will say webdriver
driver
okay so now if you see this error it
asks us to import this particular web
driver class from a package and that
package is org dot open qa dot selling
okay so now you can see this import
statement
now let's go ahead and write our
test case now for this test case what we
will do is uh we will simply launch a
browser say firefox browser and we will
also launch a website
now i'll create a method for that i'll
say public void
launch browser
so if you have looked at our previous
videos on selenium webdriver basics i
have explained there that every browser
which you want to work with in selenium
comes with its own driver and this
driver is what we need to download from
the website of selenium and i'll show
you how to do that so if we go to that
seleniumhq.org
under the downloads tab if you go down
you will see something called as third
party drivers bindings and plugins so
all the browsers supported by selenium
are listed here and their corresponding
driver files are available so now since
we are going to be working with firefox
in this demo i will go ahead and click
on this latest release of mozilla gecko
driver so gecko driver is the one which
we'll be using for launching our firefox
so just click on this and this will take
you to the latest version of the gecko
driver available so just scroll down and
depending on the os which you're working
with in our case it is a macros so just
click on this file and download this
file
similarly
say if you are working with the chrome
driver what you need to do is go to this
chrome driver
go to the latest
click on that
and select the release which you want to
work with and just download it
now i've already downloaded this file
and i'll just show you where they are
all right so in this directory which is
my installers directory i have another
directory created called as drivers and
what i do is usually i keep all my
driver files under this folder
okay so i have a chrome driver and gecko
driver already downloaded and kept here
now let's go back to our code and see
what is that we need to do to launch our
browser so there are two steps which we
need to do for launching any browser
which you want to work with
first is you need to set a system
property so for that what i do is
system dot
set property
and this accepts a key and value pair
now key for this is gecko driver is what
i need to provide here and now that is
in the codes because it's a string
argument i say web driver dot
gecko
dot driver
and the value is
nothing but the path to your gecko
driver which you have just downloaded
okay let's go to my finder so that's
here so what i do is i simply right
click on this file get info
and i copy this complete path
go to my eclipse
paste this path here
and then the file name which is
geckodriver
done so this sets a path to my gecko
driver now next step is actually
launching the web browser and how do i
do that i say driver
equal to new
firefox driver
now we need to do the same thing again
we need to import this class so i say
import firefox driver
all right so now with these two steps
what we do is we simply launch the
firefox browser
and then let's go ahead and also launch
a website say amazon.com so for that i
have a command called
driver.get
which accepts a url
now this url needs to be fully formed
url so for that what i do first is i go
to my any browser i launch the amazon
dot in website okay and then i copy this
complete url
go to my eclipse and just paste it here
that's it we are ready to launch the
browser and launch amazon.com so let's
quickly create a class here
object here of this class
so selenium first test
obj equal to new selenium first test
done
and then i need to call the method
which is
launch browser
okay so now i save this file i do a
right click on this and i say run as
java application now
this should
launch our browser
okay which adjusted and then it should
take us to amazon.com bingo there goes
our first script so we have successfully
executed our first script so that means
your selenium is up and running
successfully
let's talk about automation frameworks
okay so guys to be precise with you i'll
be talking about mission framework when
we will start automation but as that's a
part of the automation
basics so i'll just give you a basic
knowledge of it that what automation
framework is and then we'll be seeing
how we'll be going to create a framework
so first of all what is automation
framework
so it's a set of protocols rules such as
coding standards
object repository and data handling
and beneficial in terms of code reuse
portability maintenance
the framework provides the basis of test
automation simplifies the automation
effort so what happens actually when we
need this automation suppose you are
automating only
one functionality you have written only
one test script of course you don't
require to write an automation framework
for this
because there's only one script if there
is any there is any change comes you can
go ahead and make the change and done
but when this one is this script one one
automation script
becomes hundred
then it becomes very difficult to manage
them suppose in 100 test case 100
descripts there is a user name
there is a password so there is a
username and password in more than 10
test scripts
if that happens then and if there is any
change comes
in the password
or in the username you may have to go to
the 10 tips script separately and make
the change which will be very cumbersome
process and it may be possible that you
make
you made an error okay it may be
possible that you you know somewhere you
have written something different
somewhere you'll be something different
or spelling error or space error may
have also if i talk about what you have
done you have created your scripts but
that is keeping in mind for windows but
what if you have to run it on linux and
you'll go back on all your scripts and
make that change what if you have
written your script for firefox browser
and you may have to run it for chrome
browser then it will be difficult to
make multiple changes so it's always
suggested that you create a framework
for that because framework is the one
which will help you out and solve all
these problems instead of writing one
thing again and again we will write it
only at one place and reuse that again
and again it will be very easy for us to
maintain it because that in terms of
framework that's in the framework where
you can make changes very easily
portability so of course you have
written out of windows and you can run
it on any other rotating system the
framework provides the basis of test
automation and simplifies the automation
effort it is actually helpful when you
have multiple scripts for multiple test
cases
so framework is very important and
that's the reason if you go and say that
you have done the automation and you
have a knowledge of automation you will
always ask you about the framework
they will know they will not go in the
basics they will always go with the
automation so it's very important
so what are the automation frameworks do
we have we have linear framework we have
structured framework data driven
framework keyword driven hybrid
there are multiple types of frameworks
we have what is the methodology for
automation first of all you know
mythology means
how you decide whether you need to
automate or so first of all you take a
decision whether this project needs to
be automated or not because that is
becoming very complex you have plan of
methodology you have less resources all
those things you have less budget
because of that you thought to automate
that
when you have part of automating it what
tool do you want to use you think on
that so you pick three to four rules it
certainly depends you pick three to four
tools create a proof of concept
create a proof of concept guys are you
all aware what is proof of concept poc
obey is aware of that anyone who is not
aware of that can just say engineer has
heard of it kushal is aware of that okay
great not created on my own yes that's
perfectly fine of course okay says no
so guys what is proof of concept is
whenever you are suppose you are
shortlisting some tools you have
multiple automation rules in the market
correct so how do you decide whether
which
tool is best for you of course you can
go ahead and you know take a list of
tools
you can see pros and cons of those
tweets but those pros and cons of the
tools
depending on the blogger depending on
the editor who is writing about that
particular tool
it may not be applicable it may not be
possible that those advantages or
disadvantages
are actually correct for your project so
always what we do
we shortlist few tools like three to
four rules
develop or create a poc ready poc means
you
actually use those tools to
automate one simple
use
all three tools what you have
shortlisted to automate a simple script
and then figure out
the
pros and cons of that tool
based on your experience and based on
what other people say and then you
create a ppt and show it
to the management and this is the tools
we have taken up this is the poc this is
how it works this is the advantage this
is a disadvantage and then you shortlist
one tool out of it and that's what we
call test tool accusation and it does
not like uh you are talking and we are
learning selenium and you will go ahead
and face the reading and that's it they
will accept it no
you have to tell them that this is the
poc and this is the benefits of opting
selenium tool
and then if they are happy with that
then they will
go ahead with that they will say go away
else they may ask you to come back offer
with more details and all this stuff
okay
and it becomes very difficult to you
know
to
impress your management when
there is an existing tool running like
qtp is running and you wanted to
suggest then selenium tool then it
becomes very difficult because they may
say that all the other projects are
working perfectly fine with the qtp why
should we go ahead with selenium what is
the best part so that's what you need to
highlight and need to say that these are
the things which automate with fruitful
selenium you can do that so that's where
test tube acquisition comes then you do
the test planning uh that what all test
cases should be automated and start
developing your test cases or test
scripts then you execute them and manage
them then you show the result of all
those test cases and send it to all the
stakeholders then this is the
result
so in this video we will be looking in
detail about how the selenium id works
so what is selenium id selenium ide was
developed way back in 2006. it was
created to facilitate a simple record
and replay of the test automation so
record and replay tools were pretty much
invoked during this time and the main
advantage of using such tool was an
automation engineer was not really
required to know any knowledge of
programming he could just use this
record replay tool and create the
automation and this ide was available as
a firefox extension so for one to use it
you need to just go ahead and install
the extension on firefox and then use
its recording and record the steps of
your test execution it is a very simple
interface which helps in building the
automation scripts and how this works
you just need to start the recording on
id perform your test steps on the
browser and these steps gets recorded in
the script and then what you could do is
you could export the script into say a
web driver or a junit ruby or any
javascripts and then you can use it now
however the record and replay tool is
not a very powerful automation tool and
hence this ide is mainly used for
prototyping or you could say demo
purpose now since selenium webdriver
itself offers such powerful capability
of creating robust test scripts ide more
or less remains as a prototyping tool
only so in short as i said ide is a part
of overall selenium set of tools and
mainly developed to speed up the
creation of test cases and what is the
other advantage of that one need not
really have any programming knowledge to
use this tool and mainly it is used for
writing some quick test for demo
purposes advancements with the new
selenium id back in 2017 selenium id
development was completely stopped the
last supported firefox version where
this ide was available as a plugin was
firefox 54 and from 55 onwards the
complete integration point was remote or
it was completely broken however
recently apply tools help revamp much of
the selenium id code they basically
rewrote the whole ide code and then now
they have released a new version under
the apache 2.0 license and it is
completely managed by the selenium
community now let's look at some of the
features of this now traditionally the
selenium ide was only a firefox plugin
however the new ide supports both the
browsers the chrome and the firefox and
thus making it cross browser so before
even we start looking at the other
features of the selenium ide i would
like to show you how do we install this
firefox plugin or the chrome extension
so for that let me go to my chrome
browser so in the chrome words browser
what i'll simply do is i'll search for
selenium id for chrome so then let's go
to this chrome.google.com
and here you will see it as an extension
selenium id so go ahead click on add to
chrome so this will add this extension
to your chrome browser so now it says
selenium id has been added to the crew
so how do you make out if it is added so
you can see this particular icon here
which says selenium id so this is the
way you can go ahead and install it on
the chrome now on the firefox i have
already installed it since we want to
use the firefox as a browser for all the
demos in this video so here again you
can see the selenium id so if i click on
this ide it is going to open a window
for me and the first window when it
opens it says either open a new project
or open an existing project or simply
you can start recording a new test case
in which case it creates a default
project for you first so what i will do
is i'll say open an existing project and
i've already got a project created so
let me go to my folder where i have this
project so i have this project created
and i've opened it i also have a simple
test case written now what this test
case does is let me show you here it
simply goes to google.com and then here
what i'm doing is i'm searching for
selenium hq documentation and then i
click on this site which says
seleniumhq.org and docs so which should
take us to this particular website where
the documentation is available so this
is a simple script which i have tried to
write it in this id so let's keep both
this windows open and let's go back to
our presentation to see the first
feature of this selenium id the first
feature what it says is improved locator
functionality what are locators so these
are nothing but the techniques used for
locating your web elements on your
website now for example in our example
here now the type here the type which
says name equal to q so name equal to q
is a locator now this is a locator of
what initially if you saw i went to
google.com and this is the search button
which i used right the search text and
then i said enter so this is nothing but
your web element for which the locator
is name equal to q now what happens in
id is when you record it it has taken
the attribute name and it is recognized
this particular web element using this
attribute however it also has a feature
wherein it also records its multiple
locators available for that particular
web element for example it also has a
css locator it has an expat locator now
how does it help here say for example
tomorrow this particular attribute name
right for the search box if it changes
then what id does is when you execute
this test script it falls back on your
other locators mentioned here in the
structure and then if none of this
locators work only then the test case is
going to go and fail not otherwise so
how does this help this helps to make
the test cases more robust otherwise
having just one locator there is high
possibility the test case might break or
become pretty brittle as and when the
web elements change their attributes so
this is what the locating techniques are
and that is how they have improved the
locator techniques in the uh
functionality in the new id now what's
the next one parallel execution is
possible with this new id so the first
id the traditional one the parallel
execution was not possible however this
is a new feature which has been added so
we will be looking in detail how to work
with this parallel execution later in
this video next is you can add control
statements in your scripts now what are
these control statements like if else
while loops for each loops and even the
switch case the earlier ide also had
this provision but you had to install a
plugin to enable the use of this control
statements and now this new id it is
available out of box automatically waits
for page to load in any automation
synchronization between your application
under test and your automation scripts
is very important your script should not
run faster than your application
otherwise your scripts are going to
start failing so it is necessary to have
enough load times on the operations of
your web elements and also enough load
times on your page now this low time
ensures that all the elements of your
web pages and the page itself is loaded
completely before even a single line of
script is run this new ide takes care of
providing that enough uh wait time and
also you have a global set speed option
which you can
use to control your execution of your
scripts so that is something which i
will show you now so if i go back to
this so can you see this clock icon here
so it says test execution speed so what
you can do is right now it is set to the
fastest so i can actually control the
execution speed here so right now i've
just kept it a little slower so let's
see how our test scripts run so you will
be able to see a remarkable difference
when i slow down the complete speed of
this so now do you see how slow it is
initially when i ran it you are unable
to see what i entered in the search
field of the google right so now it's
clearly taking time on each of the steps
which we have mentioned there so now it
is executed successfully so next it
supports embedded code you can run a
simple java script from your test script
right and how do you run that by using a
simple command called as execute now
let's see how do we do that so let's
take the same example here now after
clicking this okay so this is our id so
what i will do is i'll first execute
this test case and then in the end where
i will show you how do we add a simple
javascript and do some function so
let me get the speed back to a little
normal because we do not want to waste
too much time so i'll just play the
script once so now we are in the
selenium documentation now if you look
at this page this is a pretty long one
so now i'm going to write a simple
javascript wherein i scroll down towards
the end of this page that's all i'm
going to do now for me to do that what i
can do is in my script itself i can just
add another line here okay here i will
say add a new command
here i'll say execute script which is my
command and what is the script which i
want to execute it's a java script which
i'm going to write here i'll say window
dot scroll by and i'm just going to
mention some coordinates here start from
zero and i'll say one five zero zero
okay this is all my code is and now i'll
simply run this test again let's see
what happens so it's going to the
documentation now it's clicked on the
link okay let's move down do you see
this initially it was right here on the
top of the page and once the javascript
was executed it brought me somewhere to
the middle of this page that is how you
can insert snippets of javascript and it
has to be in context with your currently
selected window okay and that's how you
run it all right let's go back to our
ppt okay what's the next feature so
every ide has a debugger which allows
step execution adding of breakpoints now
apart from just having a break points or
adding the step execution there is
another feature which it provides called
i will show you that which is called as
pause on exception so let's close this
window and let's just keep this id
window open here
right so can you you see here pause
button it says pause on exception so
what it does is if you enable this
button okay and when you're running the
script so if at all there happens to be
an exception in your script it stops the
execution at that particular exception
field and we will see this in detail
when we look at complete debugger for
the id can be integrated in ci since you
can execute scripts from command line
right we also talked about the parallel
execution and you can also export the
scripts to any of the programming
language you want so since you can do
that these scripts can be run from
command line and hence they can also be
integrated with your maven project and
through gen keys you can run it and
that's how you achieve your ci working
principle of selenium id selenium id
works on a very very simple principle
one is the recording it records user
interactions with the browser and which
forms basically your id script and using
this id script which is a recorded
script you execute the script and verify
and monitor for its stability and
success rate and thirdly what you can do
is you can simply save your recorded
script for your future runs or
regression testing and these scripts can
be saved either in the form of an id
project itself or you can also export
these test scripts into the form of a
javascript or your ruby scripts or even
the web driver scripts now let's look at
the components of this id interface
itself the first one is the menu bar so
let's go back to our id window so here
in the menu bar what you can see is is a
project name so either you can edit the
project name here or you can simply
create a new project open an existing
project and save the current project so
these are all the options available and
since we have already created a project
here i will not be showing how to create
a new project so that we can do it
little later now next one is the toolbar
so this is the toolbar what we have here
for the id now there are multiple
components in the toolbar so let's see
one by one so it says run all test now
if you have multiple test cases written
okay so this is an option where all the
tests can be run one after the other
this is to run your current test which
the focus is on so currently our focus
is on search test so if i click on this
button it is going to execute the search
test for you ide has this debugger
option where you can do a step execution
right you can do step by step execution
using this option we'll see how to do
that for example let's say we start from
here okay and i click on this so what it
does is basically it has just executed
the first step for me so let's keep this
side by side so that we can observe the
complete execution now if i go and press
on this again step over current command
so that is the next command it is going
to execute now it says type into this
all right so now you can see the
selenium hq documentation okay then
again i say step send keys which it
basically it said enter and then it is
going to click on that documentation
which it did and now we have a script
written which scrolls down on this
particular page so let's execute that
and that is what it is so this is how
the step execution happens so let us
close this window and let us come back
to our id window then we have buttons
here where you can say record or you can
stop recording okay then you can pause
the execution and then there are other
options available for disabling
breakpoints so basically you can add
breakpoints any various so for example
if i want to add a breakpoint on the
click here so what i have to just do is
i have to just click here so this adds a
breakpoint and if you want to remove all
the spray point you just say disable
those break points so when you run the
script even though you have a breakpoint
available here for that particular run
your breakpoint will be disabled and
your execution will not stop at this
point and let's enable them for now and
what we will do is we'll just run the
script until there so now it has stopped
here at this click now from here either
you can execute the rest of the test
case by just clicking on this run button
or you can stop the execution okay so
for now what we we'll do is we'll just
stop the execution so once you stop the
execution you will see that this is in
red which means that this particular
line was not executed or it failed
either of the things because you have
aborted at this particular line and the
rest of the things what you see in green
it shows that all these test steps have
been executed successfully so what is
our next component let's come back here
so we saw the menu bar here we saw the
toolbar we saw start and stop of
recording address bar now what is this
address bar so this address bar is where
you actually write your url from where
you want to start your recording and as
in when you start writing more and more
test cases it keeps a complete history
of all the websites which you are
working on next then we have a test
script editor box which is this so let
me just minimize this little bit okay
this is nothing but your test script
editor box and this is where all your
script steps are all your interactions
are recorded now there are four
attributes in this okay can you see a
command now command is nothing but the
actual operation or the action performed
on your web element so there are
multiple actions you can perform like in
this case we have something called as
open we have got type we have got send
keys and we have got click so these are
all the selenium commands which are
available and then we have something
called as target now this target is
nothing but the web element on which you
want to perform the action and now this
target as i said earlier also it is
identified by multiple locating
techniques and if you click on any of
this like we looked at the name here now
similarly the website which we are
clicking on if you look at it there are
multiple locating techniques which are
available here so the one right now
which is being used is the css
identifier you can also have
xpath here which is a relative x bar so
these are all the locating techniques
and this is where which is applied on
the target value so value is an optional
field so you can send any value to your
web element for example in this case
where we are sending the value which is
our text which is
selenium hq dot documentation so this is
the value which i want to send it to as
a search text to my google.com and then
comment or the description so here you
can mention any description about that
particular line which you have recorded
for example i can say here sending
search text to the google search input
box and this gets recorded here against
your uh instruction now let's look at
the test case pane now test case pane
that is here so if you look here now it
contains all the test cases which you
have recorded now there are multiple
things here one is your tests say i can
always go ahead and create another say
ah test case two okay i can add a few
more test case here test case three so
all these test cases are here now i can
also have a test suite now there is
already test suite which i have created
which is called the google suite and now
if i want to add test cases under this
what i can do is i can just say add
tests and now i can add any of the
stress which i just created under this
test suite so say i have selected the
first three and i've added it so we have
test suite we have tests here and then
executing so executing is basically it
shows that particular test case which is
currently in the execution mode so
whichever test case we run you will see
all the test cases listed here which
have been executed at that point of time
that is your test case pane and then we
have test log and reference this is a
very important window which you need to
be aware of now here this is a running
log so as and when you are going to run
your test cases the every instruction
the every test step as and when it runs
it is going to log here whether it is
passed whether it has failed whether the
command was executed properly or not and
this is how it records it it's a running
law also there is something called as
reference tag now for example just go
ahead and ah let's select one of this
command which you have written here so
which is send keys now this reference it
will show you the complete description
of the command and how to use that
command so say for click it says
references click locator clicks on the
target element it gives you a complete
detail of what exactly the command does
let's create a test script now for say
amazon.com so let's go back to our ide
what we will do is we'll create a
completely new project so i'll click on
the create new project are you sure you
would like to without saving it yes
proceed further and let's give the name
as amazon project now in this new
project what i will do is i'll say i'll
add a test and my test name is search
iphone now basically what is the use
case which i'm going to automate so i
will launch amazon.com and i will search
for iphones and once i get the iphones
let's verify the title of that
particular page now just the simple
steps will go ahead and do that so for
that first what i need to do is i need
to enter the url now this url needs to
be a fully formed url so for that what i
will do i'll first launch amazon.in on
any browser i'll just copy this url and
i can close this browser window and in
this url address space i would say
amazon.com and i'll say enter and now i
would click on this recording button
which says start recording so once i do
this what it does is it launches the web
page with amazon.com and from there i
can start recording my script so let's
do that i'll say record it so
let me just keep this window side by
side so that you can see what is
happening on the id window here now here
what i will do is i'll click on the
search and i'll say iphone and i will
click on the search button and here i
will also click on this best seller once
i'm in this window i'll say right click
now when your selenium id is in the
recording mode you will get this option
here which says selenium id and there
are a lot of options here which you can
select now for this particular moment
what i want to do is i want to assert
the title so i'll just put an assertion
point here for assert title and then i
will close my browser window now let's
see what are all the commands which it
has recorded let's go one by one right
so it is done it is opening the amazon
dot in it is setting the window size
fine it clicked on the to search window
button and then iphone is what we are
searching and then it says submit it
it's basically clicking on that button
and then we said we also want to open
the bestseller link and here is our
asset title right so it's a very simple
test so let's go ahead and execute this
now since i also have a close command
here this script is going to execute so
fast that you will not be able to make
out all the steps what we have written
so for that what i will do i will
comment out the slide now how do you
comment out any command here just select
the command and can you see here enable
and disable command just click on it so
now your command is disabled also what i
will do is i will reduce the execution
speed so that you should be able to see
exactly what is happening so let's go
ahead and execute this test first so
i'll say run current test okay i have
not stopped the recording so that is the
first thing after closing the window i
also need to click on the stop recording
now your script is ready to be executed
so let's go and run the current script
again i'll just bring this side by side
so that you can see each of these
commands being executed here okay it has
searched for the iphone it's clicked on
the best sellers and it has done the
title assertion now if you look at the
log here as i said see every step as in
when it was executed it has been logged
here can you see here and it puts an ok
and it color coded in green which says
that this particular command was
executed successfully now let's go ahead
now this is what we did by simply
recording all the steps from the browser
now one more thing what we will do is
say i want to continue recording here
right i have not completed my test case
so what you can still do here is you can
come towards the end of the script and
press on record button again and then
you can continue recording from here now
say for example after the best sellers
what we have got say i want to click on
uh say hot releases hot new releases so
i do that okay it says it has recorded
the click and then i want to stop the
recording just the another step is what
i wanted to add now it has stopped the
recording so can you see this new line
which has got added so that means you
really need not restart recording all
the steps again if you want to add
something in the middle of your script
you can always go towards the end of the
script or anywhere in between and you
can add more commands there or you can
record anywhere in between the script
and that is how this does so let's go
ahead and again execute this then i will
show you another feature of this okay
it's done the title assertion now and it
is also clicked on hot new releases done
now let's say for example i need to add
another command here now instead of
going ahead and using this recording
what i will do is i'll manually add
certain command here say for example
let's go to this amazon website and say
you want to click on this card so let me
add a command manually here so what is
my command my command is click and then
what is that i want to click i need to
identify that web element for that i can
use this here which says select the
target in the page so i click on that
and i simply select this target which is
my cart and that is all i need to do so
my command is written there so i'll just
simply go ahead and execute this again
let's see what happens so let me close
this window here okay let's run this
test cases bring this window to the site
so now you can see one by one the
instructions being executed okay the
iphone has been searched the best seller
has been clicked assert title so it says
your shopping cart is empty so that
means it is successfully able to click
on the cart so now with using id there
are multiple things you can do you can
simply record your script while you are
running your test case you can add a
command all by yourself you can stop
recording anywhere and again restart
from the same point now we have our
complete test script ready now let's go
ahead and save this so how do you save
this simply go here and save your
complete project so all the projects
from the id are saved as dot side file
so let's name this as amazon project and
i will save it so if i show you in my
finder how it looks like this is the
project we created so it always stores
with the file extension dot sid right
that is selenium id now also i said you
can export test cases into multiple
format so search iphone is my test case
so what i can do is i can just say right
click and i can say export now right now
you can see only three options it says
java junit javascripts and python
however the older ide had multiple
options of export which had even the web
driver scripts and also the javascripts
this is still in works and they would be
adding more support for other
programming languages here so but for
now the only options what is available
to us is java junit javascript and the
python so let's go ahead and export this
into java j unit so it is going to
simply save it as dot java file so let
me go here in the id test i will save
this file so if you go back to my finder
you can find our search iphone test dot
java you can open the java file i can
you can see here it's a simple junit
test it is exported into so if you have
an eclipse ide you can use this test and
execute it from your eclipse side
selenium commands selenium commands can
be broadly classified into three action
commands accessors and assertions what
are action commands action commands are
the commands which interact directly
with the web elements on your
application so let's look at what these
commands are so if we go back to our
previous example where we had written a
test script for amazon dot in so if you
look at all these things like open set
window size click type so these are all
nothing but called as action commands
and if you go here you can see let me do
one thing so let me just come to a blank
line and now let's look at the list of
commands so you have a whole list of
commands here listed in the alphabetical
order like add selection there are
multiple asset commands which is made
available to you and then there are set
of commands where you say click or click
at a particular location closing the
browser using a debugger command double
click drag and drop echo i'll just
explain how to use an echo command so
this is a command which is not or used
on your web element but something which
you want to say display on your console
and then there are if else statements
which are used as commands here then you
have something called as execute script
for you to execute any say javascript or
any different script which you want to
execute from your test script here and
then you have few mouse commands here
open which is what we use for opening a
new url pause and so on so there are
multiple commands which you can look at
and try to use this commands in your
script so these are all called as the
action commands so let's go ahead and
use this echo command and see what it
does so now in the same script what i
will do is towards the end of the script
i'll just add this command i'll say echo
and say i want to just display a message
saying that this is
the end of the script execution that is
all i want to do now i'll just go ahead
and run this and what we want to observe
here is how this particular message what
we have given here is displayed on the
console in the log so now if you observe
here so go to this last statement what
we have so it says after clicking on the
card it said echo this is the end of the
script so this is what we displayed and
using the command echo okay so this is
how you can use the echo command another
feature here what you can do here is now
say for example i just added a simple
echo statement here now for me to
execute that what i did was i executed
the complete script you really need not
do that always instead of that what i
can do is i can just come to this
particular line i can just say right
click and i can say play from here so
what it does is from this point it is
going to play the script for me and not
right from the beginning of the script
so i'll show you how now with this
command if you look here see it started
running the script here it says running
search iphone and then it executed only
one command which says echo this is the
end of the script so this is also
possible to do with the id accessors
accessors are the selenium commands that
examine the state of an application and
store the results in a variable so these
are those commands which allow the user
to store say certain values into your
user defined variables and these stored
values can be later on used either to
create assertions or you can have some
verification points created so let's see
some of the store commands in action so
i have few store commands here which
i'll be demoing so first one is a store
so simply using a store command you can
store any kind of user defined messages
in a variable and then after that you
can either use it for displaying it on
your console or you can do some
assertions with that similarly store
title so you can to store the title of
any of the web page under test then
store text so store text is basically
used to uh capture the text attribute of
any web element on your web page and
store it in a variable use it as an
assertion point store value so store
value again is uh used to store the
value attribute of any web element like
so you have lot of web elements on the
web page and say one of the attributes
is what you want to do an assertion on
so what you can do is you can use the
store value command here get the value
attribute of your web element and store
it in a variable so let's see all these
commands in action so let's go back to
the same example so we have this amazon
test script example so what i'll do is
say instead of using amazon let's do one
thing so let's create another test case
itself so i'll go here i'll say add new
test and i will name this test as
accessor test and we will use the same
amazon site here i'll say click on start
recording keep this window side by side
so first we will look at store title so
simply what i need to do is go to this
amazon site which you have launched
right click on this go to the selenium
id and you have multiple options here so
go ahead and select store title so once
i click on that it is going to ask me
the variable name where i want to store
the title of this page so let's create a
variable here i'll say var title and
i'll say ok done now come back to your
ide all right so i will stop the
execution here now i have this store
title command i created a variable
called val title and i'm storing the
actual title into this variable so let's
also display this on our console so i'll
add a command here echo and in target
how do i use the variable now this is
the way to use it i'll say dollar and in
flower braces i will give the variable
name which i have defined earlier so it
is where i dle title okay so this is all
my scriptures where i'm storing the
title of the web page and i'm displaying
it in my console or the lock so now
there are some extra commands which gets
added here now because we are doing the
recording on that so whatever the mouse
movements happen it is going to record
we do not need this so i will go ahead
and delete this particular command so
let's close this window and execute this
test first so the script has executed
successfully but let's go and see
whether did we get the title displayed
on the console yes so it did open the
amazon site it has set the window size
it captured the title here in this line
and then after assigning it to the
variable we said echo and that variable
name and it is displayed as the title of
the page so now similarly let's go ahead
and let's see how do we use the store
text command now for store text i need
an use case here say for example what
about this cut let's say we want to
display the text of this particular
element now the text of this element is
cut so now instead of again going and
re-recording all the steps i will simply
manually add this command so now after
displaying the title okay so let's go
ahead here and i will say store text and
in store text i need to pick the text
from this web element cart so what i
will do is i'll use this target select
target and i will select this particular
element which is cut after this i need
to create a variable where it can be
stored so i'll say where car text now
similarly i will also display it using
echo comma echo dollar in the flower
braces i'll say where car text so let's
execute this and then let's look at the
other command so i'll just say i'll
close this window again run this test so
now look at this log lines so our last
statements was storing the title and
displaying the title after that we added
store text okay so here is the command
it said it is executed successfully it
was able to retrieve the text from the
element cart and the text retrieved was
cart and which is what got displayed
with the echo statement on our console
so now let's move to our next store
command which is store value now as i
said store value for us to use that
particular web element should have the
attribute value so first let's examine
which element we can take and display
the value now on the same website i have
the search button so i will right click
on this and i say inspect element now
look at all the attributes of this
element it is of type input it has a
class name it is of type submit and also
it has this value attribute which is
gogo and this is exactly what i want to
retrieve and print so we will be using
the search button now similarly same
thing what i will do here i'll go ahead
add a command here as a store value same
way i will select the target as i select
target from page i will click on the
search button all right so here it has
taken the target here in the value i
will mention the variable name where i
want to store the value so i'll say
where button and value and similarly i
will say echo and i will print the value
of this variable which is dollar where
btn value let's go ahead and execute
this and say run current test so it has
taken the title it has printed the value
on the line seven so it says store value
on this particular element and the value
was stored in the variable where btn
value so that command was successful and
the value actually which was got stored
and which we retrieved using echo
statement was jio and that's exactly
what we had here if you want to check
again go here to inspect element the one
which is highlighted so as we said the
value is go and that's exactly got
printed on our console now apart from
this i also said there is a simple
command which is just store so let's use
that also now after all this here i will
say store and say we want to just store
a user message i would say a target as
all store commands demod and this
message i will capture it in a variable
say var string since it's just a text
and then like i did it in the other
string then i'll say echo and the
variable name so now if we
close this and one way to do it is
execute the complete test so which will
execute all our store commands and also
the last line is this the line number
nine in the log which says the store
command which we use to store the text
all store commands demod and that is
also displayed using the x so all the
store commands we have demo successfully
now let's close this window and go back
to our presentation so this is all about
the accessor command now what do we have
after accessor so we have something
called as assertions now what is an
assert so assertion is nothing but it
verifies the current state of an
application with an expected state so
this is something where you compare your
actual result with the expected result
now assertions are of three different
type one is assert verify and wait for
now what does assert does when the
assert command is executed and if it
fails right the test stops immediately
after this statement so if you are
asserting say
a title of a page and if you find that
the title of page is not as expected as
soon as it finds that failure your rest
of the test case test is not going to
run and it's going to immediately stop
the test and also it is going to flag
the test cases fail what is verify
verify something where the selenium id
it locks that particular assertion as
fail however it would continue with the
rest of the steps in the test case and
then at the end of it the your overall
test case is flagged as fake that is
what verified us so verify is called a
soft assertion whereas assert here is
called as hard assertion why it is
called hard decision because as soon as
an assert statement fails the complete
test execution stops at that statement
whereas in soft hazard what happens is
after the failure happens the test
continues with the rest of the steps and
continue it completes its execution and
then flags the test case as failure and
when is this usually used in cases like
as the same example say if you are
asserting a title you really do not want
the test case execution to stop even if
there is a failure why because none of
your steps are going to be dependent on
this assertion point and this is where
you will require a soft hassle wait for
wait for something which waits for a
certain condition to be true after that
it proceeds to your further steps so if
the condition goes false here for
whatever say if you are waiting for an
element to appear on the web page and if
that element does not appear the test
fails however it carries forward and
completes the test by executing the rest
of the steps and then flags the complete
test case as a failure which will be
something similar to a softer cell so
let's see all these things in action
let's go back to our id we will create
another test case here so i'll say
assert test now for this what's the
example we can take so first for assert
title let's do the assert title on
amazon itself and let's change the same
test case to verify and see how this
test case behave now for this i will
launch the recorder with the same amazon
dot in okay my recorder is launched now
simply i will go to this website and
i'll say right click selenium ide and
i'll say assert title then i will stop
the recording now here i will remove
this command which has got added which i
don't need so this is my asset title now
we have already seen a third title
passing in couple of our other examples
now i want to show you failure on
ourselves so for that what i will do i
will modify this actual type so here in
the last line i'll just remove this
amazon.com so now ideally this test case
is going to fail first because the title
which it is expecting and what it is
comparing against are not the same first
let's execute this um well i also need
to show some statements after this so
what i will do is uh let's add few more
statements here let me start the
recording here again say after asserting
the title we want to go and click on
this best seller and then i will close
this now let's execute this stop the
recording and execute this test now do
you see this assert title is in red that
means it has failed the validation here
so you see here in the log it says open
the site done set window size done when
it comes to azure title it says actual
value was something different and it did
not match with what you were trying to
look for assert test ended with one
error now after this assert please
observe that there are no other
statements which got executed this test
stopped right away after this failure
this is called as hard assert now let's
go ahead and change this assert title to
verify title so simply what i will do in
the command itself instead of assert
i'll say verify title and now let's
execute this and see what happens now
let me close this window first and then
i'll say run test running assert test
amazon dot in was open window size was
set verify title failed because the
titles were different because we have
modified that however do you see this
fourth line being executed click on link
test bestseller and click on close now
since i it was a very fast execution and
i closed the browser probably was you
were not able to see the best sellers
clicked here that is fine but in the log
we can see here that the steps 4 and 5
got executed even after the title verify
title step fit and if you compare it
with the previous example where assert
title failed the two lines after that
the line 4 where we are clicking on the
best seller and closing the browser are
not getting executed so this is the main
difference between the verify title and
the asset title so now let's look at
wait for how do we use wait for now for
wait for i want to look at some kind of
website where it would load an element
ah dynamically after a while so for that
i have a website here let's let's create
a new test again let's go to the tests
pane i will say assertion test and now
uh let's go to a browser we open
a new window and there is a demo site
which i want to use so let me search for
that and then i will use that url so
i'll say internet i'm going to use the
dynamic loading do we have here yes
dynamic loading page
element rendered now see if you look at
this website when i press on the start
button right after a while this hello
world text is going to appear on this
webpage so in our use case what we will
do we will launch this website we will
click on the start button and then we
will put an assert on this text using
wait for let's do that so let's go here
let me copy this this is the one let me
say control c and in my new test i'll
say control v and then i'll say start
recording so it's going to launch this
let's close the previous windows now in
this i'm just going to click on start so
that is going to get recorded done and
now while the recording is still on i
will add a command here for wait for so
i'll say wait for element visible that
is exactly what we are saying right so
wait for is used until for a condition
and until that condition is true so i am
saying here please wait for this
particular element which i am going to
give it in target until it is visible
now the target is i'm just going to
select the target from this web page
itself so i'll say select target and i'm
going to select this particular text
come back here to your id so wait for
the element to be visible what is the
element to be visible is this hello
volta hello world text and then you need
to give a value here now what is this
value since we are using wait for we
need to mention a timeout so we have to
tell basically to id that okay wait for
say one second two seconds or three
seconds whatever it is required and that
timeout value is needs to be mentioned
here so and this is in milliseconds so
what i will say is i'll say so let's
fail this test case first so i'll use a
little lesser timer so i'll say 3000 so
that is 3000 milliseconds which is three
seconds that is it and then we can say
so what we'll do here is we'll add an
asset so i will say assert text now what
is the other text i'm going to do i need
to look for the same element so i'll
simply say select target this one and
what is that i'm going to assert with
i'm going to assert with the same text
so i'll just copy this text and i'll put
it in the value there's another way of
doing that which we have done it
previously so i can just go here do a
right click go to selenium id and i can
say assert text which is basically going
to give me the same command so let me
just go ahead and remove one of them
either of them you can remove okay so
let's stop the recording i will not
close this browser because i want you to
see how the dynamically loaded element
behaves and will go ahead and execute
this so i'll say stop recording and say
execute this test now it's here all
right so it's waiting okay it has failed
now see this so it says wait for element
visible after that the value we have
mentioned is 3000 that is wait for 3
seconds which was not enough because and
it failed with saying that unable to
locate the element within the timer
period now let's go ahead and change it
to a passing value so i will say 10 000
here which is 10 seconds so let's close
this
and let's again execute this bring this
to the side so that we can see okay it
is waiting on that wait for element now
look at the problem here what we have
done is we have closed the website and
after that we have added the assert text
so this is a mistake what we have done
and hence though it is found that
element here for wait for what did it do
it went ahead and closed the window and
after that it's definitely not going to
find the ascertain right so that's the
mistake what we have done so let's go
ahead and debug this so what we will do
after this wait for element we want this
assert to be put after that we don't
need this click content because this was
an additional step which got added
delete it and then close okay fine so
now let's go ahead and rerun this we'll
say run current test i'll move this to a
side okay it's waiting all right done so
now it is able to do an assert text on
this all right so this is how you use
the wait for key features of selenium id
let's look at the first feature
reusability of test scripts so many of
the test scripts have test steps that
involves signing into an application or
creating an account like for example a
login screen is a very
key example in this case where whenever
you are testing your application first
you need to log in and then perform any
other test so now it's going to be a
redundant or a waste of time to recreate
the login steps again and again for each
and every test case so we do not want to
definitely do that so as we know since a
record and replay tool does not have
enough capability of writing
common test cases or a common functions
and calling those common factions like
our regular selenium webdriver has
however what id is done is it has given
us a provision to run one script from
another script so what basically what we
do here is especially for a login we
write one test case which is going to
log into your application and call this
test case in the other test cases so
let's take a a look at how this works so
for that let's go to our id so in this
id
we'll do one thing let's go ahead and
create a new project so let's say login
project in this project i will create a
new test case we'll call it as login
test let's say add now in this login
test i need to give a url now for this
purpose i will be using again a demo
site so first let me
launch a demo site here file new window
and i will see the demo site go dot uk
okay this is a simple demo site which
has a login functionality right so here
i will go to the login screen now this
also allows me to add few users and
using the same users we can go ahead and
do the login now coming back to our
login page so this is the url which i
need to launch which is going to give us
username and password we will use to
login into this application so give this
url here and say start recording move
this window here for recording and this
here now what is the first step we want
to record we want to come here click on
the username and i'll say user1 okay and
i'll say password pwd1 and i will click
on test login and then what we will do
is we will assert this text so here i'll
say right click selenium id assert text
that's it and then i will close the
browser okay this is all my test is now
come back to your id let's see if there
are any unnecessary commands which it
has taken okay click type all done and
now for the time being i'm going to
comment out this close comment because i
want the browser to be still open so
that we can see the actual test
execution properly till the end of the
script this is the login test case now
simply if i run this let's execute this
let me execute this and show stop the
recording and execute this test case so
it typed user one it typed pwd which is
my password here and then clicked on the
button and then definitely it was the
wrong password so it gave me fail
docking so this is fast fantastic
however this is with one value i have
used it but this is a function which i
want to use it every time and also a
probable use case i might have is that i
might need to login with a different
user id and password and apart from that
even just to test this login test page i
would want to test with multiple user id
and password like valid credentials and
invalid credential now for that purpose
what we will do is we will parameterize
this name that is user id and the
password and how do i parameterize it
simply go here instead of giving a hard
coded value here what you can do is just
say use any variable name here and we'll
define this variable somewhere else so
i'll say username this is the variable
similarly for my password in my value
field instead of a hard coded value i'll
say dollar and i will say password now i
cannot run this program as it is because
there is this variable is not defined in
the login.test what i will do now is i
will create my actual test case so i'll
say here i'll say invalid credential as
my test case and i'll say add now here
is where i will assign values for my
variable now which are these variables i
need to use username and password so i
need to assign some value here and then
call this function login test so let's
do that in this video previously we also
saw how do we use user variables and how
do we assign value by using the store
command so i'm going to say store and
then my target is going to be the actual
value so
user1 and where is that i'm going to
pass this to my variable username so
let's just check once if the variable
name is username yes all right done now
i have done the username now i need to
pass the password so i again i'll say
store the actual password which is pwd1
in my case and what is the variable i
need to use here i have to use password
because that's the variable which we
have used in login test here and then
after that i need to use a command which
is called as run now what this run
command does is run and whatever target
you give which is basically your another
test case it is going to run the test
case now in our case our test is login
test this is all our test case is going
to be okay so what is that we did we do
in this test case we created a variable
username and password and assigned the
actual username and password and then we
are just calling this login test and in
this login test this username and
password will get passed which will be
user1 and pwd1 and then it will execute
this test with the or with the value
which we have passed to this variable so
now which test case we need to run the
invalid credential so let's go ahead
close this window and execute this test
executed so now look at the log of this
invalid credential test see running
login test called by invalid credential
before that it said store this value
store user1 in the value username that
is your variable this is this line and
then the password then it says run login
test so it called the login test
functionality and in the login test we
have all this clicking on the password
field clicking on the username and then
asserting the text and that's exactly
what is done here this is how you use it
so now let's write one more test here
for the same login test so let me add
another test i'll say valid credentials
and let's say add now same thing i will
do here i'll say command store my target
will be now i'll say user3 value will be
username right okay now second command
will be again storing this time it is
for the password my password is pwd3 and
the variable name is password and same
thing i'll just call run and my login
test that's it now similarly let's run
this test and see what happens now this
test is going to fail why let me close
this window i don't need this why did
this test case fail because my assertion
point let's go to the tests i'll show
you my assertion point in login test is
look for failed login however we created
a test case for valid credentials right
because our valid credentials were said
that the login was successful which did
not match with what we were asserting
which is fine right so we just wanted to
see whether we can write a test case
with valid credentials and invalid
credentials and this is how you do that
by passing the variables through your
test case to your actual test case the
next feature is the debugger in the ide
like every other id offers a debugger
functionality so does selenium id so
let's look at what are the different
functions available for us in the
debugging so there are multiple
functionalities which the selenium ide
offers us so one is called as the step
execution so for us to look at how each
of these debugging techniques works what
i'll do is let's go ahead and create a
new test script so let's go to our ide
and i will create a new test case so
i'll say new test case let's use uh
facebook login this time so i'll say fb
login test or we'll just say fb test so
now for this fb test i would go ahead
and use the facebook login page so i'll
just copy this url paste it here and
then i will minimize this other firefox
window and i will launch the recorder
now so i'll click on start recording now
let's keep this side by side and what is
that we are going to do here is let's
do a simple login functionality so i'll
just use some email id here so i'll say
my user at gmail.com this is just a
dummy user id and password i'll use and
i'll say password as password1 then i'll
click on login button let's stop the
recording here so let's read the script
once whether it has got everything
whatever we need okay it has launched
facebook it clicked on email id there's
a double clicks here because i happen to
click twice on the email id field so
what i'll do i'll remove one we don't
need it and then i'm typing the keys
which is myuser.gmail and then i'm
clicking on the password field typing
the password and clicking on the login
button and then once i do that okay so
i'm going to get this pages the password
you have entered is incorrect so let it
be so we will use the script until here
and
check out some of the login options okay
so we have completed writing of the
script let me go ahead and close this
window now first thing what we will do
is we'll just simply execute the script
so we have to just say run current test
so it's going to log login your facebook
it'll enter my user at gmail it'll enter
the password it'll log in and that's
about it so now your script is executed
now let's go into the debug mode as we
said there are multiple options for
debugging what is the first option let's
see the first option we have is
something called a step execution so
what the step execution does is from
your script you can execute all the
steps one after the other so you can
basically control the execution of each
step and how you do that what you have
to do is just go and click anywhere so
let's start from the beginning let's
close this window of our previous run
and there is an option here which says
step over current command so when you
click on this what it does is it
basically executes your first line where
your cursor was and it stops immediately
after that so if you look here it has
launched the facebook page which says
open the url facebook and then let's go
ahead and just do the simple step
execution again i will click on that it
is going to execute this command where
it set the window size to certain value
again i will do a step execution now
observe what happens here it clicked on
this email field do you see the cursor
there now let's do the next step again
again i will do step over current
command now the current command was it
entered my user at gmail you can see it
on the left side here now it will be
more visible again i will do a step
execution it is going to click on the
password field now it is going to enter
the password and now the last step is
it's going to click on the login button
and with this all our commands are
executed and this is how you do the step
execution and now where is this useful
say if you've got a very long test case
written and you want at certain point
you want to start doing the step
execution to see where your test cases
fail probably one of your web element
you entered is wrong or probably the
text which you are entered is wrong so
for you to debug such cases you can use
this step over current command
functionality so what's our next command
breakpoints so there are break points
which you can insert in your script okay
so let's close this execution and let's
come back to our script so what i will
do is first let's add a breakpoint how
do you add a breakpoint say for example
we want to add a breakpoint after we
type in our email id so here what i do
is i simply go and click here so once
you click here this is where your
breakpoint is added other way of adding
breakpoint is you can right click on any
command and you can use this toggle
breakpoint so if there is no breakpoint
it adds the breakpoint and for you to
remove it you can simply go and select
the toggle breakpoint again so now i've
added a single breakpoint now what you
need to do is once you execute this once
you say run test what it will do is it
will come till here till your break
point it will execute all the commands
before that and it stops or pauses your
execution at this point okay let's go
ahead and see how it does so what i'll
do is i've added a breakpoint at the
click on password field and i will say
execute this test do you see here it
says paused in the debugger so by adding
breakpoint my test has entered the
debugging mode and where has it stopped
to at the point where i added this
breakpoint so just go back here and see
whether the previous steps have been
executed yes my previous step was adding
this my user at gmail.com into the email
field which it is done and it has paused
here and now from here i can either run
the rest of the tests if i just click on
this run current test what it will do is
it will go ahead and execute all the
steps or even i can do a step execution
from here so say if i want to do a step
execution i'll do this let me minimize
this window a little bit so that you can
see and i'm still again doing that step
execution so it added the password and
after this i'll say just go ahead and
complete the test so just clicked on
your sign in login button and it is
logged in so this is how you can use the
breakpoint so that is about adding the
breakpoint let's see what's the next
removing the breakpoint so i showed you
so if you want to add a breakpoint you
just click here or you can do a right
click and do toggle breakpoint if you
want to remove the breakpoint just click
again on the same place where it has
added the breakpoint or you can always
do this toggle breakpoint so this is the
way of adding and removing the
breakpoints what is the third option
disabling now say for example my test
case is a pretty long one okay so i
might have a multiple breakpoints so say
let's add one breakpoint here at the
email and then before clicking on login
let's add another breakpoint now when i
execute this it is going to stop here
and then again if i say continue
execution it is going to come and stop
here so let's do that first and then
i'll show you how the disable works so
let's close this window again execute
this bring this window here can you see
this it's paused here okay and here now
you should be able to see now i'll say
just run after this breakpoint do you
see here it is paused after entering the
password it has not clicked on the login
button it's paused at the click and now
i'll say again complete the test so your
click on the login button is done and it
is logged in so it's a little bit slow
yeah now you got that logged in page at
some point of time while i'm debugging
my test case i would want to just
disable all the breakpoints and not
remove everything for that i have an
option here which says disable
breakpoint so if this button is
highlighted here that means i have
selected disable breakpoint so what this
does is when i execute this test it
ignores all this breakpoints for this
run it ignores this breakpoints until i
have selected this disable breakpoint
button okay so let's see this let me
close this again and i have enabled this
disable breakpoint is what i have
selected i'll just simply go ahead and
run this test case do you see that it
did not stop at this breakpoint it went
ahead and completed the execution why
because i have temporarily disabled it
once i remove the selection and run it
it is again going to stop at the
breakpoints so this is how it works so
we saw adding of breakdowns removing of
breakpoints and disabling of breakpoints
what is the next one enter debugger by
using play to this point option okay now
another way of doing this is so let's
remove all this breakpoint now for
example like the last time we said we
want to add a breakpoint here so now
instead of doing that what i can do also
do is i can just right click on that
particular command and i can say play to
this point only so when i select this
what happens it acts like a break point
and it comes and pauses at this
particular command where i have set play
till this point so let's try to do that
so let me close this window and then for
say type the password so here okay i'll
say right click play to this point so it
is going to execute all the steps until
the password and it will stop here can
you see this paused in the debugger so
it again enter the debug mode and now it
has stopped at this point so now there
are multiple options now every time last
time what we did we did a step over and
also we said continue with the rest of
the test now what we will do we'll just
stop the execution so this is also an
option available say if you want to
change something here you do not want to
continue with your execution you can
simply go ahead and stop the execution
so we saw how do we use the play to this
point option now debugger command now
all these things whatever we did now
adding the breakpoints this was done in
the id there is also a way of adding a
debugger programmatically and how do we
do that let's see now at the same place
say after entering the password so here
i will insert a command in this command
i'll just say debugger this is all the
command is now what happens when i
execute this test cases at this point
wherever it finds this debugger command
this program enters into a debug mode
and it comes and pauses the script here
let's see this in action so simply i'll
just play the script let's type the
email id it's typed the password okay it
is going little slower here okay and
there there you go now it is paused in
deepak so this debugger did the same job
as what we did earlier with the
breakpoints now let's go ahead and just
stop the execution because let's not
keep logging into facebook with invalid
username and id okay so this is how you
can use the debugger command so i will
stop the execution here close this
window and then now let's see the next
one let's close this window so we saw
the debug pause on exception okay this
is a very brilliant feature of this id
i'll show you how it works now let's say
let me remove this command now i do not
want the debugger i'll say delete this
command just click click it be there now
if you look at this what we are doing is
we are identifying these elements like
email password and then clicking on the
login button now say for example say
this click so
let's run this then i'll show you what
it is and i wanted to come and stop here
okay so i will execute this all right so
now it is paused here so now what i will
do is the click right so this is where i
am clicking is this login button so this
login button is identified by some
identifier which is an id now there is a
possibility that tomorrow this
particular id might change or any of the
locator might change on this particular
website and if that happens the first
point of failure what you will see is
when you click on this button because
this script will say that this element
is not found in such cases if you are
using pause on exception that is here
pause an exception what happens is
whenever this script finds an exception
it goes and pauses at that and enters
into a debug mode otherwise what happens
whenever you find an exception your
complete test script will stop executing
because there is an error and your test
case fails instead since we are in a
debugging mode if you choose this option
what happens is if there is an exception
it is going to come get into the
debugger mode and it is going to pause
the execution at that point and once it
pauses what you can do is you can go and
correct it and then continue your
execution so let's see that in action so
now for example the click button so here
the id is you underscore 0 underscore a
so say i try to change this let me add 1
here and then if i execute this this
script should fail for me basically
because it is not going to find this so
can you say is trying to find this id
and since this particular element with
this id does not exist this whole test
case should fail for me now as i said
earlier in this video so if by any
chance if one of the element id is not
found so if that is not found it always
falls back into the other locator
techniques and that is what it did in
this case it tried to locate the login
button using some other id and that's
what it says element found with the
secondary locator okay to use it by
default update the test step and to use
it as a primary locator and that is
where the test case pass so let's try to
see if i can make this test case fail in
any way for that let's remove this and
let's try on the email id so what i will
do is let me try to comment this out
remove the debugger and i will add a
command here i'll say insert new command
and in this i will say click and then i
will use the target as id equal to email
now in this case i do not have a
fallback id because i am not using ide
to recognize the element rather i added
my own command and i added my own
locator here so now let's try with this
and now instead of this is the right id
so what i will do is i'll just change
this id to something like underscore one
so that this test case fails for me now
let me close this and let's run this
test case and basically this test case
should fail so if you see here in the
log it's saying trying to find the
element with id email underscore 1. so
this id has a default timer so it will
keep trying to find the element until
the timeout value is completed now there
we go so it had an implicit timeout of
30 000 so that is 30 seconds 30 000
milliseconds which was 30 seconds now
after that this test is filled so this
is the scenario we wanted what happens
here is it simply started executing the
moment it found an exception it
completely stopped so as a tester what
you need to do is you need to go back
look for this red lines where it has
failed correct it and then rerun the
whole test now instead of that what this
pause and exception does is let me click
on that so this is what is selected now
what it does is when i execute this this
is going to come and stop here let's see
that so let me close this and run this
program again so run current test i'll
bring this to the side now see it's
trying to find the id since the timeout
is almost 30 seconds we need to wait
until it pauses at this so now do you
see this now it is not exited from the
test it is just at the same step where
it is unable to find this email field
okay and it's saying okay it failed with
an implicit timeout of 30 seconds but
now since i'm in the debugging mode and
how did i get into the debug mode by
selecting this option pause and
exception now what i can do is i can go
ahead and change this back to the actual
one and then from here i can just simply
do this i can say run the test now so
now see what it did the moment i changed
that and i said run it passed and how
did it pass because i gave the right id
here and that's exactly you can do with
this debugger control flow statements so
in the legacy id uh these control flow
statements were available as plugin so
one had to install the plugin for you to
use any of this control flow statements
however in the new ide these are
available out of box so let's see what
this control statements are so let's go
to my notes so there are two types of
control flow statements one is
conditional branching and the other one
is looping so in conditional branching
we have a regular if else if nested if
else and end and when we talk about
looping there are multiple loops
available one is the while end loop so
how does the while end loop work the
code between the while and the end is
executed until the expression is true
and then we have a do repeat so do
repeat where the commands after the do
will get executed first and then the
condition is checked and this is
evaluated in the if statement times end
so you can specify a number of
iterations you would like a piece of
code to be executed using this loop and
then there is another loop which is a
for each loop so this provides the
ability to iterate over collection
objects like say if you have an array
object with you and you want to say or
traverse through the array and perform
certain operations on each of the array
element so that is possible using the
for each loop so let us go and write a
test script and see how this work so
what i will do is i will demonstrate a
use case for the if else and then for
the looping i have a few test scripts
which i have already written which i
will show you and i will walk you
through them it's a simple counter which
we can use where it will be incrementing
the counter using one of these loops so
we will just uh see how the loops are to
be used what is the syntax to be used
and how they execute in the id so let us
go to our id now let us minimize this so
this was our previous test case so what
i will do is i will close this project
and open another project so i have
another project here which is called as
control flows so as i said i have few
scripts written for some of the loop
however for the demo use case we will go
ahead and write a new script so i'll say
add new test and
we are going to be working with a demo
site called calorie calculator okay so
let me name the test case itself as
calorie calculator test so let us look
at what is our use case now in this use
case this is my use case i am saying go
to this gallery counter website okay so
let's see what that website is i have
this website open here so this is a
calorie calculator website in this
website we are saying if the gender is
male then click on the mail radio button
so you have multiple fields here where
you are accepting the age of a person
the gender of a person the height the
weight and then the activity level of
the person and when when you click on
calculate this is going to give you the
number of calories so for our purpose
for our demo use case what we will do is
we will store the gender to be selected
in a variable say for example i want a
gender female to be selected and then i
am going to write an if condition here
that if the gender is male right so if
the gender is male then click on the
mail radio button here and then i'm
saying click active from the activity
drop down so there's a drop down called
activity here in this i'm going to go
and select active as daily exercise or
intense exercise three to four times a
week this is what i am going to be
selecting and if the gender is female so
if the value passed from the gender is
female then what is that i want to do i
want to click on this radio button
female and select very active intense
exercise from this activity dropped up a
very simple use case so this is what we
are going to write in our test script so
let's minimize this window or we can
just close this window for now we do not
need this and here so how do we start
this test case i need to enter the url
so for me to enter the url let me go to
that copy this url ctrl c minimize this
and control v done so now here i will
start my recording by clicking on the
start recording button so now this url
is open now the first thing what i need
to do is in my test script i need to
write a open command so i'll say open
and my target is what this url done the
next command is as per our use case i
want to store the gender to be selected
in a variable so we will use the store
command and when we use the store
command we need to specify the target so
let's say the target is
f and where is that i want to store i'll
create a var gender that's my variable
so i have stored this now what is the
next thing i want to do so once i have
stored this first is i need to put an if
statement because my use case is if the
gender is male and if the gender is
female now since by default the male is
already selected here so let's put an if
condition for this condition if the
gender is female okay so that is exactly
what i am going to do so here i will say
if in the command once i say if in the
target you need to specify the condition
now condition is i want to check for
dollar that's my variable var gender i
want to check if this is equal to f and
how is that i can check i need to use 3
equal to here in double quotes i'm going
to mention f now this is what i have
stored in the variable bar gender this
is what i'm going to check so if this is
the condition in the next line now all
the next lines whatever i'm going to
mention are the ones which will be
executed if this condition is true now
in the next line what i want is i want
to select this radio button correct so
now what i will do instead of writing
all the commands manually i will now use
a recorder to do that since i'm already
in the recording mode i'll just go to
the url or the website here and i'll go
click on this female so on the right if
you see these steps are getting recorded
and then our use case also said that
from the activity drop down we want to
select very active so now if you look
here all our steps have been recorded so
i clicked on the female radio button and
then we selected the id activity here
which is our activity drop down and then
we clicked on the desired value which is
very active and then you end the if
statement here so but we also want to
add an else statement so instead of
saying end here i will say else so that
means if the gender selected is male
okay what is that we want to do i want
to go and select in the activity field
as active because the mail is already
selected so i'm not going to select it
again and then i will end the if loop by
end statement that is all so this is all
my script is so let's stop the recording
here there are some mouse move mouse up
which i really do not need so what i
will do is i'll just delete this so this
is the simple statement what i need in
the else where i'm saying select so
select is something a command which is
used to select a web element which is
your drop down so you select the drop
down here and once the drop down is
clicked and then you go ahead and click
on
this particular target is nothing but
your active daily exercises or intense
this value from the drop down is what
i'm selecting and same same thing what
we did in the if statement so let's
remove these also we don't
mouse move at and mouse up at so all
these statements we don't need so same
thing if i am saying the if statement
says if the gender is f that is female
click on the radio button then go to the
select activity select the activity by
clicking on very active and then end the
loop so this is all our scriptures now
let's go ahead and execute this and see
whether it works so let's minimize this
window and i will simply say execute the
current test let's slow down the
execution speed little bit so that you
can observe what exactly is happening
now i'll say run the current test so the
calorie calculator is open so we are
passing the value f for the gender
correct so that means it entered this
loop you can see here in the log so if
the gender is f which is female yes it
found the condition to be true and then
it clicked on this radio button it went
to the select field which is your
activity drop down it selected the very
active option from here and then it
ended now in the same program what i
will do instead of f let's pass the
value m mail and let's see what happens
and then we will go ahead and execute
this program so let's close this window
again and execute the test script again
so now according to the script we are
not re-selecting the radio button
because this is already selected by
default and in this descript if you see
now all the green colored one if you see
okay the open command ran successfully
store command successfully it came to
the if condition it checked if the
gender was f or m it found that this
condition is not true so can you see
here all these other statements in the
if are in black color that means these
were not executed instead it came to the
else part and then it executed all the
commands in the else part so this is how
you use a if condition in your selenium
id so let's close this now as i said
there are other looping statements what
we have like while end loop or do repeat
and time set so i have couple of
examples written here let's walk through
that and see so let's take the while
loop first so what happens in this while
loop let's see in this while loop what
i'm basically doing is i have created a
counter and i'm counting it from 1 to 5
and then displaying the value of the
counter and i am using a while loop for
that so here it says first i am setting
a counter value to 1 and then i am
saying while the counter value is less
than 5 this is the loop while and end so
whatever commands are within that those
get executed until the condition is true
so this loop will get executed until the
counter becomes 5. so once it sees that
counter is 5 it is going to exit the
loop and just print the value of the
counter it's as simple as while loop so
just pay attention to the syntax the way
it has been used here so this execute
script is what a simplest statement what
i have used this could be anything it
could be any of your web elements you're
performing certain operations say there
is a calculator which you are using say
a calculator under test so if you want
to key in certain numbers until say the
sum of the numbers is 30 or something an
example like that could be a valid use
case for your while loop so you could
use that so let's execute this and see
how the counter works so if i execute
this command so now take a look at the
log here this is running while test so
first statement where it assigned the
counter value and then it got into the
while loop and it executed the volume
until the counter was assigned the value
5 and once the counter became 5 the
while loop got exited and we are
printing the counter value so this is
how a while loop is used now similarly
the same function of using a counter i
have tried to use a do loop here so
let's look at it now in the do loop what
happens is the first the script is
executed because it's the first command
after the do statement so whatever is
between the do and repeat if is executed
and then the condition is checked here
so here what i'm doing is i'm just first
assigning a counter with value 0 and i'm
incrementing the counter every time by
10 and then i have a condition that once
the counter becomes 50 please exit the
loop that's all i'm doing here and
another statement what i have written
here is every time the counter gets
incremented i am printing the value of
the counter so let's execute this can
you see that the way it is executing it
alright now let's see the log running do
loop test okay the counter has been
initialized to 0 and then it executes
the script and this script is doing what
it is just incrementing the counter by
10 the counter becomes 10 and then 20 30
40 and 50. so as soon as it becomes 50
it's going to exit the loop and print
the value of the counter so one thing to
notice is there is no web element or
website testing which i am doing from
the script however one thing what the id
needs is it needs a starting point so
whenever you create a new test kit it
asks you to at least give it a url from
where it can start though it is not
going to launch that url it is going to
launch your browser definitely before
even it executes a single line of test
so that is something a mandatory in the
ide so we saw do loop we saw the while
loop there's also something called as
time slope so which is what i have said
here times and n so this is something
you can specify a number of iterations
you would like to perform a set of
commands so now in this example what am
i doing i'm simply incrementing a
counter by one right and i'm saying just
increment that is this is the only
command which i want to execute but i
wanted to execute two types that's all
so there is no other conditions here it
is simply saying there is a set of
command or a single command which i want
to execute it twice and the number of
times which i want to execute is what i
mentioned here in the target so first
initially i am assigning a counter with
value 100 and then i am saying increment
this counter by one two times and then
print the value of the counter so let's
execute this and then change the number
of times so if i say run test here so
can you see this the number of times it
got titrated and now the value is 102
why because initial value was 100 in the
loop which is the time slope i am saying
the iterations is two two times execute
the command which increments the counter
by one so that is why your counter value
becomes 102. now say i increase this to
say 10 so that we get a feel of how the
loop executes here and same thing i will
execute it now see it you can visually
see the number of times the loop is
getting executed all right and in the
log you can see the values also here
okay can you see here so this loop
executed 10 times and hence the counter
value becomes 110 so these are a simple
ways of using these loops in the id so
you can implement this loops for any
kind of functionality you may want to
perform on your web elements or any
logic which you want to build for your
test cases
selenium side runner selenium side
runner is a command line runner tool
which allows the user to run your
selenium id test cases on any browsers
or to run the test cases parallelly and
also it gives you a mechanism to use the
grid setup to run your test cases on a
remote machine okay so for us to work
with this selenium side runner there are
certain
installations which we need to do and
some of the installation prereqs are one
is you need a node.js server and what is
this node.js server node.js server is a
powerful javascript based platform and
this is the platform which is
intensively used by many developers
across the world for developing their
web applications and it's an open source
and it is available free of cost to
everyone to use it so we will need to go
ahead and install a node.js server for
this so now let us look at all the
installation steps which are involved in
installing the side runner and running
it okay so let's go to my notes so the
seleniumhq.org has a complete
documentation on how to install this
command line runner how to use it and
what are the different ways we can use
this runner i'll just show you where it
is and you can use this as a reference
for any of the tests which you're
creating and using the side runner to
run it
so let me open a new window here let's
go to this website
so if you see here it has a complete
guide on how to use this command line
runner right including the setups what
is the prereqs installing the browser
drivers
and
how do you do the different
configurations which are available with
the side runner so you can configure
various browsers with that you can set
different capabilities for the browser
if you want to use the selenium grid to
run your test cases on remote servers it
also gives you complete details on how
to do that and also using the parameters
changing your base url so this is a
complete guide which you can refer to
when you're working with the site runner
okay so let's go back to our
installation
so coming back to our installation here
so the first prereq what we need for the
selenium side runner to run is your
node.js okay so if you go to this
website
let nodejs.org open the same
browser okay
all right so here you will see that the
node.js is available as an installable
for all the platforms like do you have a
windows installer you have mac os
installer you have linux installers also
so if you're working with the windows
machine there are two options for you
either you can go ahead and download the
msi installer or you can just download
the zip and unzip it into any folder on
your system and since i'm using mac
machine what i have done is i have
downloaded this version pkg version and
have installed it on my machine okay so
once you download say if you're working
on the windows machine so say 64-bit is
what you require and you click here and
download the zip package i'll show you
how the folder structure looks like so
this is where i have downloaded the
node.js installable now if you look at
the windows one so this is what happens
when you download the zip file and unzip
it this is the folder structure it
creates and this is what we would need
right so npm is something which we would
be using to install all the packages
which are required on this node.js
server and i'll explain to you what
those packages are okay so once you do
this installation you need to go and
check if your installation is gone
properly or not so for that what you do
is go to your terminal window or in your
case if you're using a windows machine
just open a command prompt right and
then you have to just give this command
here you say npm minus v which is
basically saying what is the version of
the node.js which we have installed
which is 6.9 okay now what is this npn
npm is nothing but it's a node.js
package manager and it gets installed
with your node and this is used to
install all your other packages or what
it is called as modules on your system
so now with this we know that our npm
has been installed properly so let's
move to the next step of installation so
now we have our node.js installed now
next thing is to install the selenium
side runner now the selenium side runner
is a library which is available to us
and we need to install this library
using the npn so let me go back to my
terminal again so i'll just show you the
command what it is what we use for
installing this package or the library
and since i've already installed on my
machine i will not be doing the
installation here so what you need to do
so if you are a windows user you can
directly give the command as npn install
minus g selenium side runner okay so
this is the command which you need to
get however if you're a mac user or a
unix user since you need to use a root
user here what you need to do is just
say sudo once you press enter here it
will go ahead and install this complete
library on your system now since i've
already installed i'm not going to do
that okay so i'll just exit from this
now once the installation is done how do
you check whether your installation has
gone correctly or not you have to just
simply give a command like selenium side
runner minus version okay and now this
will give you the version number if the
installation has been successful so
right now the version installed which is
the latest version is 3.11 okay so so
far we have done the installation of the
node.js server we have done the
installation of the selenium now while
you also you do this installation you
need to know that where is the selenium
ide side runner has been installed right
as i said it's a library or what you
popularly call as module in your npm
right so for you to check whether where
it has got installed you simply need to
go to the directory i'll say ls minus
user local library so if you see here
you'll see something called as node
modules so whatever packages you're
going to install using npm would get
installed in this directory the node
modules directory so let's go ahead and
see whether i have my selenium side
runner there or not so i'll just use the
same ls slash
node modules okay do you see this
selenium side runner is what has got
installed and previously to that when we
installed the node.js server it also
installed this npm right so that is also
available under the same folder so for
so good so we have our selenium ide
installed now what else is required so
we installed the nodejs we installed the
selenium side runner now we need this
browser drivers now what are these
browser drivers now what you did using
your ide was let me
in ide was we said right in the id
itself i said run the current test and
since i am using firefox browser here
any test case using the ide plugin on
your firefox you execute is going to
execute on the firefox browser correct
same way if you are using the selenium
ide on chrome which is an extension on
chrome and you run the test cases there
it is going to use the chrome browser to
run the test case however any test cases
or any automation scripts you're going
to write you want your scripts to run on
all the browsers because you want to do
a cross browser testing right so for
that purpose what we do through command
line is we install this browser drivers
right so say if you want to run your
test cases on edge browser so that means
you first need to install your edge
browse driver on your systems before you
run your test case on edge process if
you want to do it for chrome similarly
you need to download the chrome web
driver and install it for firefox the
same and once you install that then you
should be able to run it on any browser
now where are these chrome browsers
available so if you go to the
seleniumhq.org let me show you that
okay in the selenium hq website if you
go to this download tab right and if you
go down here you will see something
called as third party drivers bindings
and plugins and here you have a list of
all the browsers and its corresponding
driver files which are available and
this is what which you need to go and
download for example say i want to run
all my tests on chrome browser right so
what i do is i click here okay in the
download section go to the latest chrome
driver available click on that and then
depending on which os you're working on
if you're working on mac just download
this if you're working on
windows you download this and once you
download the driver what you need to do
is you keep that drivers like for
example uh
can you see this driver file so this is
my driver file this is my executable
driver file so what i did was i just
downloaded this file for mac and i
copied it to the location where my tests
are present okay now so once i have this
available what i need to do is i need to
install this driver using again the npm
command and to install this driver what
you need to do is you need to be in the
same directory where your driver file is
present okay in the same directory you
just issue this command you say npm
install minus g and your chrome driver
this is it so once you install this
driver you should be able to work with
your chrome driver got it very simple so
similarly if you are working with
different browsers say if you also want
to run your test cases with edge or
internet explorer or the firefox browser
same way you need to download all the
drivers from this location
so from here like you have edge browser
here opera browser you have a mozilla
firefox browser so any of the browser
which you want to work with you have to
just download your driver from here
place it in this location and install it
using npn command okay so i will not be
executing this command again because
i've already installed it so once your
drivers are installed what's the next
step we are ready to execute our test
cases okay so these are all the
installation steps which are required to
get your command line runner which is
called as selenium side runner ready for
you to execute your test from the
command line all right okay now let's go
ahead and see how do we execute the test
cases so let's go back to our previous
example in this video where we wrote
some of the test cases for testing our
control flows okay so these are all the
test cases now if you observe here i
have not created any test suite here we
just had a default suite which was
created when we created the project and
we just went ahead and created all the
tests here for the side runner to run we
need to have a test suite so if i just
try to run the test switch let's try to
run this what is the name of this
project control flows so i will show you
what happens if there is no test suite
defined for this so let me clear the
screen and ah which is our project here
this one okay so what i will do is let
me simply go ahead and execute this
project so to execute any test this is
the command which you use you simply
call selenium side runner and the
project name okay and also once you have
installed the selenium side runner you
can also check the version of it so
let's execute this selenium
site runner and the project name project
name is this
done so now if i press enter now see
what happens
okay it's saying running the default
suite
see here
it looks for a test suite to start its
execution okay so it picked up the
default suite which is here
okay since it was created when we
created this new project fine however
it's a test suite failed to run why
because your test suite must contain at
least one test and all our tests are
residing outside the test suite we have
none in the default test way correct so
what we will do let's go ahead and
create this test suite instead of
default what i will do is i'll say first
rename this let's give it a proper name
so we'll say control flow test test
suite okay done so i have renamed it now
let's go ahead and add all those test
cases which we have created to this so
i'll just simply say add test and select
all these tests so we have around four
tests here so i'll just select all that
done so i'll save this project
i'll go to my folder id tests and the
same file name i'll just say replace now
we have a test suite called control flow
test now let's go ahead and run that
again now let's see what happens
okay so there are multiple test cases
here so let's see all these test cases
will be run one after the other
sequential so we have that calorie
counter test case and then we have the
loop test cases all right so it is done
so now let's understand the flow of this
test case okay so this is where we
started running our test suite so it
finished first test case it finished the
second test case it finished the third
test case and then the fourth test case
so all the four test cases it has
completed and it says all the four
passed total four and it also shows you
the total time taken for the complete
test suite to run and for every test
case what is the amount of time required
to execute that so this is all the
information which is available here if
at all there is a failure in any of the
test case that would get reflected here
it would say 4 past 1 fee and total four
executed okay so this is the kind of
report what you will get to see good so
far okay so let's go back to our notes
and see whether we have done everything
so the other way of running is say you
have multiple browser drivers installed
and you want to run this on a particular
browser so during that time what you can
do is you can use this command you can
say selenium side runner minus c minus c
is nothing but setting the capabilities
capabilities for what for the browser
and then you give a browser name here so
you can say chrome or you can say
firefox whatever the browser of your
choice and then give your project name
so with this what happens is if your
browser is installed now we have to
install the browser using this command
correct so if your browser is installed
it will execute this particular test
suite on the browser which you have
mentioned here right and that is how you
use the selenium site runner to run your
test cases on multiple process now
simply what you can do is you can create
a shell script or a batch script you can
add this line into a bad script for the
multiple browsers and you can execute
this so that way all your test cases
would executed on all the process so
that that way you can achieve your cross
browser testing so other thing if you
remember i also said that command line
runner like if you go back to our
presentation it says we can run it for
parallel testing now let's see how do we
achieve this parallel testing now to
achieve this parallel testing there are
certain steps which you need to do in
the id so let's go back to our test
suite so we have this test suite so if
you go here and go to the settings can
you see this run in parallel so you need
to check this check box to run all these
test cases in parallel so right now what
happened when we executed it all the
test cases ran sequentially one after
the other correct so for every test case
there was a chrome browser launched and
the chrome browser was closed before the
next test was launched now let's try to
do this i am going to check this
checkbox where it says run in parallel
and i'll say submit i'll save this
project again now
same thing i'll overwrite this project
save done replace now let's go to our
terminal window and run this test cases
again so for that what i will do i'll
call the same command again however now
please observe the number of chrome
browser windows it's going to open okay
i'll show you that so it has started
running the test suite okay can you see
this three chrome browser windows open
at the same time okay and one by one
they're going to get closed out okay so
there was also the fourth one open but
since the test case was so small that it
was too quick for us to see here now
look at the complete execution here so
what it has done is it opened all the
browsers in parallel okay and it ran all
the test cases parallely
you will see a big difference and since
these are very small testers you might
not be able to see a big difference in
the execution time however if you have
got a bigger or bigger test cases which
you are running you will see a
remarkable difference in the time taken
by the suite to run the test cases still
here you can see okay it's almost 11
seconds it took whereas in the previous
example it took 13 seconds as i said the
difference is very small because our
test cases are very very minor test
cases right if you have a bigger test
cases where it launches the browser
launches your application under test
then you are doing multiple operations
you will be able to see a remarkable
difference when you run the test
sequentially and when you run it
parallel so this is how you work with
the idea and this is how you achieve the
parallel execution okay so that
completes our selenium side runner now
let's look at some of the limitations of
the selenium id the first limitation is
you cannot export your id scripts to web
driver scripts the support is yet to be
added right so earlier in this video i
showed you there are ways to export the
scripts to junit and python however the
previous ide did have this capability of
exporting your scripts to web driver
scripts and that support is yet to be
added to the new id data driven testing
like using excel files or reading data
from the csv files and passing it to
your scripts so this capability is not
yet available in the id so you cannot do
data driven testing database testing is
also not possible so you cannot actually
connect your database read the test data
from your database or even you cannot
perform any kind of database testing
reporting facility so it does not have a
good reporting we saw when we use the
command line runner or through the id
when we run the test there is a very
minimal reporting capabilities what we
could see so it does not really have a
capabilities of reporting like your test
ng or the report engine what exactly is
the selenium web driver and how we can
go ahead with that
so coming back to the selenium web
driver so here a selenium webdriver is
one of the most important component of
the saline test suit
when we talk about the selenium uh tools
suit over here like we talk about okay i
want to create a whole together
regression test suit so selenium web
driver is very important component for
that
and when we talk about the selenium web
driver it allows the cross browser
compatibility which means like you want
to test your applications you can have a
test suit there one for the chrome
browser one for the firefox one for the
internet explorer you can then say like
okay i want to test and validate my
application across all these three
browsers and in future if safari browser
comes in all you have to do is like you
have to just run the same script with
the web driver of the safari so this web
driver is not only static for one
browser it's actually
approachable for across multiple
browsers there so that enhances the
compatibility there that yes this set
test suit even if you're writing the
test suits in case of selenium it's not
limited to one browser so it's kind of a
cross browser here
so these are small small benefits
although we are talking about the
selenium webdriver here but if you
closely see these all points are
actually defining why exactly the
selenium is best uh when we talk about
the weber automations or the web testing
automation here right
and then it's actually supporting
various programming languages like uh uh
programming languages yes it's there
it's even uh supporting with different
browsers and then of course it's
supporting different operating systems
also
because
you can pretty much run these test cases
onto linux macs or windows whatever the
platform you feel like you want to use
you can pretty much use it so you don't
have to worry about like where exactly
this web driver is getting deployed and
from where you are trying to refer it so
that kind of compatibility is also
something which is available here so you
don't have to
think about the uh specific different uh
versions or the different operating
systems as such over here and then let's
talk about further on this one so it
also provides the compatibility across
different programming languages so you
can see like what are the different
benefits you got you got benefits like
you know it's it's supporting different
programming languages it's supporting
different browsers and ultimately at
last it's supporting the different uh
particular uh operating systems or the
platforms here so these are small small
things like different uh benefits which
we get with the help of selenium here
and uh it's it's having the support
across different programming languages
so uh it doesn't matter that if you're
working with java or if you're working
with dot net this is going to work for
across a different different platforms
like different uh
environments you can actually deploy so
these benefits are something which can
definitely help you to see like how the
overall
benefits can be achieved over here
and uh definitely the chrome browsers
are the safari the firefox the oprah
different uh platforms you will be able
to see like how the execution needs to
be done and how the setup used to be
performed here so that's where the
complete uh implementations uh needs to
be performed here right and these web
driver provides a faster execution of
the test scripts uh because that's uh
the kind of automation which we are
looking forward that we are not trying
to see like how the systems can be
implemented so when we are trying to
talk about the automation here so these
web drivers basically help us to go for
the faster execution also so it's not
only about uh that we are trying to see
the setup like we are trying to go for
the configurations here it's also like
the performance and the efficiency which
we're getting with this one is quite
beneficial so you can get an easy and a
faster execution of the test cases
so it's it's having a lot of benefits if
we talk about in these features only
itself you can see like there are a lot
of benefits which we got over here so
it's fast it's efficient and on top of
that it's
not depending on any kind of environment
it's quite generic like you know it's
something which you can use for windows
you can use it for linux you want to use
it for dotnet you want to use it for
java it's kind of uh
chandrick for a lot of technologies
platforms and programming languages
right now why exactly we require the uh
selenium web driver like what is the
purpose of using this one so let's
explore on that part here so selenium
fib driver provides a user friendly
interface that could uh you know it can
be easily understood by a particular
person like when we uh when you are
using this selenium web driver so this
is something which you can easily
understood like uh it's pretty easy for
you to understand that and it's not that
much complex for you to understand that
okay you are going to take a lot of time
to
consume you're going to take a lot of
time to
uh you know understand that so that's
not a kind of interface which we are
getting when we talk of the
selenium webdriver here right and the
web driver is something which is having
much more uh features as compared to the
uh selenium rc and selenium ide there so
when we talk about the
selenium web driver so this is something
which is having uh much more features as
compared to the other components like
you know these the other components is
also about the selenium only but yes the
when we talk about selenium uh web
driver so it's having much more features
as compared to the selenium rc and the
selenium id here
so you don't have to worry about the
features like all together selenium uh
pep driver is something which is quite
efficient and better as compared to the
other components so that's another
benefit which we get with the selenium
here
so selenium uh
we have got some other components like a
selenium remote control here so rc is
something which enables the uh the
creation of uh you know automated web
applications like uh in in case of
programming languages such as java c
sharp uh node.js different different
programming languages are there so we
can pretty much uh use the remote
control uh selenium remote control over
here which will enable the uh the
creation of the automated web
applications there so that's the purpose
of using the selenium remote control
here it's uh it's not something which is
being used nowadays because most of the
functionalities have nowadays moved on
to the uh
selenium driver here so that's a
migration which has happened over there
and that's the reason why we are not
going to use
much of the
selenium remote control over here so
that's not being used as such as
compared to the other components but yes
the selenium web driver is something
which is quite popular and because of
its features and the efficiency we are
going to use of the particular uh
browse the uh web driver as compared to
the any other component as such here
right now selenium ide
needs not additional any kind of setup
is required like uh you know apart from
installation of the browser because uh
in that case everything will be
integrated in that like because we are
using we are integrating the complete uh
selenium ide over here so all you need
to do is like you need to do the
installation of chrome browser that's
also because you want to
go for the uh specific
chrome driver which you require for the
execution of the test cases so for that
only you are basically trying to install
the chrome browser but other than that
there is no other component which you
actually require when we talk about the
selenium ide here
so uh the ide makes the life easy
because it helps us to go ahead with the
debugging mode here like a kind of a
debugging environment you will be able
to do that so even if there is any kind
of issue any any kind of problem which
comes up so it will be very easy for you
to debug those things and go ahead with
that part
so uh tracking the exceptions managing
the exception so all those things can be
easily handled with the help of the
selenium ide here so selenium ide is
something which is kind of a bigger
package which is uh further comprising
of different different components like
it's something which is giving us a
variety of things here
right now how exactly the uh selenium
whip driver is at all different from the
selenium rc and ide because those are
also the solution which is available
there from this lane now unlike the
selenium ide selenium webdriver can
actually work with different browsers so
that's something which we have already
focused on that it's having the
compatibility across multiple
uh browsers there that's the first
benefit which we get over here in this
one now also the web drivers is
something which does not require any
user to start the server or anything
like that there so just in case of a
selenium rc you have to start some
server because you're ultimately
connecting to that server and that's how
the communication is happening but that
kind of stuff is not there in the uh
selenium uh web driver here
also this linear web driver is an api
and it's not a gui based plugin so uh
it's it's something which can easily
handle like uh it's having the um
quite efficient uh connectivity or you
can say like the uh integration is also
good there because we most of the
applications nowadays are working on the
api format which is pretty generic so
there is no gui based interface which we
have to explore which we need to
integrate here so it's all like the api
is called which we need to do in order
to use uh make use of the selenium web
driver here
now in selenium webdriver the apis are
entirely object oriented in nature as
compared to the selenium rc and selenium
id so which is not a kind of object
oriented in nature but selenium
webdriver is something which is quite
object oriented here also uh
web driver the selenium web driver is
actually uh supports multiple
listeners right so uh which is available
there as compared to selenium rc and
selenium id here so these are some
couple of features which is available
there also it also supports the testing
of the ios and android which is not
being supported in the uh rc and ide
there because most of the applications
uh nowadays also have the counterpart uh
android or the ios applications so if
you don't have the interface or
integration with those platforms then
it's a incomplete way of testing here so
not only the web applications but even
the mobile applications also now getting
integrated with the help of the selenium
web driver here so these kind of
features which is not exactly available
in the rc or the id over here but
definitely it's it's going to be
available there in case of selenium web
driver so what exactly is the overall
need of the web driver like the selenium
webdriver here so uh let's talk about
that that uh how exactly we can use it
for the software uh automation here so
there are a couple of benefits which is
available there so let's focus on that
one by one the very first one is the
open source now it's something which is
available or which is uh available as an
open source over here which means like
it's something which you can use without
any license without any cost uh just
like that you can go to the selenium dot
dev website and you can start
downloading the
selenium related uh
deals or selenium related components
second is multilingual support it's
having the support for different kind of
programming languages not only for the
java based applications it's actually
supporting like different different
programming languages so you just have
to learn one single tool and then can
serve eyes or that can support multiple
programming languages here several
operating system support yes it's not
only related to the windows or linux
platform here so it's actually supported
across uh windows linux macos a
different operating different support
operating systems is supported by this
particular selenium here uh multiple
frameworks are there so that's a
multiple framework support which is
available in this one
user friendly it's quite user friendly
there and the developers were more
comfortable with the java programming
languages so they get uh quite
comfortable and integrated with the
selenium because it's also using the
same java syntax over here in this one
um it's cross device testing uh
definitely both mobile desktops are
different platforms different operating
systems mac os uh ios android different
uh platforms are actually supported
by this uh particular selenium here so
selenium web driver is something which
is having like cross device testing here
community support is there it's kind of
open source yes but uh it's having a
very good community like a lot of people
are actually there
who can contribute to this selenium you
can get the information from there and
it's kind of a huge efforts like a kind
of a huge community efforts which you
can uh see over here in this case
also uh compatibility testing so it's
having a very good compatibility here so
uh when you're working with this uh
selenium so it's compatible with pretty
much any programming languages any
platform any operating system so that
kind of
benefits you get with the help of this
selenium web driver here
and uh
unlike uh selenium rc you don't have to
start any kind of server component here
uh which you need to connect so it's
like uh on demand like when you're
running the scripts a kind of a local
chrome browser will be initialized
and your test cases will be executed and
uh performed and that that's how the
whole executions will be performed there
so there is no inward like you have to
go somewhere start some server start
somewhere remote server there and then
the communication or the execution of
the test cases will be initialized so
it's not like that kind of communication
here
right so let's talk about the uh web
driver
architecture here now in this one there
are some different components which is
available there in this architecture
components the very first one is the
selenium language bindings here now
these are actually available in
different different programming
languages like java ruby python c-sharp
javascript these are the different
programming languages bindings which is
available there then with the help of
json-wire protocol these are going to be
connected to the different drivers now
browser drivers is the one where exactly
the request will be sent out so this
selenium web driver is actually going to
connect or send the request to this
drivers so um depending on the platform
also and depending on the different uh
systems you can actually go for the
browser drivers here so you want to go
for chrome driver you want to go for
firefox you want to go for opera you
want to go for safari these are the
different browsers which is available
there earlier the uh internet explorer
was also there but now in the latest
version say it
each browser or h driver is something
which is available there
and uh these are going to be connected
to the actual uh particular browsers
like the chrome firefox and also it will
be sending the request over the http uh
http uh that request will be sent out to
the real drivers so the browser drivers
and then the real drivers will be there
so the web driver is going to connect to
the chrome driver and then in fact from
there the chrome driver is going to
initialize the chrome browser and then
the whole request will be processed the
websites will be open the clicking the
access everything will be done after
that on that case so these are the
different uh
steps which is involved when we are
basically going for uh from one step to
another like where the communications or
will be performed over here in this case
right so uh again uh it's not dependent
on any programming languages it's not
dependent on any kind of
browser any kind of components here so
right from the uh language bindings it
will go to the json wire protocol from
there it will be sent out to the browser
drivers various browser drivers whatever
the browser drivers you want to use you
can use that and then those drivers are
actually going to connect with the real
drivers or with the real browsers over
here so that the communications or the
exact end result you should be able to
see
so
for instance if you run a particular
chrome browser uh chrome driver there so
you will be able to see like a chrome
browser getting initialized and the
website is getting accessible so all
that activity will be happened or will
be performed over there so these are the
parts of the sequence these are kind of
architecture components like one to
another these will be processed or these
will be executed here right so uh these
programming language these selenium
programming languages again it's
actually a kind of a generic one
so these are the client libraries which
is available there depending on this one
for example for java i can download some
binaries uh i can download some jar
files so that will be referenced or
utilized into my source code for ruby
it's maybe like different uh third-party
libraries or shared libraries which will
be available there for python it will be
available in the form of modules uh
c-sharp javascript so each and every
programming languages
is actually having its own uh
libraries now these libraries are
actually required so that we can get the
whole interface of the selenium it's
okay like i'm writing some test cases
i'm writing the complete test sort and
i'm using it but unless and until i
import my uh selenium libraries it will
not work for me i will not be able to
work on that part because i will not be
able to get those features as such in
order to get those features i need to
download these bindings or these kind of
language bindings there corresponding to
my programming language and these are
easily available on the selenium website
so if you go to the selenium website
whatever the programming languages you
want to follow you can download these
findings these windings will be nothing
but the archives where you will be
having some kind of executables
depending on that programming language
right now from there uh we will be using
our libraries like these bindings in
order to interact in order to initialize
the selenium so then we will be going to
the json wire protocol so it's kind of a
connector between the libraries and the
web drivers
now uh programmatically
using these with the help of these uh
client libraries we're going to send the
request to the web drivers it also helps
to enable the transfer of data between a
server and client
because of course you have to uh get
your end result process right so that's
where you need to go for the execution
so what you're going to do is like
you're going to see like okay i'm going
to run or i'm going to execute this uh
json wire protocol over here and it's
going to connect between my client
libraries and the web drivers here so
that's the communications and the
connectivity which we want to establish
or we want to provide here now these are
selenium browser drivers are actually uh
specific browsers now because
the json wire is going to connect uh to
the specific uh
browsers uh the drivers here so that the
communication can be happen
now uh these drivers are actually used
uh as in drivers in order to interact
with the exact browser because these are
not the exact browser now if you want to
interact with the chrome then you
definitely have to use the chrome driver
if you want to use for the fireworks
then you have to use the firefox driver
so depending on the programming language
you have to define like which driver you
really need to process or you need to
really go ahead with that part so that's
where the selenium browser drivers
really comes into the picture and then
uh the exact browsers will be there now
once the
executions will be done at last you will
be able to see like all these browsers
getting open if you're going to use the
chrome browser then chrome browser will
be initialized if you're using the
firefox then the firefox browser will be
initialized so whatever the browser or
driver specific driver you will utilize
so according to that you will see a
particular browser being invoked over
here
so that's how the communication happens
and it's kind of a sequence here like
step by step here
so each and every stage is very
important because that's how the
communication will happen over here
and you will get the end result or the
desired output if you uh have any kind
of uh failing component over here so
that's where the whole connectivity will
be breakdown and you will not be able to
get any kind of values x expected so
this is something which we really need
to consider or we need to go ahead with
that part here
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free
visit skill up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
so what are the different drawbacks
which we got with the help of the
selenium web driver here so when we talk
about the selenium web drivers so what
are the different drawbacks which we are
getting over here so that we can
understand like how exactly we can talk
about that part here
now the drawbacks of selenium webdriver
is something which we uh you know use
because
this is kind of uh
uh main component you can say like you
know using which you can actually do the
complete validation but the problem is
that it's not something which you can
use for the desktop application so for
the desktop application this does not
works so this web driver is something
which is supported for the web
applications only it's not something
which we can use for the desktop
applications as such so that's a kind of
a limitation which we get with the help
of the selenium web driver here so it's
only there for the websites for the web
portals
secondly uh the uh it requires the
expertise of the teams uh you know in
order to manage these scripts because
these are the programming languages of
course there although it's a test suit
but uh it requires a programming
language efforts as such in order to go
ahead with that in order to manage these
things
so it requires a kind of expert team uh
who can actually handle these scripts or
who can work on these requirements
so uh that's a kind of a overhead
because if it's not like very easy to
manage these like uh pretty much a
person who is an expert in these things
can only handle these kind of
requirements so it's kind of a
limitation where we will be only
depending on an expert to manage these
scripts as such right now um
it's not having any kind of uh
reporting builder reporting capability
over here so it's not available in this
one so test reports which is getting
generated here is uh with the help of
the j unit and test ng so there is no
default reporting mechanism which is
available over here in this one so we
only have the mechanism of the j unit
like we can extend our test scripts in
selenium by integrating with jh unit and
the test ng here
so that we will be able to get a proper
reporting so for the uh reporting
purposes we actually use the components
like this junit and the test ng over
here to go ahead with that
so these are the ways in which we can
actually go for the integration where we
can integrate the selenium and the other
frameworks like junit and the uh test ng
kind of components here
and that's the whole basis because
alone the selenium web driver is
something which can execute the scripts
process the request but it's not going
to handle any kind of
reporting mechanism so reporting
mechanism is something which you can
only get with the help of the junit or
the test uh ng here because these are
the additional packages which you need
to integrate so it's it's a kind of a
custom solution which we need to design
uh you know where we don't have only the
web driver available over here like the
core components but also we have like
other components available over there
which will be of course having the other
components like test ng and the j unit
here so that's also something which you
can integrate all together with this one
right also uh it's very difficult to
manage there is a lot of management or
the maintenance activity which we get
over here
also it's very difficult to scale this
up also depending on the load or
depending on the requirement it's very
difficult to scale it up also if you are
using for some infrastructure some kind
of a load there so having it increased
to a different level is kind of a
difficult task here
also maintenance activity is quite huge
so if you want to have a proper
maintenance or management you have to
get
a couple of uh
you know experts in that case so that
they can easily manage those things so
these are the different uh requirements
which is available there where we can
see like how exactly the uh we can you
know manage all these things
now it also uh you know allows the
across
browser uh compatibility testing here so
it's something which can easily handle
like different requests across the
browsers
so um image testing is not available so
uh
you don't have to uh you know use the
selenium alone like selenium alone is
not compatible for testing the images
here so if you really want to test the
images so you have to
integrate securely uh in with your
selenium so that you can have a complete
package so again uh selenium in some
cases is not sufficient for like most or
a variety of things there so in some
cases you have to actually
go for another tool integrations so that
you can have the complete details you
can have the complete component here
so that's where the uh real mechanism
comes in like yes uh you don't have the
uh exact single tool available for
taking care of all these things but yes
you can have all these things integrated
uh with the other tools other components
there and from there you will be able to
get a complete uh values and the
complete uh implementation here
right so these are the um you know
different uh drawbacks which we get once
we start using the a web driver here so
let's go ahead uh with the uh particular
demo over here to understand like how
exactly the uh selenium web driver can
be utilized can be used
so that we will be able to run some test
scripts here so we are going to run or
prepare a test suit here so that we can
get it executed with the help of
selenium so that's what we are trying to
do here so for this one we require some
couple of components to be there like
the jdk eclipse and all so let's talk
about that component so let's go ahead
with the implementation
so let's begin with the uh
configurations of this webdriver here
now the very first thing which we
require is that we require to the
installation of the
java here now let's uh go ahead with
this url so now this one is something
where we have to see like how uh we can
go for the installation of the jdk here
now here we need to go for the jdk
installation that's the version which we
want to install now it a variety of our
versions are available there like which
version you want to install you can go
with that uh jdk 11 8 it is the most
stable version so you can go ahead with
the jdk8 here so you can download here
different platforms it's available like
windows platform uh whatever the
platform is there all you need to do is
like you need to just download this exe
file now once the exe file is downloaded
so what happens like you will be able to
do the installation now i have done the
installation of this jdk here so if i
have to open my uh command prompt here i
would be easily able to see that i'm
using a jdk version of
1.8.0 over here in this one so that's a
version which i'm using but i've gained
of course if you're using some different
version of jdk that will also work here
the only thing is that you need to see
that you need to go for a compatible
browser
a compatible uh
java and the compatible eclipse tool
here so that's what you require now what
i'm going to do is like i'm going to
install or download the eclipse browser
also now let's download the eclipse here
now uh we got an official website of
eclipse here from where we can download
these eclipse
different platform you can do it like
this is the one which is available there
now you can click on download this one
so that will help you to download the
eclipse here
so uh here the uh download will work
just like that you can do the download
here even if you want to go for a
different offerings like uh you want to
go for a different platform
you feel like you want to decide that
which package actually you need to do
because uh in the eclipse also you got
like different things
um ide eclipse ide for the java
developers for uh the c plus c plus plus
so different uh different uh operating
system and different uh packages are
also available there so it's basically
up to you like which exactly environment
you want to follow
so i want to download this uh 64 bit
over here in this one so let's download
this here now uh let's again download
this this is kind of an exe file which
is available here so let's download it
again
now um
it will be working on like uh it's kind
of a download which is getting started
over here so it's close to 102 mb which
is available there this is the
executable which is going to help us to
do the installation of eclipse now this
is the uh latest version our 2020
version is what it is getting installed
over here and uh it's completely there i
have already got the jdk installed
because of the fact that using this jdk
the eclipse will be open if you don't
have the jdk installed the java runtime
then the eclipse will not be installed
for you so uh in order to get the
eclipse uh installed and executable
perfectly fine you need uh the jdk
installed to be done here so we got like
one more minute here to complete the
download and this is just a
mb package or installer which is
available there and once this is
installed we will be able to get ahead
with this installation of the eclipse
here so once the eclipse is installed
all you can do is like you can go ahead
with the
particular configurations you can create
some couple of cro uh projects in case
of eclipse um then we'll also see like
how we can download the
programming languages binding so that
also we are going to download so these
are the different components which
you're going to explore while working on
this one so uh let's wait for this uh
download of this executable to be
performed here so that we will be able
to proceed further with this one so
let's wait for that so it's hardly
taking one minute more to complete it
so selenium and eclipse both are the
open source one you're getting a donate
to a class community page there because
that's the donation which they want but
again you can use it like 100 open
source and free of cost here
so you don't have to pay any cost as
such over here in this case so there is
no cost associated with this one
so just 10 seconds more and uh then we
can pursue with the installation of the
eclipse here and here we go so the
installer is almost done here so i can
pretty much go ahead and
open the file so this will help me to do
the installation of the eclipse here so
the eclipse installer is what it's
getting started initialized over here in
this one
uh now the java runtime is already
available with me we require the uh
specific
uh jdk installed the java command line
is working we can download the eclipse
here
and
then we can go for the uh specific
executions like we can go and uh
download the uh browser drivers here now
the thing is that if you really want to
go for the chrome browser or firefox or
any kind of those things in case of your
uh particular system in case of your
windows machine over here
you don't have to necessarily go for any
kind of uh a kind of a driver as such
here because of the fact we got a links
over here like this mozilla for the
firefox uh this one is there for the uh
particular selenium this one is there
for the chrome now chrome is something
which we have already got here like we
have already got the chrome browser
installed but let's see like uh we can
download this driver also like uh
depending on that we can go ahead with
that part and then we can also download
the java client uh libraries over there
from the bindings over there from the
specific selenium selenium.dev website
over there and we can download and we
can integrate it so let's do it one by
one so first of all let's see like you
know once the installation of the
eclipse is done and then we'll be able
to go ahead with the third component or
the third request which is the a web
driver or a particular chrome browser a
driver over here so this installer is
going to give us the same thing here so
i'm going for the
uh specific java developer here so let's
go for the uh installation here now this
is going to uh install uh the uh java 8
right uh this runtime over here so uh if
you feel like you want to use the jdk 11
because that's something which is
available there now if you're using an
existing ones like uh you're already
using uh an existing once over here the
jdk and all so uh that's where the
installation is going on like uh it's
it's going in with that part here but
we already got some system related uh
jdks which is installed but you feel
like you want to go ahead with this one
um like you're not doing the separate
installation of the jdk or jre so there
you can actually use this once here
so let's select this one like i pretty
much want to use like any one of these
uh jvms over here like which i feel like
i can configure or i can utilize so
that's pretty much we can do here so
it's like uh we can use these variables
like we can go for these jvms or if you
feel like you can go for an external jvm
also there so it all depends on you like
how the uh installation you want to
perform here
right and this is the location let's uh
go for the desktop location there
and or you can go for the default
location also over here in this one
so let's go for the installation now
just accept it and uh the installation
will be proceeded over here so
uh even if you have not done a separate
jtech installation so this will
basically have a jdk installed i have
selected the java 11 over here
but you can go for the 15 also in this
case in this scenario so the whole
installation of the eclipse is what it's
happening over here
so once the eclipse is installed so then
we can pretty much go ahead with the
next component there which is like uh
dealing with the uh specific selenium
related components and chrome browser
again it's already something which is
installed there but we'll see like how
we can download the chrome driver how we
can configure and we can utilize that so
that's what we're going to follow here
so it's going for the installation and
uh it's something which we are trying to
do like uh it's
this installer is pretty much
downloading some couple of components as
such uh like this j uh
jre is something which is getting
installed or downloaded from the uh
eclipse website and uh that's where the
uh you know all the components is
getting installed so one by one all the
components will be downloaded
from the eclipse website here and it's a
complete package which means like you
don't have to necessarily go for a
separate installation
there is another installer which is
available for eclipse where you just
have to unzip up for a zip file and uh
you can pretty much use it but in this
case
this is something which is having all
these things integrated all together
inside that so that's an another
component which is being available here
so the installation is still going on
there
so uh it depends because all these
things are getting cached up from the
internet so it also depends on like how
much size of file is getting downloaded
here
so let's uh you know let's uh wait for
the installations to be complete and
then we'll proceed further
so now the installation is done so we
can launch our eclipse here so that's
what we are trying to launch here now
apart from eclipse what happens like we
require some other components also like
uh we require this lyrium web driver
also there so for that we have to
download the java related client
bindings so for that uh chrome browser
first of all it's already installed so
we don't have to do any kind of
installation there uh yes i can go ahead
with the exe file like of the chrome
browser driver that i'm going to use it
so i'm going to open the uh specific
downloads here now in this segment what
happens like selenium.dev is the website
which is available there now here we can
go for the downloads now related to your
programming language whatever the
programming language you are trying to
use so you can download the language
binding for that now language binding is
something which is utilized so using
which you will be able to see like how
uh you can establish the connectivity
it's just a kind of a libraries where
you can do the connectivity and you can
see that execution
so what i'm going to do is like i'm
going to download this bindings here so
let's download this one now it's again
available as a zip file which is
available there so uh
depending on the version you can go for
the beta download version also and i'm
going for the stable version which we
want to utilize we want to refer it so
it's going to download zip file so this
zip file will have all the jar files and
all the required libraries there
and when i'm going to create a project
into my eclipse at that moment of time i
would be requiring all these components
like all these
various libraries i should be added up
into my uh project as such in case of
the eclipse so that's what i need to do
here so let's go to the eclipse here
so here we are going to expand this like
a package
explorer and here we're going to go to
file
new and java project so i'm going to
create a java project over here so um
in which we will be getting some couple
of class files in which we will be
having the
selenium related test cases like how we
want to process or how we want to
execute that part so i'm going to
proceed with that part so
let's put the uh project name here so
i'm going to say like selenium
just a project name i want to put uh
then the jdk now uh if you want to go
for a specific jdk like another version
so you can go with that but right now
i'm using like jdk 1.8 which is pretty
much configured so i can use that
uh you feel like you want to use the
specific jre of
gre which is available as part of jdk
1.8 that also you can use or if you want
to use like a jdk so that also something
which you can utilize over here in this
one so there are different things like
you can configure the gres also so if
you have some custom path which uh where
you have the java available or the jdk
or jre is available there so that also
you can easily refer it so you can
simply say that yes uh this so and so
location i want to refer i want to see
my source code so that's where you can
do the you can go for the execution now
once you're providing these values like
the install gres which you want to
provide which you want to process here
next thing what you need to perform is
like you need to go ahead with that
execution so i'm completely okay with
the jdk whatever the environment i want
to process i can easily do that and i'm
completely okay with that
right so uh let's go with that part and
then click on next
and uh this is the source directory
which is available there right and if
you want to add any additional libraries
so uh here exactly you can add your
selenium related libraries using which
you will be able to see your source code
working fine but i'm not going to do
that activity here so i'm going to do
that later on so that we can get our
complete things in a sequence
and then here we go like finish so you
will be able to get
the gi related libraries and the source
folder here so right now it's completely
empty project there is nothing available
as such here and what i'm going to do is
like i'm going to create a class file
over here to see with the specific
source code of the selenium to how the
web driver is getting loaded up and
processed so that's stuff we are going
to talk about here so let's see like
what content we need to really put up
over here in this one now if we
downloaded this selenium
programming language bindings here so
let me extract it
uh you can pretty much keep it into the
eclipse folders also or if you wish you
can keep it aside in some specific
folder because it's just going to be
referenced with every project so it's
just kind of a shared release which is
available there so whatever project you
want to onboard you want to use so this
kind of a
package or this kind of uh share library
you can easily utilize and you can
implement it so we are just trying to
extract it now once extraction is done
so you will be able to see like some
couple of files and folders
uh now this is having a particular uh
two executable files like client embed
combined this is kind of connecting uh
acting like a selenium client and which
is using to connect and process all the
requirements
and we also have a sources file which is
available there for this one but again
it's something which depends on the
requirement so you don't have to put the
sources uh jar file also over here
because that's not required so you can
pretty much uh use this executable jar
file because in this one you will not
have any kind of source then of course
your selenium-related jar file is
further on depending on some
dependencies like this so these jar
files are also uh something which you
should be putting up into your uh
specific
uh
shared library so that your selenium
related jar files should not started
failing so uh we'll we'll try that
scenario also so that we can get the
complete output and complete in chance
here so let's see now uh we'll go to
this uh we'll import this particular
file over there and for that we have to
write a class file so let's see like how
we can do that so we have already got
the selenium web driver so
uh the eclipse is what we have followed
so we have created a new java project
now we want to create a new class file
the build path configurations we will be
taking care of that later on but right
now we are going to see like how we can
proceed further with that
so i i'm going with this uh specific
component here right so uh whatever the
browser or whatever the
driver you want to follow you can do
that so firefox if you want to use you
want to use our chrome browser it all
depends on you like it all depends on
the way that how you want to configure
it so uh let's see let's uh import this
uh particular component here now if the
uh specific uh
firefox browser is installed that's
great if it's not installed so you can
just go back here so here you will be
able to see like this browsers like
these specific components which is
available here
so this is the driver which is available
so for the windows 64-bit you can again
download this one here
so whatever the platform you want uh
like if you want to use for the chrome
browser you can go for that if you want
to go for the firefox edge whatever the
driver you feel like you want to go you
can do go with that part here
so let's uh open this one here and
extract this one also so that we should
be able to refer it over here into our
specific source code so this is the
driver this is the exe file which is
available there now all we need to do is
like we need to just open our eclipse
there so uh in our eclipse uh we should
be using or we should be referring to
this one here so this is a kind of a
path which is available similarly we
will also be giving a path over there so
that uh we can refer to that specific uh
driver that driver over here so let me
open that and uh let's see
so i'm going to create a class file here
you can create a package
uh called
calm
and
in that package you can further on
create a class file
like
selenium
test
uh
it's also uh depends like this is just a
custom name so
uh you feel like you want to give some
different name you can uh
go for
uh you know any kind of class name over
here but this is something which is uh
something we are going to see like how
the execution needs to be performed and
needs to be done here
so there are different uh you know names
like uh you want to follow some
different name you can do that also
now if you see closely here let me save
the file here now in this one you're
getting some errors uh related to this
one like you're getting the uh error
codes related to the imports here like
how the uh specific execution should be
done here right now the thing is that uh
this is something which is uh really
causing the problems uh like how the
import or the execution should be done
right
also uh the thing is that uh
we require these imports to be available
there right so uh that's definitely we
are requiring over here and uh that's
that's something which we uh
require uh we want to process as such
also so right now let's uh have an uh
particular declaration of the uh package
also there because it's something which
is there in the comp package so let's
have the package com also here so it's
there in the com package
but again those errors are not related
to that so these are like related to the
configurations which we are trying to
put
and uh during the copy paste there might
be a conversion of the code so that i
have taken care great
so uh let's see now what i have to
really do is like we have to see like
how we can proceed further on the uh for
the most executions and we need to get
this driver like we need to get this one
so i'll right click on my project here
and go to the build path and click on
configure build path
so first i'm going to uh add my binding
jar file there the java binding the jar
file which i downloaded just now this
client combined one here so only this
jar file we are trying to add up over
here
and with that
most of the uh related errors related to
that uh imports will be resolved now i'm
not sure that how it's going to work how
it's going to uh you know function
whether it's going to success or failure
that's a different story but yes all you
have done is like i right clicked on my
project went to the build path went to
the configure build path here and went
for the add external charge so these are
the external jars which you have to do
we have to put up over here
so only the combined client combined jar
file is what i have put up over here in
this one in the reference libraries you
will immediately be able to know that
part of the jar file here
now this is a directory where you will
be having the exe file available for
that driver for the firefox so let's get
the path for our component also so we
got the path so let me paste it over
here
and here we go so we got the path here
this is the folder where we got our
driver available here and let's try to
resolve it let's try to run it over here
great
so now i'm going to right click here
just say run as and java application
now in this one i got an error saying
that some com google common collect
imitable map some class file is not
available there this is of the fact that
i did not imported those dependent jar
files also which we got downloaded from
the
java binding file here so that zip file
was also having some of the jar files
there in the library folders so in this
one also you will be able to see like
some executions of the jar files is
required over here as an inputs as a
standard imports
so let's import this one and this is the
reason why we got the error at the first
place because we are not importing those
ones those jar files which is being
required by our client combined jar file
also so these are the dependent jar
files which we are trying to import here
so ultimately at last you will be able
to have your referenced libraries
available here with all these jar files
component available here
right now since our driver is configured
everything is configured now the next
thing which we require is the browser
now i have the chrome browser but
unfortunately i don't have the firefox
browser so let's go ahead and download
the firefox browser so for that
let's open the browser so i'm going to
download a
firefox browser over here into my system
so uh the official website is something
which is quite good so we can go for the
download firefox here now uh why because
i require now i'm using the firefox here
if i am using the chrome browser i will
not be having or facing any kind of
issues as such but since i'm using the
firefox uh driver so i require firefox
browser so uh the uh dependency of the
uh browser is there when we want to go
ahead because uh pretty much my uh core
base is going to connect or this
one is going to connect to the driver
here but driver ultimately internally or
require a browser show that it can
perform these occasions it can do that
execution so these drivers are going to
just uh
communicate between the your source code
and the actual browser here
so after the driver you also require the
browser to be installed like the chrome
browser to be available here so that you
can pretty much use it and you can
perform the configuration so let's see
uh we are getting the browser over here
in this one and uh we got the browser
installed perfectly fine over here so we
should be able to see the browser uh
because in this one we are basically
trying to open the browser and getting
our website called
www.google.com here
and then we are having a particular
sleeve one and then ultimately the
driver is getting cured here
so let's see so once the browser is
downloaded and installed so right click
on run as java application
so you will be able to see the browsing
here so okay it's connecting the uh
browser the firefox exe file is getting
executed a browser is getting executed
and it will be maximized automatically
you can see here like it's you know
getting maximized automatically here
and uh we just have to wait for a couple
of seconds more
and uh here we go we got the a browser
closed automatically also because there
was a slip of a couple of seconds over
here and you got the failure like you
got the complete uh component or it got
the driver closed there driver closed
means that definitely the browser will
also be closed here and you can see here
that the uh specific
output which is being performed or which
is getting executed over here it's
actually showing us like how the
executions and the uh setup needs to be
performed
or needs to be done here
so this is the way that how
the bra the implementations really
performed or really gets executed over
here in this case you got the browser
execution and everything will be work
perfectly fine
so again i'm right clicking over here
just click on run as java application
the same browser will be open again uh
it will be automatically refreshed you
will see that progress like this and
after a couple of seconds uh the thread
will be on sleep but yes after that it
will be closed automatically over here
so like that you can program how to open
your website how to proceed further from
there you want to click on some buttons
you want to do some processing that's
all up to you like how you program how
you code it over here so this completely
helps you to see like how exactly you
can go ahead with the complete program
and this program will help you to uh
execute a good amount of testing
validations and running or executing
some couple of test cases so this is
what we have in this demo where we saw
like how we can configure the different
drivers the web driver the browser
driver and ultimately the browser and
the selenium web driver here so you're
using this linear web driver over here
which is going to invoke the browser
driver and this browser driver is going
to invoke the browser as such over here
in this case
so that's it for this demo let's move on
to main content
so that was the demo in which we
executed a very simple program in order
to execute the selenium web driver which
is going to further invoke the uh
browser driver the firefox driver and
then it was invoking the uh specific
implementations there right so this is
what we did and if we summarize this
demo so in this one we downloaded uh the
selenium web driver we installed it we
configured it
we uh integrated the eclipse with the uh
selenium web driver
and we also executed a specific test
script in order to see like how a
particular browser will be invoked and
the previous cases yes the browser was
invoking a
www.google.com website there and we were
getting the response accordingly and
that was the executions mechanism like
that's the whole basis that how the
selenium test cases used to work and
used to be integrated over there so this
is the complete way that how exactly we
did this demo here
first of all you should have java 8 in
your system to run selenium 3.0 three
plus averages so you should have java
eight if you want to run selenium three
plus okay you can verify whether you
have java on uh version eight plus or
not by going to command prompt say java
hyphen version and then see if you have
the latest version of java or not if you
don't have download it from the link
provided right here and install that in
your system and configure it second
selenium 3.3.1 is mentioned right here
but now the latest version is 3.5.3 you
can simply download the latest version
whatever you get from the selenium
website okay uh here it is talking about
test ng
so we'll be talking about test ng at the
later point
when we will be talking about unit
testing framework so as of now you don't
need to download it no need okay you
don't need to download it just set up
selenium and java in your system and
make it ready
because from now onwards we'll be
writing the script solely now let's talk
about the project setup steps
so first create a new java project and
give a name
second
create a new source folder and provide
this uh situation
so source folder is automatically
created you don't need to worry about it
right click on test source folder create
a new package and provide a situational
name this is scripts so here we will be
going to create a new
package we have already we already have
a package that is called as selenium
examples
so we will use it
right click on test source folder create
a new folder and name it as resources
right click on the project create a new
folder and limited slip so why they are
calling it as resources and why they are
calling it as lib let me tell you that
so they are asking us to create two new
folders in the project so by
saying new folder
give it a name resources
in this resources we will be going to
keep all our drivers that is chrome
driver firefox driver all those drivers
it is also good it is also asking me to
create
print okay it is also asking me to
create one more folder
that is called as lib
okay
so in this lab we'll be going to store
all our selenium libraries
okay
so earlier how we set up so there are
two ways to set up
one is you are going to the project
go to properties java build path add
external jars and you select the
libraries which you want to add
okay
the second one is you go to lib
you don't go you just create a left
folder you go here copy the libraries
paste it here inside this after pasting
it doing the right click do the right
click and say say
here's that let's see
i completely not
here
why i'm not getting that option you can
try it right now if you like
so download the live ids
create a new folder right in this in
your project by creating the folder
you will get here liv and you can
paste all your libraries right into this
folder
and then you can select your library
do the right click and then you will get
an option add to
build path you can then add your
libraries directly to your build path so
how it helps
it actually helps you to manage all your
libraries at one project
and
it will be configured in your
project how to add libraries into the
lib folder just copy the library
come here and paste it
and done
so here if i go to lib folder copy it
and paste it
and then it will be added or you can do
the right click
go to properties
copy this path the location where this
lib folder is present
you can copy it
paste it here and here
you can paste your library this is also
an option
after that you select your libraries do
the right click and there you will get
an option add to build path
okay
and then the libraries will be added to
the build path
i would suggest you to try yourself as
well it will be there in your eclipse
you want you won't face any issues like
i am listening
so that's what we do uh it is just that
uh we do create a library here so that
we can maintain all the libraries in one
folder in the same project instead of
you know go and explore like ladies or
search for the libraries uh
it's completely there is no difference
you can use any way you can use any
approach just that when you do the right
click in the project and go to
properties and
do add external charts
then it is getting added from some
different location
but here you are creating a folder in
your own project
where you are working so you don't need
to go here and there to search for the
libraries
that's it
yes it goes to the reference libraries
regi
after you add it to the build path
it is uh you know adding it to the
heading files to the left reference
library it is same
no difference
do the setup okay
today itself so here you can see they
have created a lib folder
on top of that they have created two
more folders that is one is source and
one is test source is what that we
actually get it there is no need to
create test folder if there is a maven
comes if you know built to enable comes
then you will see automatically all
these architecture will be created it's
by default comes when you work on living
okay this is how they are saying that
your folder structure will look like
this
then they are asking us to add you know
libraries so they are asking us to copy
the downloaded serium jar into the
folder like i have shown you
this one
they are asking us to add the drivers in
the resources folder
so just add the drivers in the resources
folder
asking us to test add the test ng
library just ignore for the time being
will not be going to do that
and here you can see that guys
okay great obey i hope you must be
getting the
build path option and add to build path
by right clicking on the project
so there are two ways like i mentioned
one is you select all the libraries and
say build path add to build path or
another way is add to external jar files
so
you can choose any way it's up to you if
you don't have chrome and ie then
install those browsers as well guys it's
for you as well if you don't have ie and
chrome just download them as well no
surajit you don't require any github
account to get the jaco driver you just
what you need to do is
go to jekyll driver version and here you
have windows
zip file click on it and it will
download the zip file for you and that's
it done you don't need to create any
kind of a you know any account and all
that if you have an older version of
firefox then install the latest version
so that we can work on latest version
and guys make sure that you have chrome
ien firefox because these are the main
browser people uses and we'll be working
on all these browsers as well so this is
how they are showing us that you know it
has been added so they have maintained
the resources in a package but we are
maintaining it in a separate folder and
it is always suggested
maintain your drivers in a folder you
can for the time being you can ignore
this the package okay so
let's create this architecture of course
i have the architecture correct so we
have already created that and but in
resources let's copy the jaco driver
chrome driver and i driver as well so
let's go to that uh selenium resources
so here i have stored all my library all
my you know exes and libraries etc so
here i need to add the jaco driver how
to download tracker driver and repeating
it once again just take a look here for
the jaco driver click on this version
clicked on it you will get this page go
down you will get a zip file here click
on it and download it and unzip it
download it and unzip that that's it
second chrome driver click on the latest
version 2.31
let it open
you will you will get
chrome driver
click on the zip file it will get
downloaded and then unzip it and that's
it after that ie driver so for i driver
just move your cursor up move your
cursor up and here you can see there's a
different section completely internet
explorer driver server okay
so click on 64-bit windows
ie
when you click on it it will start
downloading the i driver server and done
so all the three drivers are downloaded
and now
you can unzip them
and after unzipping
you can add them to your resource folder
so jekyll driver copy this paste it in
resource folder go back let's see chrome
drivers this is my chrome driver
let me go inside copy this
again paste it here control v
going back internet explorer driver
server open this
copy it paste it and done all the three
drivers has been placed in the folder
you don't need to add them into the
build path okay don't add them into the
build path so you just need to add the
libraries into the build path not the
resources okay okay all the setup is
done no more setup is required now
in this session we will begin by
learning what expert is what is its
relevance and in the process of learning
about xpath we shall see its syntax and
different types of expat locators
we shall learn the types of xpath
different expat functions and lastly we
will see expat access while we learn all
of these we shall see the syntax often
along the side
but before we begin make sure that you
have subscribed to our youtube channel
and click that bell icon so that you can
never miss an update from simply learn
okay so without further ado let's get
started with what is expert
xpath stands for xml path language it is
a selenium technique that is used to
navigate through the html structure of a
web page it is a syntax or language that
makes finding elements on a web page
possible using xml path expression
there are other locators in selenium
that search for elements using tags or
css class names and they are simple to
use but then they are not always
efficient and effective
there are times when you need to select
all dom elements of an html document
which is when xpath comes to your rescue
the xpath helps in dynamically searching
elements with a webpage giving
sufficient flexibility to the user
it has always been an essential part of
an automation script development to
locate a web element and it has always
been a challenging task to find the
correct useful and accurate locator in
an automation test development process
this is when xpath comes to the picture
and provides its various functions to
help write effective experts
in selenium automation there may be
times when elements can be hard to find
with general locators like id name class
etc and this is when xpath is used to
locate those elements on the web page
we can use xpath and selenium on both
xml and html documents
xpath in selenium has a basic format or
syntax here we can use a syntax that has
many keywords
these double slashes are used to select
nodes in the document from the current
node that match the selenium no matter
where they are
then tag name
is used to give the tag name as an input
this add the rate symbol is used to
select the attribute
the keyword attribute indicates the
attribute name of the node and lastly
the value refers to the value of the
node next before we move on to the types
of xpath let's first see the types of
expat locators
as we know by now xpath is used to
locate web elements based on its xml
path here the term locator refers to an
address that identifies a web element
uniquely within the web page these
locators are html properties of a web
element which tells selenium about the
web element it needs to act on
the first type of xpath locator is the
id
the best and the most popular method to
identify web elements is by using the id
and obviously each element's id is
unique the second type is the class name
in this case the class name of the
element is used to find the element the
third type is the link text here the
links text is used to find the element
all the hyperlinks on the web page can
be identified just by using the linked
text
we can determine the link on the webpage
with the help of an anchor tag
the anchor tag is used to create the
hyperlinks on a web page and the text
between the opening and closing anchor
tags constitute the link text then comes
the xpath locator that uses the name of
the element to find that particular
element the other type of xpath locator
is the xpath
this is required by the dynamic element
and to traverse between different
elements of the web page the last type
of xpath locator is the css path it
locates the elements that have no class
name or id
now let's move further and learn about
the types of xpath
there are basically two types of xpath
absolute x-path and the second one is
relative expat if we talk about the
absolute x path then it refers to the
direct way of finding an element
the major drawback of an absolute x path
is that if there are any changes in the
elements path then the x path will fail
the x path begins with a single forward
slash which states that
we can select the root node element
the syntax of the absolute x path looks
something like this you can determine
the absolute x path
of any windows file by right clicking on
the file and then clicking properties
in the file properties first look at the
location which is the path to the file
next add a backslash and then the file
name to the end of the path these
actions will give you the absolute
x-path of that file now next let's see
the relative expert
in the case of relative xpath the path
begins from the middle of the html dom
structure here the structure with a
double slash or double forward slash
that states that the element can be
searched anywhere on the web page
relative xpath enables you to write from
the middle of the html dom structure
without any need to write a long x path
the syntax of the relative xpath looks
like this
a relative path needs to be combined
with another path to access a file
creating a link to an absolute path is
easy since you are pointing to the
file's internet url
if you want to find a specific files
related xpath certain things must be
kept in mind
the file must exist on the same server
as the html file the path to the file
must be relative to the directory of
html file
this is what sums up the two types of
xpaths for us the next topic in this
session is the xpath functions
now the question arises what does the
term xpath function mean there may be
times when locating a particular web
element using general attributes
xpath in selenium provides xpath
functions to write efficient x parts to
discover elements uniquely there are
elements with similar properties like
the same name or the same class name
this is when the simple x-path
strategies are not efficient and then we
need the expat functions
there are three types of xpath functions
the first type is the xpath contains
the xpath contains in selenium is a
function within the xpath expression
used to search for the web elements
containing a particular text it can find
the element with partial text it is used
if the part of the value of any
attribute changes dynamically like login
information etc and here we can see the
syntax of xpath contains function
the contains method accepts two
parameters the attribute of the tag must
validate to locate the web element the
value of an attribute is a partial value
that the attribute must contain
the second type of xpath function is the
xpath text
the xpath text function is a function
used to locate the element on the web
page using the web elements text
it helps to find the exact text element
and it locates the elements within the
set of text nodes
the function proceed worth if the
element contains a text like a label or
etc
so
here we can see the syntax of xpath text
on the screen
the text method here returned the text
of web element when identified by the
tag name and compared with the right
side's value now comes the last type of
xpath function that is the xpath starts
with function
the xpath starts with function is used
to find the element in which the
attribute values start with some
specific character or a sequence of
characters
the function plays a major role while
working with the dynamic web pages
we can also use this method to find
element's worst attribute value is
static that is not changing the syntax
for the starts with function can be seen
on the screen
this starts with accepts two parameters
the attribute of the tag must validate
to locate the web element and the
attribute value is the partial value of
the attribute with which the attribute
is expected to start after the xpath
functions let's move on to our next and
final topic that is the xpath axis
all the xml dom elements are in a
hierarchical structure and can be either
located using absolute path or relative
paths
for this xpath provides a specific
attribute called xpath access
expat access and selenium are methods
used to identify those dynamic elements
that are impossible to find by normal
expat methods such as id class name name
etc
access are shown in because they tell
about the axis on which elements lie
relative to an element
here an axis shows a relationship to the
current node and helps locate the
relative nodes concerning the tree's
current node so the x path axis uses
several nodes to find those nodes in the
dom structure
let's have a look on some access that
help in locating the elements on the web
page
the first expat axis is the ancestor the
ancestor axis selects all ancestor
elements grandparent parent etc of the
current node then comes the ancestor or
self
this axis is used to locate the current
node along with its ancestors along that
comes the attribute axis the attribute
axis are used to specify the attributes
of the current node then comes the child
axis as the name suggests it selects all
the children elements of that current
node the next axis is the descendant
axis
it is used to locate the children of the
current node to the leaf node
then comes the descendant or self access
that is used to locate the current node
with its descendants
after that comes the following axis
which locates all the nodes that come
after the current node now comes the
parent axis that is used to locate the
parent of the current node and at the
last we have this self access
the self access are used to locate
current or the present nodes
there are several other nodes other than
these that we have just seen
there is a preceding axis used to select
all nodes that come before the current
node then a following sibling node that
selects the following siblings of the
context node and siblings are at the
same level as the current node there is
one axis called the parent that selects
the parent of the current node let's get
started what exactly is a chrome driver
now when we are working with selenium so
pretty much we
are going to use that tool for the
automatic test cases for the automation
of the test cases is what the main basis
of the selenium tool here so if you got
a website and uh let's suppose you want
to log in you want to put some
credentials you want to do some
transactions so if this kind of flow you
want to test it out definitely having
some back-end test cases will not help
you on that part because they will not
help you to click on a particular button
put some inputs in the input text so
it's it's more on like a dealing with
the more on the gui perspective so
that's where the selenium chrome driver
or the selenium comes into the picture
where it helps you to drive those test
cases where if you are working on some
kind of gui uh related interface and you
want to test out that application so
this kind of functionality will be
helpful for you and how exactly it goes
on let's talk about the chrome driver
here now chrome driver is a kind of a
component which is available in selenium
like you pretty much use chrome driver
only when you feel like
it's being utilized and at that moment
of time you are working on uh the
specific chrome driver and it gives you
a kind of a content here where you feel
like okay i'm going to use this chrome
driver to see like how the
implementation should be done and how
the automation should be performed over
here so chrome driver specifically helps
you to launches the uh launch the google
chrome browser if you're going to use
firefox if you're going to use internet
explorer then they have their own
specific drivers but this one means like
all your test cases is going to be
executed on the chrome browser so if
your application is compatible with the
chrome browser then this particular
driver makes more sense for you
so it's kind of a driver like uh
definitely this web driver is going to
have all the api calls embedded inside
that which is going to help you to
automate your web applications testing
so
whether you want to go for chrome driver
you want to go for firefox you want to
go for internet explorer it totally
depends on the user and your
application's compatibility if it's
compatible with the chrome you can
pretty much use the chrome driver
without any issues as such here right so
why exactly we need to use a chrome
driver here now when we are using a
chrome driver so it's basically a kind
of main component which is being
utilized by the selenium by the selenium
web driver because selenium requires a
browser plug-in or a browser driver so
that it can send the request so it can
send the request to the chrome and it
can process the request uh if the
selenium web driver is saying like i
want to hit onto some input box i want
to hit onto the summit box so those kind
of requests will be processed by the
chrome driver so for that purpose we
require the chrome driver which will
only send the notifications or the
communications which will be sent out to
the chrome browser with the help of the
selenium web driver here now it's being
used to navigate between web pages so uh
if you want to navigate or if you want
to go from one web page to another web
page so for that also you can use the
chrome browser chrome driver here
so while doing the processing here what
you can do is like you can put the
inputs in the web pages like let's say
like you got a login page so you can put
up a username password you can have the
credentials not only you can provide the
credentials but you can also click on
some button certain buttons like okay
let's click on the login button so if
you want to test out how what will
happen that if automatically you're
going to
click on the login button so how your
application is going to behave so if
this kind of a validation and this kind
of verification if you feel like you
want to do then in that case these
chrome browser will be used by the
selenium to interact now the uh selenium
web driver or the selenium
tool can actually send the request and
all these requests will be processed by
the chrome dropper so ultimately it's a
chrome browser where you will see the
end results like the website is getting
navigated the browser is getting closed
automatically the browser is getting
started or initialized automatically
here so all that activity is going to be
done by the chrome driver which will
intake all the specific requests from
the selenium web driver here now let's
see like how we can uh set up a chrome
driver for this one you require a chrome
like a chrome browser unique wire
whatever the platform you're using
chrome is pretty much installed there if
you already got a chrome browser
installed all you need to do is like you
need to get a browser uh exe
path over there so that you can
configure that into your
specific uh source code here so as a
chrome driver in the configurations for
that you can put okay this so-and-so
location we have the exe file present
there and the source code can actually
use it to launch the
chrome browser and do whatever the
activities he want to perform on there
as such
right so let's see like how we can set
up the chrome browser uh and the chrome
driver over here so that we can run some
couple of selenium test cases now for
the chrome driver uh demonstration over
here we require four things one the
jtech installation the jre which can be
installed from the oracle we already got
the jdk installed into our system and
eclipse also installed into our system
so these two pre requests is already
being done now chrome browser is
something which is also available over
here we already got the chrome browser
embedded inside this machine so the only
thing which is left out is the selenium
here because pretty much though the uh
jdk
uh eclipse and chrome browser you will
already be having it there on to your
development machines or into your
personal machines if you're already
dealing with the uh disk with the java
programming source code so you already
have these things available there but
even if you don't have these things we
can easily download those things and
configure into our machine so that we
can start using that one right so we
have the respective links over here
eclipse is pretty easy to download just
download the zip file or exe file
eclipse will be installed and you can
start using it and in order to make the
eclipse work first you have to do the
installation of the uh jdk or uh you
know the java which you want to install
so that that's what you require here
right so let's open the selenium uh
browser here so i'm going to click on
this button here so this will help me to
open the selenium
website selenium.dev is the website
which is available there which can help
us to see like how we can go ahead with
this uh particular selenium download
here so we are going to download the
selenium here and then we are going to
utilize that uh selenium over here in
this one to process it so this is the
selenium which we got this is the
website now here if you go to the
downloads like first of all you got web
driver ide selenium gate these are the
different components which is there now
if you go to the downloads button
so here you will be able to see like all
the downloads which is available there
like the browser or if you want to see
like the web driver if you want to
install so these are the different uh
programming languages integrations which
is available there
right so you can see like how the
executions uh even if for the c sharp
you have this one here so you also got
the selenium id which is available there
so all these different components are
available which you can see which is
easy for you to integrate for the
selenium here
right now since we are going to uh use
it for the java so we have got like uh
the specific version over here three
point one point uh for
141.59 here so this is something which
we can use and uh you can also go for
the beta version also but i want to
download the uh stable version over here
you can go for the vito download also
right whatever version you feel so let's
go for the download option over here so
this will basically help me to download
a specific file as a file over here now
this zip file is something which is uh
going to have all the
required values and attributes which is
available there so let's see like what
exactly is available in this file so
this is kind of a selenium which we are
downloading and this is what we are
going to use in the clips also so in the
eclipse we will be using this stuff so
that we can utilize it
so let's open this one here
okay now you got this uh specific
library files these are the different
library files which is a required over
here you can say like as in dependencies
and these are the ones which is
available there these are the uh
executables like you can say like these
will help you to run any kind of
selenium test cases so all you require
to do is like you can just indicate
these ones into your class path while
running your uh eclipse project you can
add these ones to the build path there
and this will surely work for you
these are the requirements like these
are the predictors which is required in
the eclipse so that you can proceed
further with this one if these are not
there then it's going to show you the
compilations error so first we'll try to
put up the code base there and see that
what kind of error comes in and then
later on we'll see like how we can
resolve those errors as a chair so let's
go to the eclipse right now what we
really need to do is like we need to
create a new java project and uh create
a new class so that's what we need to do
and in that case uh we have to configure
the build path but i'm not
going to add the external jars as of now
to put that class bar there so what i'm
going to do is like i'm going to first
see there that how i can do that
installation so i i'm going to copy this
code here because this is what i'm going
to put up into my a specific class so
whatever the name of the class you can
give so here we are using in the code
base as in the get started here so the
same class name we can use so that we
don't get any kind of issues
so let me copy this content
also uh provided like uh the driver the
chrome is already installed here so we
don't require so you can see here that
we are giving the path of the chrome
driver in case of linux platform when
you're trying to deploy it like when
you're trying to put it up right there
so in that case probably you have to do
the installation like you have to
download the chrome driver for the linux
platform but here it's pretty much like
you can simply use it or you can get it
uh uh done because already the windows
platform we are using it so we are
launching the eclipse here so
uh in this one we will be creating a
quickly a class over here in this one or
kind of a project so that we will be
able to proceed further with that
so we're going to create an empty
project here in this case
so we got the uh specific eclipse opened
so we can go for a new java project here
so i can say it like selenium so we can
give any project name here
and we can say it like finish so there
will be some basic structure which is
available there so i'm going to quickly
create a specific
file like a class file here
now these are the java files which is
available like white from the jdk but uh
we can easily go to the build path and
we can add the external charts but we
are not going to do that now we are
going to first see like whatever we are
going to get so i'm going to create a
class here like a simple class so
getting uh
started is a class which i'm going to
create here because that's the one which
is available into my content of the
class file so you can uh you know if you
feel like you don't want to use the same
name like this one so you want to use
some different names so you can easily
do a rename so that can be easily done
there now here the since like the
imports is something which is coming up
like this is not uh something which is
coming up over here like it's not
getting resolved because of the fact
that uh we are pretty much using uh the
uh specific open uh the selenium jar
files the jr files but it's not getting
that it's not showing that output here
so let's see like uh let's open the uh
specific downloads window here so from
where we can access these jar files and
we can refer it so we got this one so
let's extract this completely
uh you can put these uh for jar files in
any other locations if you feel like you
want to refer that so uh you can keep
put up into the default location of the
eclipse also if you feel like this is
getting referenced
pretty much frequently and there are a
lot of projects which you are working so
in that case you can have it into a
small folder or directly import it into
the eclipse itself so
here i'm just doing a one-time activity
so let's
uh use this downloads folder itself from
where we can simply import these
jar files here so these are the jar
files which is available there in the
libraries we also got like an additional
jar file which is available right so uh
we can go ahead with that part here so
these are the different libraries which
is available and these again the
libraries so let's
you know change the build path here so
we'll go for the build path here
and uh we'll say like uh we can add the
libraries here now libraries is
something which we want to sorry we want
to edit the build path here
so here we're going to talk about the
external libraries like you know the
libraries which is available there which
we want to put up into this one so we
can say like add external jars
so now we can go for the downloads
button here and here we can put up this
jar file here now we also got a sources
one a sources jar file which is also
available there but what we have done is
like we have added only the executable
ones because sources ones and executable
ones is this is just the same the only
thing is that the sources one will have
the source code also we don't require
that as such
then lastly we comes up with the junit
one then of course like a junit uh you
know is also being referenced here so
for that we don't have to download the
jjured one because most of the eclipse
browsers are already having the
libraries integrated so all you need to
do is like you need to click on the add
library here and we already got the j
unit in this one so we don't have to
really go anywhere there because it's a
part of the plug-in of the eclipse that
it's already integrated there in case of
selenium you went for the add external
jar files and you added the jar file
there but not in this case in june it
will be automatically referenced because
of the fact that we are using it on over
here in this case
right so these are the two references
like junit also we reference it because
we are running some genuine test cases
here so which is like already a part of
the plugins here in the eclipse yes if
you put the plugin of the selenium and
you integrate in the same way then also
you don't have to go for this
third-party references but it's okay
like you can reference it there and
you know any project of selenium can
work now because you got the basic
executables required for that so that
that's how it it works on there
right now we also have got like a
certain other jar files which is uh
which needs to be added up over there
now those were not uh something which we
added because right now we just resolve
the issues related to the uh selenium
but uh these selenium executables may
also have some other dependencies so for
that what you need to do is like you
need to add and another uh folder like
uh you know another folder over here
which is like lib here so these jar
files will also coming up over here
because your code bases may be available
or maybe depending on these ones
so these are the exact uh you know
because your selenium may be depending
on these jar files there so that's also
we are going to add up over here so not
only the client combined jar file but
other dependent jar files also is going
to be there into the reference libraries
here right now let's find out the
executable path of the chrome browser
here so i'm going to open the uh c drive
here because in that case we will be
having the chrome browser installed so
it's a standard location where you will
be able to see your uh particular chrome
application exe file here so uh pretty
much this is the directory structure
which is available there like in this
one
it will be installed there so um you can
get the same information from the chrome
shortcut or the from a chrome
icon also that where exactly this exe
file is referenced and if any difference
is there so you can do that now this is
a directory like this is the exe file
which is available there
so i'm going to just put that one over
here in this one
right so this is the way uh we are going
to put up the paths here in this ones
like how the uh path should be
referenced should be executed over here
and uh ultimately uh this is required
because definitely when we are going to
run the test cases uh this chrome
browser will be sent the notifications
to opening
www.google.com here and it's going to uh
wait over there on that part and uh it's
going to search the specific keyword
over here called chrome driver
so this is what it's this program this
basic program is going to perform here
so now let's run the chrome browser here
so uh we're not going to run the chrome
browser but ultimately the junit test
cases so you right click over here and
say run as junit test cases and this
will ultimately help you to launch a
chrome browser now i have not triggered
it manually uh i have got it like
automatically over here and you can see
like the cursor is going to blink
because it's basically waiting for the
selenium to put up the inputs and all
now if you have the test case executed
like you open this website go to this
website click on this and click on that
so according to that your browser will
start behaving without any interaction
from the human there now this is a kind
of a functionality which we will get
with the selenium and this makes easy
for us like if we
want to validate or if we want to go
through any kind of web application
waste testing this is the ultimate way
like how we can go for that
verifications right so this is what we
have in this demo where we can see like
how the automatically we can do the
chrome browser we can interact with
chrome browser right from the selenium
over here so let's go back to the main
content right so that was the way that
how we can configure the chrome driver
with the selenium here so that we can
invoke chrome browsers and when then we
can according to the statements we can
start sending the request
so that's uh pretty much which is there
now the various uh activities which we
did in this case was the jdk
installation uh eclipse selenium chrome
browser now chrome browser ide and jdk
is pretty easy to download and you can
configure it and uh that that's the way
that how we can set up the chrome
browser the main important thing is like
how to download the selenium and refer
it into your projects okay so that you
can start using the selenium over here
now we will come to various annotations
this change you will be going to talk
about test engine out today what is
distinction let's talk about that
existing
next generation this is the full form of
this ng what is test engine so first of
all prestige is a unit testing framework
or i would say java unit basic framework
very specific to java there are two most
popular united states framework one is j
unit and one is distance these are the
two the distinct framework for java and
uh if i talk about jna j in it
it's
used a lot by developers
so developer use this particular
framework a lot for the unit testing
purpose and when i talk about test ng
testing g it is used
a lot by
testers
why there's a discrimination between
these two frameworks then
okay what happens is uh you know
developers are keep on using unit from
quite a long time and they don't want to
switch to the new one
that's only the thing which i feel is
they are using jlit
however if i talk about testing g
testing g is
having
more annotations
compared to
j unit
it's having more annotations means more
functionalities
let's let me write it here more
the latest version of junit is is
jonathan
for testing g
it is actually
six point that one is the latest version
of testing gm for your junit as it's the
fourth version
for jnet there is a new version coming
up that is called s5 and it may be
possible that that will be more advanced
or more not more advanced but that will
be equivalent to testing g because i
have seen as an introduction
that it is having functionality similar
to distance
so now then we won't be able to say that
testing g or sorry j unit is behind test
engine but as of now yes it is
in test ng if i talk about we'll be
going through
some annotations these annotations helps
us to make our test
more reusable easily
maintainable
okay
if you
get stuck at any point of time you can
go to the documentation of this engine
you will find each and everything
clear and very easily defined so test ng
uh documentation is very good so i would
suggest whenever you get time you can go
through with it but most of the 70
percent of the test ng functionality is
what we are going to take a look okay
because they
are very helpful when we talk about test
ng we always talk about view and
notation efficient
when we talk about annotation what
annotation is can anyone tell me what
annotation is
let me create a package here
so actually testng learning testing is
very interesting thing
we are creating a class and we are
saying
it as
login test cases
you see here
verify
with valid
credentials
verify with invalid credentials
verify
um
suppose if you have any other test cases
well let's let me just think
if you can tell me one test case of
login
one is with valid credential one is with
invalid credentials you can expand it as
much as you want
you but
please verify it with
with no credentials as well correct
or we can say verify with special
characters
sql
injection
so there can be multiple methods correct
guys have you observed at any point of
time
whenever you are working on java if you
have written any programs or anything
like that have you observed
there is one annotation comes up there
is one line comes up that is at the rate
override
sometimes at the rate
surprise warnings
any one of you have have you ever seen
this kind of statement
no one it seems
okay
we also get
deprecated
okay
so
let me come back from that so
whatever you write on top of your method
with enterate sign
and anything post that
that will be considered as an annotation
on top of a method on top of it to pass
anywhere
okay these are called as annotations
and it can be anything i will say at the
rate is i so it's not what you will
define
this is
what you will say any name to it
no
these are the annotations which are
being provided by test ng
and every
thing whatever you will be going to
define here
has some functionality attached to it
so it's not that it is just for the name
purpose
it will be going to add up some
functionalities
okay
that's the thing
but okay
let's find
[Music]
so whenever i am talking about
annotation i am talking about
few things which i am going to add on
top of methods or on top of the class
okay
and they actually place an important
role in your particular class or in your
methods
before i tell you about annotations
that what all annotations do we have in
test ng
let me tell you how you are going to
download this test engine
first of all when i said junit jr note
is a pre-installed
jam it is pre-installed in eclipse but
test ng is not
if you have to download this then just
go to
help
eclipse marketplace
wait for it to
move up
right here
they're changing
and defined okay this will hang
just let it come
here test ng and search for it
so to install it you right uh you go to
help eclipse marketplace
and inside that you mention
destiny when you get the test change you
will see here testing g for eclipse just
click on install this is how install
button will look like click on that and
install sng and done
testing g will be installed in your
system
okay
now let's talk about few annotations in
test ng we are talking about annotations
from quite a long time now
let's write some annotations
enter it
before
sweet enter it before test
at the rate before
class
and the date before
method
enter it
test
it
after method
enter it
after
class
enter it
after test
after shoot
enter it before
group
and the rate
after group
iterate
data
provider
and and and let's just think if i have
entered it
parameter
okay
so these are the annotations what we
have in test ng
so here what it says score of the driver
automation framework without proper
design your test may look like the image
below
if you don't
think and you know without any design
you may end up by saying login test
product test add to cart test checkout
test checkout test payment checkout test
shipment payment test and pigmentation
etc
it may be possible that the things which
you are using here might
can be used in product test as well it
might be possible that whatever the
things which you are doing here can be
used in add to part as well
so these
are the things which
we are going to use now like this
this
so with page object you are creating one
object for sign in page product list one
object part one object shipment one
object payment one object order one
object
when you are using the log and test when
you are creating select product test it
might be using
sign in page objects as well as product
list object so it may be possible like i
have shown you just now in the trivago
in that we were using multiple pages
multiple page objects and we were coming
up with the
test case
and that's what it is showing us in a
form for diagram if you want you can go
through with that but this is how we are
going to
write our
automation framework and that's what it
states consideration whenever you create
page object design always consider these
few things
always create a class for every web page
create a class for every web page
webpage elements web page elements are
instance variables off page with a class
of type web element so what it's saying
that whatever the elements you will be
going to write in that are always
instance
or always instance variable
we will be going to do that service page
would include
sign in page active cart
which becomes a method in page object
class
so there will be services pages where
you may see sign in page add to cart
page add to cart query functionality
or methods i will say
and then at the last we have written in
text you create object of page request
and call the methods so let's go
with these more slides there are we'll
go through that and we'll see design
pattern test does not have any technical
code to communicate with deal with the
browser so test will not have any
technical code okay make sure that
whatever you are writing technically you
will be writing in the
pages test call page objects and verify
the result test is more readable like i
have shown you it was more readable form
test object do not verify page load we
don't verify whether the page is loaded
or not okay but they communicate with
the browser these are the syntaxes what
you have mentioned here if you see here
they are using
weight dot until no that is again also a
method so you can ignore it again
okay let's just take a look at this
because all these syntaxes is what we
are going to see
after the break but let's take a look
these are the best practices one can
follow to make design robust and
maintainable
create one page object class for each
web page
web page okay we'll be doing that
each page object method should either
return the object on that page or should
return the page object of the next page
so we'll see it is this is what we call
as in the name of language linking
between the classes
linking between the classes each page
object should sell self validate whether
the page is fully loaded before giving
control to the next step any data used
by the page object should be passed to
test and should not be hard coded so now
will not be hard coding anything
and that's what here it is showing us a
very small example with the page check
bmi calculator and the test and here
again
but
let me just create
an architecture of the framework
and then we will
see
all the things will be going to execute
this is my test
i'll be going to create few packages
inside it and i'll be going to tell you
about each package everyone has a
different way to define it
and this is how i always define
some people say it as page package but i
call it as core package
the score package in this four package
i'll be going to initialize all my
elements
in this
this is the heart of the package
if something goes wrong in this package
in this whatever i will define in this
package if something goes wrong in that
nothing will get executed nothing will
be executed
second package
this is the package i am going to call
it as pages
pages is here we'll be going to create
all our pages
means all
are classes for web pages
so all the pages are maintained right
here
another package
we'll call it as
test cases
here i'm keeping all my test cases
another package
util
here i i'll be keeping all my utilities
under package
config
here i'll be keeping all my
configuration pipes
another package
logs
here i'll be generating all my logs
related to my project
a new folder
let's do one thing instead of creating a
folder let's use utilize this resources
and let's put here
one folder by the name of
drivers
so all our firefox chrome ie drivers
will be placed at this location
one more folder
test data
excel sheet or whatever trace data you
are using you'll be putting your test
data right at this location
one more folder
screenshots
it's at the
project level so all the screenshots
will be maintained in this folder
and this is the architecture of my
framework which will i'll be going to
create
let's take up one more concept that is
first principles and srp let's see that
what it is so first principle structures
the test creation and create value of
the best suits not all the first
principle can be followed in ui testing
use first principle as a long term guide
to maintain a
test suit let's see that what all those
five principles are fast
isolated independent
repeatable self validating
throw time so your test whatever the
test you are writing it should be fast
enough so
that's why we always discuss that void
use of thread
pick up one more
concept that is first principles and srp
let's see that what it is so first
principle structures the test creation
and create value of the test suits not
all the first principle can be followed
in ui testing use first principle as a
long term guide to maintain a
test suit let's see that what all those
five principles are fast
isolated independent
repeatable
self validating
through timely so your test whatever the
test you are writing it should be fast
enough so
that's why we always discuss that avoid
use of thread dot e
what explicit weight put implicit weight
else you may be spending a lot of extra
time so better avoid this
isolated independent
minimize dependency between tests as far
as possible
so there shouldn't be dependent uh your
test cases should not be dependent on
each other because if one fails it may
be possible the other one will not run
in that case
okay don't make your test case dependent
on each other as much as possible and
also in your test case
insert at least verification of course
you will be having that verification
because that's a
requirement repeatable
configured test so that re-running the
test always give consistent result we
have to keep now our test
cases separately in different different
methods so that if even if we rerun it
won't impact
the results and of course it will not
impact and it actually does not apply to
the service here validating while
writing the test you should automate
decision
as automation
suits run without human intervention
don't assume any human intervention so
always whenever you are creating
your framework your test scripts
don't think that you will be providing
some input to it
never ever give any input to your test
cases to your
uh automation pack make it in such a way
that it can be freely or it can be run
in your absence as well so what you will
do you will schedule it at three am in
the night and it will run and it will
give you the results you'll have to make
your test in such a way
not that that it requires your input
like verification here we are saying you
should automate verification you know so
when you are opening up a website you
should verify whether it has actually
opened or not
that is actually opening that particular
url or going to that url it is going to
some other different url
need to verify all these things
thoroughly uh borrow timely this is
applicable to request this list should
be through in terms of coverage so when
i say in the terms of coverage you know
guys
what happens in unit test cases in unit
testing
we
write code okay
selenium also we write code and in code
we write some variables we create some
methods some extra methods some extra
line of code as well but if we write
some extra line of code that means
if your graph will then sponsor program
will get executed execution time will be
more correct if you are adding some more
things if you are using objects which
are not being used anywhere if you are
creating objects which are not generally
here if you are creating variables which
are not being used anywhere so of course
java while executing java will take care
of them and will see them
correct we'll go through through those
steps
which is of no use actually in your
scripts
so here in terms of coverage what it
means is you should get the code
coverage that you have written hundred
percent of your you know you have
written your complete code but actually
how much percent is being used
fifty percent sixty percent seventy
percent so there are some code coverage
tools
which you can use and can see that
actually
how much code is being used
so when you write your script it may be
possible that the
50 percent of the script is only useful
50 is you know it's completely not is of
no use
so when you get the coverage code
coverage report you can see that which
one is of no use and you can remove
those extra lines
that's the benefit of code properties
and it is applicable of unit test it is
applicable in selenium as well
running or executing softwares or
applications with the aim of finding out
errors or bugs in the developed
application is called software testing
selenium and qtp are two software
testing tools used widely in the current
software industry
let's do a comparison between these two
testing tools in this video
in this session
we will be going through what is
selenium what is qtp
then we'll have a comparison between
selenium and qtp
we'll then try to understand why one
should shift to selenium
and finally how to migrate from qtp to
selenium
so
what do you mean by selenium to put it
in simple terms selenium is an open
source testing program for web-based
applications spread across different
platforms and browsers
selenium is a set of four components
that are usually required at the time of
software testing
they are
selenium integrated development
environment or ide
this is a web browser add-on that
creates tests very quickly through its
record and playback functionality
depreciated selenium remote control rc
this is a test tool that allows you to
write automated web application ui tests
in any programming language against any
http website using any mainstream
javascript enabled browser webdriver
this is used for cross browser testing
and selenium grid this is used for cross
platform testing so what is qtp
qtp is a testing tool developed by
havelet packard
it stands for quick test professional
identifying errors problems or gaps with
respect to the expected results of any
software that is being tested are the
functions of the hpqtp
vbscript is used by qtp for automation
purposes and it need not be installed
separately as it comes along with the
windows os
the latest version of qtp is called uft
and it is a combination of hpqtp and hp
service test
hudsons and jenkins are two open source
continuous integration system that is
supported by uft
it also provides support for mobile
testing
uft mobile support allows to create
agnostic scripts that is scripts
compliant with for all mobile platforms
this script developed in ios can also be
run on android let us now have a
comparison between hp qtp and selenium
hpqtp is a famous tool in the market of
web-based testing but with the dawn of
selenium's popularity and its ability to
do more than qtp ever could has made it
a worthy competitor
these are quite a few straightforward
differences between qtp and selenium
that might help people choose between
the two
qtp is used commercially and hence it
requires license while selenium is an
open source tool and is free for
everyone to use
qtp can be used to test both web paste
and desktop application
while selenium can only come in handy
while testing web-based applications
only qtp ide can be used while doing qtp
test
while in case of selenium tests multiple
ides can be used like netbeans visual
studio eclipse
qtp can only support vb scripts while
selenium supports multiple programming
languages like dotnet ruby perl php java
javascript etc qtp supports multiple
types of dialog box while selenium can
only support dialog box partially
developing time is high in selenium than
qtp
authentication windows can be automated
in uft whereas in selenium we have to
use auto id or use
robot class in java
qtp has a very good official technical
support while selenium has community
technical support
qtp is comparatively more user friendly
and the scripts can be developed in a
short time on the other hand selenium
has less functionality as it is low
level and the scripts take up more time
to come and to be maintained
hp uft is a tool used to integrate qtp
on the other hand selenium does not have
any tool used for integration
speaking of execution qtp can test one
application per machine whereas selenium
can execute multiple tests on a machine
at the same time moreover selenium takes
lesser cpu and ram power in the time of
execution as compared to qtp
so why should one then shift to selenium
a slight modification in the code has to
be tested to make sure that the code is
running fine and fulfilling the target
now repeating the tests again and again
can get costly the high portability of
selenium allows the automation engineers
to write codes without worrying about
the os
the testing is ideally kept
self-contained within the program and
they can be modified as desired this
approach makes sure that any change in
quotes does not increase the development
and improves maintainability
the flexibility offered by selenium
allows coders to manage tests better
since selenium is open source users can
extend share and modify codes thus
saving a great deal of time and effort
for the programmers
so how to migrate from qtp to selenium
choose the script language keeping the
team's experience and the relevant kind
of automation framework in mind
put off building frameworks and write
simple selenium scripts in the beginning
keep tracks of the issue that come up
with time and make use of the solutions
to build larger test suites in future
once comfortable with selenium start
discovering tools that can be used with
selenium for example maven test ng etc
selenium jobs and salary a very
interesting topic so the market trends
for test automation are continuously
changing and selenium has seen an
exponential growth in a very short time
period this selenium makes it convenient
for clients to receive an roi much
faster and how does that happen by
reducing the number of test cycles
involved in testing their product in
present scenario selenium is a perfect
automation for any of your web web
application testing and automated web
application testing and it is the first
choice of your automation tester as well
as the companies also so as the
softwares are becoming more and more
complex so is the test automation and
selenium is a key skill set for any test
automation engineer to have but of
course it's not the only skill set one
needs to have so if you look at a
typical job description here so gone are
the days when the engineers were hired
as a manual tester every company today
wants to hire engineers who knows how to
do automation and since selenium is the
most popular web application automation
tool companies look specifically for
selenium automation engineers and this
is the typical job description of any
automation engineer to develop test
cases to detect bugs and errors
automation framework designing it's not
just about automating your test cases
one should have the ability to design
the complete framework related to the
project to improve and automate test
practices to participate in
communicating best practices defining
test strategy test manuals for tracking
and fixing your software issues let's
look at the compensation part of it so
compensation varies from company to
company and it also depends on your
experience level so according to the
stacks if you look at the us market it
can vary anywhere from 21 000 to one
fifty thousand dollars average could be
of course somewhere around ninety
thousand dollars and if you look at the
indian market range it ranges anywhere
from two to ten lakhs per annum for a
startup with an average of five lakhs so
the more and more you're going to get
experience the better is going to be a
compensation package and the market has
always been very lucrative for
automation engineers so since selenium
is so powerful web auto mission tools
there are some of the top end companies
who use selenium in their various
project they want to provide their
customers the best quality software and
help them reduce the time to market and
hence they going for selenium so a lot
of these companies have selenium
deployments in this video we will look
at most commonly asked questions in the
interview and some guidelines on how to
answer them nowadays automation tool and
especially the selenium skills is a very
key requirement for an qa engineer or
even an automation engineer jobs so if
you're on the outlook of automation
engineer or a qa engineer positions i'm
sure this question bank will definitely
help you prepare for your interview so
this video consists of three parts
basically three different levels of set
of questions one is the beginner level
second is the intermediate level and
then the advanced level questions and
each level has a set of 10 most probable
questions which you might be asked in
the interview so let's begin with the
beginner level questions
question 1 what are selenium suite
components so selenium is a set of tools
and libraries to facilitate automation
on web applications you already know
this it is not a single tool so what are
those components which are comprised in
the selenium so selenium comes with four
major components the first one is the id
id happens to be the most simplest tool
in the whole suite of selenium it is
nothing but an integrated development
environment which has a record and
playback functionality this was earlier
available as only firefox plugin however
you need to know that the new version of
selenium ide is available as a chrome
extension as well as a firefox plugin so
that means you can either use any of the
browsers that is firefox or the chrome
for recording your test scripts also you
should also know that the new id comes
with many new features and
now this new ide has become more
powerful than what was available earlier
so some of these new features are like
reusability of your test cases it comes
with a better debugger now and most
importantly it supports parallel test
execution and how does it do that it has
a utility called selenium side runner
that's about selenium id the next
component is the selenium remote control
so selenium remote control or popularly
called as selenium rc is used to write
web application test in different
programming languages it supports
multiple programming languages like java
c
python rupee and php it is nothing but
it's a server which interacts with your
browser using a simple http get and post
request for communication selenium rc is
also called as selenium 1.0 version or
selenium core third component selenium
webdriver it is a programming interface
to run your test cases and webdriver was
introduced by simon stewart in 2006 and
this was introduced to overcome some of
the limitations of selenium rc so rc's
architecture was very complex because it
required an eddie